SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
THE COPING NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
WHAT'S WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES. TODAY
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. ALL MEMBERS
WHO ARE. ATTENDING ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE ROOM HOW TO
ASK THE CONSULTANT TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH.
SENATORS PARTICIPATING. EGGMAN
MELENDEZ AM HERE DO WE NOTED
SENATORS EGGMAN AND PAN ARE IN
ATTENDANCE THIS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR THOSE ARE REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MAKE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING THE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND IN TIME
YOU WANT TO BE RECOGNIZE USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING AND THE I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL. DIRECT YOU FROM THERE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ARE BEST
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALSWISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE. NO NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE FIVE THREE ONE
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO OUR SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL REMOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT WHAT
YOU'RE ON ABOUT YOU WILL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU MAY BEGIN WE WILL
BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU AND WILL YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE. TO MAKE YOUR
REMARKS IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH
TIME FOR YOU CAN ALWAYS CONTACT
THE SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE AT A
LATER DATE WE WILL WE WELCOME
YOUR COMMENTS. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL REVIEW PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS ACROSS ALL
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES IN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE ASKING
THE L. A. O. TO READ INTO THE
RECORD THE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT RECEIVED BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AFTER THE L. A. O.
HAS CONCLUDED THE PRESENTATION.
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THE OF FINANCE. THE SUB.
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. TO OUR ABILITY TO
INQUIRE ABOUT THOSE PROPOSALS
WITH ADMINISTRATION WILL HAVE TO
OCCUR IN ANOTHER VENUE AT A
LATER TIME- THIRTEEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS. YEAH
I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY SAY AGAIN
I APPRECIATE ALL THE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS WHICH I UNDERSTAND THE
ONLY A WILL BE- READING TODAY-
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM- FROM SPONSORS SAYS SO WE
GO THROUGH THE BUDGET. PROCESS
SO- AGAIN OF THE PRESHEAF THE
PROPOSALS AND LOOK FORWARD TO BE
ABLE TO DIG INTO THEM THOUGH
MORE AND IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR PAN
OKAY HELLO ARE YOU READY TO GO
WARNING THIS PRODUCT NICE TO SEE
YOU. NICE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTER PAN AM
SON YOU'VE HAD IT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND I JUST READER RE ITERATES WE
WERE ASKED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO READ THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS
AND- CONSEQUENTLY THEY DO THEY
ARE NOT ILIO RECOMMENDATIONS. IN
ADDITION WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL'S HOWEVER IF YOU DO
HAVE QUESTIONS WE ARE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE ORGANIZATION
PROPOSING AUGMENTATION AND GET
BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. SO
WITH THAT I WILL BEGIN FIRST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY- THERE SIX
PROPOSALS THAT. WOULD FALL UNDER
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.THE FIRST IS ARE FROM
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AGENCY CONCERNING
ENHANCE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM. THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AGENCY
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
THIRTY OF THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TO
ENHANCE THE CONTINUUM OF CARE TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNSHELTERED.
INCLUDING ST HEALTH TEAMS A NEW
WELLNESS RESPITE SITE. CLINICAL
AND HOUSING NAVIGATION SERVICES
AND THIRTY NINE NEWLY BUILT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL IS A HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL AND SAFETY
NET PRACTICES. THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATES CAL THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES ALREADY OF SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FIVE YEARS TO PROVIDE SMALL AND
SAFETYNET PRACTICES WITH THREE
SERVICES INTENDED TO SUPPORT
THEIR TRANSITION. TO ACTIVELY
EXCHANGING DATA. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES AND SUBSIDIZED
INTERFACES. THE THIRD PROPOSAL
IS SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
QUALITY STANDARDS BOARD. SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
CALIFORNIA REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
ESTABLISH THE QUALITY STANDARDS
BOARD FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES TO SET SPECIFIC
STANDARDS RELATING TO WORKING
CONDITIONS WAGES TRAINING HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND USE OF FUNDS WELL
GIVING STATE AND THE WORKERS A
VOICE IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. THE FOR THE PROPOSAL IS
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS LINE LONG TERM
PLANNING AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
. THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
THE KENNEDY FORUM REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THIRTY
OF EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
ESTABLISH A TELEPHONE SURCHARGE
TO FUND THE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
SYSTEM AND TO PUT IN PLACE A
STATEWIDE PLANNING PROCESS
INCLUDING APPOINTING A NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT CRISIS SERVICES
DIRECTOR. TO PROVIDE DIRECTION
AND OVERSIGHT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF OVER NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT AND FACILITY AND
FACILITATE STATEWIDE NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLANNING. THE FIFTH
PROPOSAL IS A STUDY TO CREATE A
RIGHT TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE. THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
ALREADY A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
COMMISSION A STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THAT
PROVIDES RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
TO CREATE A RIGHT. TO THE FULL
RANGE OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
NECESSARY FOR PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL. ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS TO RECOVER AND THRIVE
. THE SIX THE PROPOSAL IS LOCAL
ACCOUNTABLE COMMUNITIES FOR
HEALTH. THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INITIATIVE REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THIRTY
OF FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
EXPAND AND SCALE THE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMUNITIES FOR
HEALTH MODEL TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES IN SUCCESSFULLY
ACHIEVING THESTATE'S GOALS AND
IDENTIFYING AND WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS TO ADVANCE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. THE NEXT TO PROPOSALS
WOULD FALL UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FACILITIES FINANCING
AUTHORITY. THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS
SPECIAL NEEDS DENTISTRY
EXPANSION. THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE OF THIRTY A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. DEVELOPMENT OF PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
DENTISTRY CLINICS THREE GRANT
PROGRAM FACILITATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS A DISTRICT HOSPITAL
BRIDGE LOAN. THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
OF THIRTY OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
TO SUPPORT BRIDGE LOANS TO
THIRTY THREE DISTRICT AND
MUNICIPAL HOSPITALS TO ALLEVIATE
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
NEXT TWELVE PROPOSALS WOULD FALL
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION. THE
FIRST IS A CLINICAL LABORATORY
SCIENTIST AND MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNICIAN INTERNSHIPS. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MEDICAL LAB TECHNOLOGY REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
ALREADY OF TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO SUPPORT GRANT
FUNDING TO HOSPITALS OR TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
CREDENTIAL TO TRAIN CLINICAL
LABORATORY SCIENTISTS. AND
MEDICAL LABORATORY TECHNICIANS
TO CREATE TWO HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
TRAINING POSITIONS TO ADDRESS A
SHORTAGE OF CLINICAL LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS AND MEDICAL
LABORATORY TECHNICIAN POSITIONS
AND REQUIRE TRAINING INTERNSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS A LICENSED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THREE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING ONE. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOAN
FORGIVENESS FOR STUDENTS WORKING
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND
NONPROFIT AGENCIES TO. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLINICAL STUDY BILLIONS FOR
NONPROFIT AGENCIES AND
FACILITIES TO INCREASE FLIGHTS
FOR PRE LICENSEES TO OBTAIN
CLINICAL HOURS. AND THREE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR MASTER'S LEVEL
STUDENTS SEEKING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RELATED DEGREES. THE
THIRD PROPOSAL IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO CREATE A
DEDICATED LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORK FORCE. BEFORE THE PROPOSAL
IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY A FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. ONE TEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM. TO SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE ALLIED
HEALTH LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
THREE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ALLIED HEALTH
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NURSE PRACTITIONER
FELLOWSHIP SLOGS THROUGH THE
SONG BROWN HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAM. FIVE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT FELLOWSHIP SLOTS THREE
SONG BROWN AND SIX FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TEACHING HEALTH CENTERS THROUGH
SONG BROWN. THE PROPOSAL IS
CALIFORNIA ABORTION SUPPORT
FUNDS. ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO
SUPPORT IT CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE ABORTION SUPPORT FUND
TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO ABORTION CARE
REGARDLESS OF THE DECISION MADE
BY THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT. AND THAT THE CARE IS X.
IS ACCESSIBLE AND PRACTICAL FOR
ANYONE SEEKING ABORTION CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SIX PROPOSAL
PROPOSAL IS THE CALIFORNIA
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM. ASCENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH
ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
NARAL PRO PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
M. PLANNED PARENTHOOD REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THIRTY
OF NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. TO CREATE AND FUND
AN UNCOMPENSATED CARE PROGRAM TO
REIMBURSE ABORTION PROVIDERS FOR
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT OTHER MEANS
OF PAYING FOR CARE. INCLUDING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TRAVELLING
FROM OUT OF STATE WHO WOULD HAVE
QUALIFIED FOR MEDICARE ALL OR
THE MEDICAL ACCESS PROGRAM BUT
FOR THE PROGRAM'S RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS. THE SEVEN PROPOSAL
IS SCHOLARSHIP FOR ADDICTION
MEDICINE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER
TRAINING IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA REQUEST
EXPENDITURES ALREADY FROM THE
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUND OF
THIRTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR A NEW WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM. PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
TRAINING AND EDUCATION IN
ADDICTION MEDICINE. A ONE YEAR
FELLOWSHIP AT UC IRVINE FOR
PRIMARY CARE AND EMERGENCY ROOM
ORIENTED TRAINEES AND PROVIDERS
INTERESTED IN ADVANCED TRAINING
IN SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
OPIOID MANAGEMENT. THE PROPOSAL
IS SCHOLARSHIPS FOR HEALTH AND
WELLNESS COACH TRAINING FOR
UNDERSERVED AREAS. PSYCHIATRIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT SCHOLARSHIPS FOR A NEW
UC IRVINE WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR HEALTH AND WELLNESS
COACHES WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRAINING. TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE RECEIVED THE PRIMARY
CARE TRAINING AND EDUCATION IN
ADDICTION MEDICINE FELLOWSHIPS-
TONIGHT PROPOSAL IS INVESTING IN
PRIMARY CARE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
THIRTY OF WENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THREE
TO SUPPORT INCREASED GRANT
FUNDING AWARDED TO PRIMARY CARE
AND FAMILY MEDICINE GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS. THE
PROPOSAL IS HEALTH IT WORKFORCE
RECRUITMENT AND TRAINING FOR
CLINICS IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA TELL.
THE CALIFORNIA TELEHEALTH
NETWORK AND- CHEN BECAUSE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THIRTY
OF FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
ESTABLISH A TRAINING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS IN UNDERSERVED
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES TO FILL
SHORTAGES AT THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
HEALTH CENTER OR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCY CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WOULD
HELP ADDRESS THE TRIPLE
CHALLENGE OF HEALTH EQUITY.
DIGITAL INCLUSION FOR
UNDERSERVED PATIENTS AND CAREER
TRACK TRAINING FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE BURGEONING BURGEONING HEALTH
IT SECTOR BY PROVIDING CAREER
LADDER OPPORTUNITIES IN
OPERATIONS AND HEALTH I. T. WITH
THE A LOT OF PROPOSAL IS PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE. THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TO SUPPORT THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE. A MULTI
YEAR INVESTMENT IN THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING
COMPONENTS ONE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SPECIALIZED CURRICULUM FOR
TRAINING PROFESSIONALS TO SERVE
JUSTICE AND SYSTEM INVOLVED USE.
TO ADDITIONAL EDUCATIONAL SITES
FOR LICENSE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THREE SUPPORT FOR
PAID INTERNSHIPS FOR MANDATED
TRAINING HOURS FOR EDUCATIONAL
SLOTS FOR A DICK ADDICTION
PSYCHIATRY AND MEDICINE
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS. FIVE
STIPENDS AND SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
SIX WISHIN ASSISTANCE AND TEST
PREPARATION FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELORS SEVEN
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PIPELINE.
EIGHT CERTIFICATION FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALISTS NINE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
INCENTIVES FOR PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND TEN
PAID INTERNSHIPS. FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. B. TWELVE
BEEN A PROPOSAL BURKE FIRST
FUNDING FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
FIVE YEARS TO SUPPORT PEAK
PEDIATRIC WORKFORCE TRAINING IT
CALIFORNIA'S NOT FOR PROFIT
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. THESE
FUNDS WILL BE ALLOCATED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION THREE YEAR INVESTMENT IN
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
NOW THE NEXT- TWO PROPOSALS
WOULD FALL UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE. FIRST
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE
AFTER SHE WON ESTABLISH CLEAR
ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS FOR PLANS
AND PROVIDERS FOR THE COLLECTION
AND REPORTING OF DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA BY AGE SEX RACE ETHNICITY
LANGUAGE SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY. AND DISABILITY
STATE AS WELL AS DATA ON HEALTH
RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS SUCH AS
ACCESS TO HOUSING FOOD. AND
OTHER SUPPORTS. AND TO ESTABLISH
A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND OTHERS TO OTHER
INCENTIVES TO HEALTH PLANS AND
PROVIDERS TO IMPROVE THEIR DATA
PRACTICES INCLUDING TRAINING FOR
PROVIDERS AND STAFF ON DATA
COLLECTION. ITS LEGALITY AND
USES AND HOW TO WORK WITH
PATIENTS TO IMPROVE COMFORT
LEVELS IN SHARING THIS DATA AT
ALL POINTS OF CARE. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS MEDIC CAL MENTAL
HEALTH OUTREACH AND EDUCATION.
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
ESTABLISH AN OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY DMH SEAT TO ENSURE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT
EDUCATION AND MATERIALS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO MEMBERS AND- DAM TO
EDUCATE BOTH MEDIC CAL MEMBERS
AND PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS.
IT'S RATES TO TIMELY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES UNDER THEIR
MEDICAL. MEDICAL PLAN. HOW TO
PROVIDE HOW TO FIND A PROVIDERAND HOW TO SEEK ASSISTANCE
NAVIGATING. THE NEXT FORTY ONE
PROPOSALS WOULD FALL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. FIRST IS A PROPOSAL TO
ENHANCE MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT
FOR OBSTETRICS OBSTETRICS. THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
REQUEST EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS EIGHT POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FEDERAL FUNDS TO
UPDATE ALL OBSTRUCTION
OBSTETRICS CODE PAYMENTS TO THE
LOCAL MEDICARE RATES IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT OBSTETRICIAN
GYNECOLOGISTS PROVIDING CARE TO
PREGNANT AND POSTPARTUM
INDIVIDUALS. AND TO ENSURE
CONTINUED ACCESS TO QUALITY
OBSTETRIC GYNECOLOGICAL AND WELL
WOMEN CARE. THE SECOND PROPOSAL
IS COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
SERVICES PROGRAM EXTENSION. BUT
TURN ON CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
REQUESTS EXPENDITURE OF THIRTY
OF ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION. WHICH IS
TWENTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND NINETY
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS AND ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION SPECIAL FUNDS. TO MAKE
THE FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL SERVICES
PROGRAM. ONE COVER ADDITIONAL
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
ASSESSMENTS INDIVIDUALIZED CARE
PLANS VISITS AND UNITS OF
SERVICE FOR AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MONTHS AFTER THE CURRENT SIXTY
DAY PERIOD. TO PROVIDE MEDICARE
L. M. CAPRI EMBARRASSMENT FOR
COVERED PREVENTIVE SERVICES WHEN
RENDERED IN A BENEFICIARY'S HOME
OR ELSEWHERE AWAY FROM A MEDICAL
FACILITY BY THE PROVIDER
PARTICIPATING IN THE
COMPREHENSIVE PRENATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM. THE THIRD PROPOSAL IS A
MEDIC CAL RATE INCREASE FOR
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION- FOR HEALTH SERVICES
AT HOME REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. OF FIFTY FOUR POINT I'M
SO I'M SORRY FIFTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND AND SIXTY NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FROM GENERAL
FEDERAL FUNDS. IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO SUPPORT A ONE
TIME SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASE
FOR MEDIC CAL PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING HOME CARE SERVICES. THE
FIRST PROPOSAL IS RESTORATION OF
CHIROPRACTIC OPTIONAL BENEFIT IN
MEDIC CAL. THE CALIFORNIA
CHIROPRACTIC ASSOCIATION REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FIVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION OF WHICH ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS JUST FROM
FEDERAL FUNDS. TO RESTORE THE
CHIROPRACTIC BENEFIT IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. THE PROPOSAL IS
A NO COST EXTENSION. OF SHORT
TERM MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD IS MEDICINE
COALITION REQUEST BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXTEND THE TIME TO
USE FUNDING PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGETACT. FOR THE SHORT TERM
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
SIX PROPOSAL IS TO INCREASE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
ORTHOPEDIC AND PROSTHETIC
PROVIDERS. THE CALIFORNIA OR
NEVADA CAN PROCESS THAT I COULD
ASSOCIATION REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. OF WHICH FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION IT'S FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM FEDERAL FUNDS TO
RESTORED 10% PROVIDER RATE
REDUCTION IMPOSED UNDER AB
NINETY SEVEN. WIDE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET CHAPTER THREE STATUTES OF
TWENTY ELEVEN FOR PROSTHETIC AND
ORTHOTIC APPLIANCES. BUT SEVEN
PROPOSAL IS FORGIVE PHARMACY
RECRUITMENT. THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION REQUEST
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND SIXTY THREE
MILLION FROM FEDERAL FUNDS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FORTY
NINE OF WHICH IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION OF WHICH IS FROM FEDERAL
FUNDS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. TO FORGIVE THE RETRO
ACTIVE RECRUITMENT OF PHARMACY
REIMBURSEMENTS DUE TO CHANGES IN
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY REQUIREMENTS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. BUT PROPOSAL
IS GERIATRIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
LEADERSHIP POSITION. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
REQUEST EXPENDITURE OF THOR
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF WHICH A HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED IS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. FORTY TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED IS FROM FEDERAL FUNDS
AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED IS FOR A SPECIAL FUNDS
TO ESTABLISH A LEADERSHIP
POSITION WITHIN EACH YES TO
SERVE AS A LEAD ON ISSUES
RELATING TO OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THANK
PROPOSAL IS MEDICAL GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION. THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REQUESTS GENERAL. ANSWER IT
TWENTY START OF HER. THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REQUEST EXPENDITURES AUTHORITY
OF UP TO NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED OF WHICH
IS FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND SIX
HUNDRED MILLION FROM FEDERAL
FUNDS. ANNUALLY TO EXPANDA
MEDICAL GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION REPLACING
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TRANSFERS FROM
PUBLIC HOSPITALS WITH GENERAL
FUND FOR THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
OF THE PROGRAM'S. THE PROPOSAL
IS MEDIC CAL EQUITABLE EQUITABLE
PAYMENT MODERNIZATION. THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REQUIRES GENERAL- SORRY NOT KEEP
I KEEP WANTING TO SAY GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY SO
MARTIN MISTER NUMBERS TIED TO
STAND HOW WORDS ARE HARD THE-
THEY THEY ARE. THANK YOU- THE
CALIFORNIA ESOS REQUEST X. OF
THREE EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION OF WHICH IS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IT FROM FEDERAL
FUNDS TO UNFREEZE APR DIAGNOSIS
RELATED GROUP PAYMENTS MAKE AN
ANNUAL PAYMENT ADJUSTMENTS TO
ACCOUNT FOR PATIENTS SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES AND
CONVERT FROM IF YOU FOR SERVICE
HOSPITAL INPATIENT REIMBURSEMENT
TO A VALUE BASED STRUCTURE THAT
INCLUDES. GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
AND THE ELEVENTH THE PROPOSAL IS
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN. THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP CHILDREN NOW FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
FIRST FIVE CENTER FOR CHILDREN'S
POLICY MARCH OF DIMES MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM AND WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
REQUEST EXPENDITURES THIRTY OF
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. TEN
MILLION OF WHICH IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND TEN MILLION
FROM FEDERAL FUNDS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TWENTY OF WHICH IS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY FROM
SURE FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY
THERE AFTER TO PROVIDE MULTI
YEAR CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR
MEDICAL CHILDREN UP TO AGE FIVE.
AND I AM NOW GOING TO PASS IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE LUKE
CRUCIAL MORROW BEFORE I.
CONTINUE TO INVEST FOR NOW IT'S
pWORDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
PANIC WELCOME MR CRUCIAL. BUDGET
MAKERS MORROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I WILL BE
COMPLETING THE REMAINDER OF THE
I. D. H. U. S. PROPOSALS BEFORE
AND AFTER NOT ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- THE FIRST PROPOSED
THE TIE THE TWELVE PROPOSAL IS
THE INTERNET ONLY CHILDHOOD PUT
IT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
PROVIDE A TRAINING- THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP CHILDREN
ALLEN FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AVAILABLE
UNTIL. JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY SIX HIS PART BE ABLE
HEALTH NEEDS OF CHILDREN AGES
ZERO TO FIVE AND THE CHILDREN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE- THROUGH PROGRAMS
SUPPORT EXPANSION AND PROVIDE A
TRAINEE. THE FOURTEENTH PROPOSAL
IS TO RESTORE PEDIATRIC
VACCINATION RATES TO CREATE
ECONOMIC LEVELS THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED MILLION. AND FIFTY
MILLION WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL
FUND AND FIFTY MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
REIMBURSE ADMINISTRATION OF WHAT
TEAM CHILDHOOD VACCINES AT THE
SAME RATE AS A MEDICARE PROGRAM
CONSISTENT WITH THE RATES FOR
THE- ADMINISTRATION OF. THE KOBE
NINETEEN VACCINE. THE PROPOSAL
TWELVE IS A INCREASE. TO SPECIAL
CARE IN MEDICARE. THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL AS MEDICAL AS- REQUESTED
X. AUTHORITY OF THREE HUNDRED
AND TWO MILLION. DOLLARS ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND AND THE
REMAINING ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND SIX HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION OF WHICH OF THE GENERAL
FUND AND THE REMAINING THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION TO SETTLE
FUNDS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
ENHANCE ACCESS TO TARGETED
SPECIALTY PROVIDERS. IN MEDIC
CAL TO ADDITIONAL SET TOP MODEL
PAYMENTS IN BOTH MANAGED CARE
AND FEE FOR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS. THE PROPOSAL FIFTEEN
ADDITIONAL THREE FORTY BE
SUPPLEMENTAL. THE CALIFORNIA
PLUS HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
TWO HUNDRED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE HUNDRED AND TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND- THE
REMAINING ONE HUNDRED TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION. FEDERAL FUNDS
ANNUALLY TO INCREASE ALLOCATION
TO THE NON HOSPITAL THREE FORTY
P. SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT COOL.
PROPOSALS THIS HEALTH FOR ALL
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC NETWORK REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND TEN MILLION
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COME COMPETENT OUTRAGE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. PROPOSAL
SEVENTEEN IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM MATERNAL AND
CHILD HEALTH ACCESS ASIAN
RESOURCES INCORPORATED COMMUNITY
HEALTH HEALTH COUNCILS
INCORPORATED AND CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NET WORK REQUEST
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FIFTEEN MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS. ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT A GRANT PROGRAM TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FOR OUTREACH ENROLLMENT
RETENTION AND UTILIZATION
SERVICES. ROSAL EIGHTEEN ITS
ONGOING RESTORATION OF IN THE IN
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA RULE INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY A TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TO SUPPORT ON GOING
FUNDING OF THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM TO FUND GRANT. GRANTS TO
TRAVEL HEALTH PROGRAMS. THE
GOVERNOR GENERAL BUDGET INCLUDES
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS- FOR THIS PURPOSE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THE PROPOSAL NINETEEN IS FOR ICF
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
HOMES- URGENT FUNDING FOR
CONTINUED RAVAGES OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND RATE EQUITY. THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES NETWORK
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TWENTY MILLION OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY THREE
MILLION. OF WHICH WOULD BE
FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR IS A PART OF PERMANENT
ONGOING RATE INCREASE OF 10% FOR
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES.
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I
CFDT. PROPOSAL TWENTY IS CLOSE
STI COVERAGE GAP FOR LGBTQ PLUS
POPULATIONS IN FAMILY PACKED.
THE END OF THE EPIDEMICS
COALITION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF ACCESS TO
STI SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME AND
UNINSURED LGBTQ PLUS PATIENTS
THROUGH THE FAMILY PACK PROGRAM
TO ADDRESS RISING STI RATES AND
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
PROPOSAL TWENTY ONE IS MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR NEW BORN AND
PEDIATRIC JANET JANET TESTED. IT
THE DAY CORPORATION REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL AND THAT SORRY
FEDERAL FUNDS. ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT PROVIDING NEXT
GENERATION SEQUENCING OR WHOLE
EXOME SEQUENCING TO NEWBORN AND
CHILDREN UNDER TWENTY ONE IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. ROSAL TWENTY
TWO. BROTHER TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
PROPOSAL TWENTY TWO DIFFERENT A
LOT OF THE YEAR. PILOT PROJECTS
ON MEDI CAL PRECONCEPTION
PERINATAL AND NEWBORN GENETIC
TESTING IN THE DAY CORPORATION
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
TWO MILLION GEN GENERAL FUND AND
TWO POINT NINE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS OVER TO YOUR SEATS OR
SUPPORT THREE GENETIC TESTING
PILOT PROGRAMS IN MEDIC CAL. THE
FIRST IS PRECONCEPTION AN
IMPORTANT HILLARY'S GREEN IN THE
SECOND PREGNANCY LOS FIELDER
MINE'S STILL BIRTH AND SUDDEN
DEATH GENETIC TESTING AMADOR
NEWBORNS WITH NEXT GENERATION
SEQUENCING. PROPOSAL TWENTY
THREE IT'S PEDIATRICS INFORMED
MEDICAL HOME MODEL PILOT. LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TO SUPPORT A PILOT PROJECT
FOR TRAUMA INFORMED PRIMARY
CARE. MEDICAL MEDICAL HOME MODEL
FOR CHILD ABUSE VICTIMS AND
WOULD SEEK TO PROVIDE A SEAMLESS
CONTINUUM OF MULTI DISCIPLINARY
RESILIENCE INFORMED MEDICAL CARE
. PROPOSAL TWENTY FOUR IT'S
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING BENEFIT IN
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CENTERS THE
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH COALITION
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH HOURLY RATES FOR
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING SERVICES
PROVIDED BY PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH
CENTER WITH THE TRANSITIONAL
CARE UNIT. THE PROPOSAL TWENTY
FIVE IS EQUITY IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PAYMENT FOR MEDIC CAL COMMUNITY
CLINICAL CLINIC ABORTION
PROVIDERS. PARENTHOOD REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO ABOUT
ELIGIBLE MEDI CAL PROVIDERS TO
BUILD AN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
EQUITY FEE OF AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS WE PAY FOR
ABORTION SERVICES INCLUDING FOR
MEDICAL ABORTION. PROPOSAL
TWENTY SIX IS THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PILOT
PROGRAM. HARPER I DON'T KNOW TO
REQUEST GENERAL FUND X. TORTILLA
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TO
SUPPORT A PILOT PROJECT TO
SUPPORT INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
AND PATIENT CENTERED
COLLABORATIONS TO SAFEGUARD
PATIENT ACCESS TO ABORTIONS
REGARDLESS OF RESIDENCY.
PROPOSAL TWENTY SEVENS IS A
MEDIC CAL PROVIDER DATA SHARING
INCENTIVES AND INFRASTRUCTURE. A
COALITION OF TWENTY TWO
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING HEALTH
PLANS PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS
AND HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE
ORGANIZATIONS. REQUEST
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND WITH THE REMAINING
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS BEING FEDERAL FUNDS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
HUNDRED SIX MILLION DOLLARS
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND WITH THE
REMAINING ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
MILLION BEING FEDERAL FUNDS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
AND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND NINETY SIX MILLION
OF. BEING FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER DO SUPPORT THE
PERFORMANCE PAYMENTS FOR MEDICAL
PROVIDER IT'S THAT JOIN IN SHARE
DATA WITH QUALIFIED HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES AND
FUNDING FOR QUALIFIED HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES TO BUILD
AND MAINTAIN THE HEALTH DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR
CALTRAIN. TO SUCCEED. PROPOSAL
TWENTY EIGHT IS JIM CROW OUR TO
MEDIC. FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WITH SERIOUS
ILLNESS. THE PSYCHIATRIC.
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
MAKE THE FOLLOWING CHANGES TO
PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
MEDICATIONS. TRANSPERTH CRIED TO
MEDICAL AND RELATES WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. THE
FIRST IS TO ELIMINATE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST FOR THOSE
OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE WE
HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED APPROVAL
AND THE PREVIOUS THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS. THE SECOND IS
TO AUTOMATICALLY APPROVED PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST FOR THOSE
OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE WHO
ARE DISPENSED THE MEDICATION IN
THE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS PRIOR TO MEDICAL AND ROMAN.
AND I THOUGHT AUTHORIZES THE
NINETY DAY SUPPLY OF DRUGS TO
TREAT. SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
GRANTED- PRIOR ALL. REQUEST AND
THE FOURTH IS TO AUTHORIZE ONLY
REFILLS OF DRUG TO TREAT.
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS IF LESS
THAN SEVEN DAYS OF THERAPY
REMAIN. ROSAL TWENTY NINE IS A
MEDIC CAL OUR ACTS AND THREE
FORTY B. PROGRAM PATH FILL FROM
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA.
COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
DISPARITY IN THE DH YES FUNDING
FORMULA OR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO SANTA BARBARA COUNTY FEEDBACK
BUT LOST THREE FORTY BE REVENUE
DUE TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
MEDIC CAL OUR ACTS. PROPOSAL
THIRTY IS A MEDIC HEALTHCARE
SUPPORT SPECIALTY SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE RUN ORGANIZATIONS
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE REMAINING
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS. IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AVAILABLE FOR TWO
YEARS TO SUPPORT A PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
ARE YOUR SUPPORT SPECIALISTS AS-
AS MEDICAL BILLABLE PROVIDERS
AND ADD YOUR SUPPORT SERVICES AS
A MEDIC CAL. COVERED BENEFITS.
ALL PROPOSAL ONE IS TO RESTORE
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN REDUCTIONS
FOR PHYSICIAN SERVICES. A
COALITION OF TWELVE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
PHYSICIANS FOR. REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO REPEAL 10% MEDIC
CALIBRATE REDUCTION OF PHYSICIAN
SERVICES INCLUDING CLINICAL
LABORATORY INNOGY. IMOGENE AND
OTHER PHYSICIANS SERVICES
IMPOSED BY EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN- COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
CHAPTER THREE STATUTES OF TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. PROPOSAL THIRTY
TWO IS TO UPDATE MEDICAL SHERIFF
COST CALCULATION. BEDSTEAD
ACTION CALIFORNIA SO ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM
DISABILITY RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
JUSTICE IN AGING SENIOR AND
DISABILITY ACTION SAN FRANCISCO
AND WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND FUNDING TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIANS MEET MAINTENANCE
NEED INCOME LEVEL 2110038% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. THE
CURRENT INCOME CUT OFF FOR FREE
MEDICAL COVERAGE IN THE CURRENT
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH HAS
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR DECADES.
RUSSELL THIRTY THREE SIGNALIZED
PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY CARE
PHYSICIAN NETWORK. THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION WRIST.
PRESS EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
SEVENTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. THEN FORTY POINT
THREE MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT AN INCREASE
TO THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SERVICES RIGHT
AUGMENTATION BY ADDING AT LEAST
25% THE CURRENT AUGMENTATION
PERCENTAGE. RELATIVE TO THE
APPLICABLE MEDI CAL HE FOR
SERVICE RATES. PROPOSAL THIRTY
FOUR IS THE EXTENSION OF
TELEHEALTH POSSIBILITIES TO PACE
ORGANIZATIONS. APPROPRIATE
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WITH UNKNOWN COSTS REQUIRE DHT
ESTY SECURE A FEDERAL WAIVER TO
CREATE NEW CREATE NARROW
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY TO PACE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN ENROLL AND
ASSESS NEW POTENTIAL ENROLLEES
WHO HAVE DIFFICULTY COMPETING IN
PERSON APPOINTMENTS. THE
PROPOSAL THIRTY FIVE IS
INCREASING ACCESS TO POSITIVE
PARENT PROGRAMS AND FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. A COALITION OF
FOURTEEN ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
FIRST FIVE ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHER FAMILY SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
TWENTY POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND NINE
COUNTIES TO LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND DEMONSTRATED
TRACK RECORD. OF IMPROVING THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
FOSTERING NURSED NURTURING AND
FAMILY ENVIRONMENTS AND
PREVENTING CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. PROPOSAL THIRTY SIX IS
FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT YOU
PURCHASE WHAT WATSONVILLE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. HERRO VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT IN THE
CALIFORNIA NORTH OF NURSING
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE TO ALLOW THEM TO
HEROIC VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT TO COMPLETE ITS
PURCHASE OF THE WATSONVILLE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. THE PROPOSAL
THIRTY SEVEN IS TO ADJUST FEVER
SERVICE RATES FOR DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND- ENTERAL FORMULA.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MEDICAL PRODUCTS AND SUPPLIERS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWENTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
SUPPORT RESTORATION OF THE 10%
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTION FOR THE
DURABLE. MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. IT
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND ENTERAL
FORMULA IMPOSED PURSUANT TO
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN COMMUNITY
ON BUDGET CHAPTER THREE STATUTES
OF TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. OF THESE
FUNDS SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD ELIMINATE
RETROACTIVE RECRUITMENTS
PURSUANT TO EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. THE THIRTY EIGHT IS
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
IN CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
PRESERVATION OF CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER WAS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FOUR YEARS TO DEVELOP TEST AND
EVALUATE PROGRAMS AND SYSTEM
PARTICLES. ARE GOING TO
UNDERSERVED FAMILY CAREGIVERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT. BECAUSE OF THIRTY
NINE IS REFINING THE HACCP TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE PEDIATRIC HEALTHCARE
. CHILDREN NOW AND LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO MAKE
THE FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THE
HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM HACCP. OKAY
FIRST ALIGN PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SERVICES CCS PROGRAM.
TO EXPAND COVERAGE TO CHILDREN
UNABLE TO ENROLL WHO HAVE
PARTIAL COVERAGE OR HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES AND THREE APPLY MEDI
CAL AND CCS TIMELY ACT SAYS AND
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO STANDARDS TO
HACCP. PROPOSAL FORTY IS HOUSING
PLUS INTENSIVE ROCK SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS FSP AN SUV CLIENTS THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. BRIDGE HOUSING PROPOSAL
TO SUPPORT HOUSING PLUS
INTENSIVE WRAP SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CLIENTS. THE PROPOSAL
ONE IS A CHILDREN'S CRISIS
CONTINUE ON THAT PROGRAM THE
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF THE ACCESS
CRITERIA FOR CHIP THE CHILDREN'S
FROM. CHIME BUT CHILDREN'S
CRISIS CONTINUUM PILOT INCLUDE
MEDICAL ELIGIBLE YOUTH. I WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
JEAN BELL AND ABOUT. BORROWED TO
GO FOR- FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME IS
BUILT. MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNY FELLOW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
HERE TO READ THROUGH THE NEXT
SEGMENT O REQUESTS STARTING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH HAS FOURTEEN
REQUESTS. WE BEGIN WITH THE AMER
AT THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
TESTING FOR HIV HEPATITIS B. AND
SYPHILIS. THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AT THIRTY OF THIRTY
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO SUPPORT GRANTS TO
HOSPITALS FOR TESTING FOR HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND SEVERAL S. AND
LINKAGE TO CARE. THE SECOND
REQUEST IS FOR FIREFIGHTER
CANCER RESEARCH THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
REQUEST. GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWENTY
MILLION AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
TO SUPPORT RESEARCH ON THE
CAUSES OF CANCER IN FIREFIGHTERS
PERFORM APPROACHES TO MITIGATE
EXPOSURES AND INTERVENTIONS TO
PREVENT CANCER IN FIREFIGHTERS.
THE THIRD IS FOR THE COMMUNITY
DENTAL ROTATIONS FOR STUDENTS
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TEN MILLION
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO DEVELOP A
CONSORTIA OF CALIFORNIA DENTAL
SCHOOLS TO CREATE NEW AND
ENHANCED COMMUNITY BASED
CLINICAL EDUCATION ROTATION FOR
DENTAL STUDENTS TO IMPROVE ORAL
HEALTH UNDERSERVED POPULATION
GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA. THE FOURTH
PROPOSAL IS FOR MATERNITY
OUTCOMES DATA COLLECTION. THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND AND. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR THROUGH TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. AND TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS INCLUDING FOR CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE LED BIRTH IN AND
OUT OF HOSPITAL SETTINGS
CONSISTENT WITH SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE
FIFTIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
. A COALITION OF TWELVE PUBLIC
HEALTH EQUITY ORGANIZATIONS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF A HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT GRANTS TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS
AND TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADDRESS THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF PHYSICAL HEALTH. AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ADVANCE RACIAL
EQUITY AND REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES. EXCEPT FOR A HEALTH
EQUITY IN HARM REDUCTION
INITIATIVE. THE END OF THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWENTY MILLION
ANNUALLY TO ESTABLISH THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND HARM REDUCTION
INITIATIVE WHICH WOULD ENSURE
CONTINUITY AND SUPPORT FURTHER
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA HARM
REDUCTION NITIATIVE WHICH IS A
PILOT SET TO EXPIRE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
IT WOULD ALSO FIND A BROADER
RANGE OF HARM REDUCTION SERVICES
INCLUDING DROP IN CENTRES MOBILE
SERVICES AND OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS. THE SEVENTH IT'S FOR
HEPATITIS B. OUT REACHED
SCREENING LINKAGE TO CARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS. THE END
OF THE EPIDEMICS COALITION
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF EIGHT MILLION
AVAILABLE JUNE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TO
SUPPORT UP TO FIVE HEPATITIS B.
OUTREACH SCREENING LINKAGE TO
AND RETENTION IN CARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOCUSED
ON PEOPLE LIVING WITH AND
VULNERABLE TO HEPATITIS B. COULD
FACE MULTIPLE BARRIERS TO ACCESS
ACCESSING CARE AND TREATMENT.
EIGHT IT'S FOR HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION AND LINKAGE TO CARE
THE END OF THE EPIDEMICS
COALITION REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWENTY
MILLION. ANNUALLY TO FURTHER
DEVELOP THE STATE'S HEPATITIS C.
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TO MAKE MEANINGFUL PROGRESS
TOWARD ENDING THAT HEPATITIS C.
EPIDEMIC. THE NINETIES WERE
CIVILISED OUTBREAK STRATEGY THE
AND THE ACADEMICS COALITION
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FORTY NINE MILLION
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TO SUPPORT A
SYMBOLISING CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
OUTBREAK STRATEGY IN KEY LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS WITH THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE BULLETIN
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
TRANSMISSION. TO INTENSIFY
PREVENTION SCREENING AND
TREATMENT EFFORT AND TO
IMPLEMENT INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
TO REACH THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND PRIORITY
SETTINGS. INCLUDING SUBSTANCE
USE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
. THE TENTH IS FOR MEAL THE
FAMILY MEAL SACRAMENTO REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF THREE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TO
SUPPORT LOCAL RESTAURANTS TO
FEED VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. THE ELEVENTH IT'S FOR
CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRY
FUNDING- CAN CANCER SOCIETY
SOCIETY THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY I'VE SIX
POINT SIX MILLION ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA CANCER
REGISTRY. THE TWELFTH IT'S FOR
KOBE NINETEEN CASTING IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS. PROTECT
US REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. TO
CONTINUE CURRENT FUNDING FOR
KOBE NINETEEN TESTING AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS AND
EXPAND TESTING FOR OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. THIRTEEN IS
TO ESTABLISH A RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL. A COALITION OF
FORTY ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES AND DISEASE SPECIFIC
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND ANNUALLY
TO ESTABLISH A RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO GIVE
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH A RARE
DISEASE A UNIFIED VOICE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
ACTIVITY ADVISORY BOARD ON RARE
DISEASES TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO YOU OR THAT ARE
CHARGED WITH THE CARE OF RARE
DISEASE PATIENTS AND DELIVER
DIRECT FEEDBACK SOLUTIONS AND
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT DECISION MAKERS WITH
ONE COMMUNITY VOICE. THE
FOURTEENTH IT'S FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS. THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY A FIFTEEN MILLION
ANNUALLY. TO SUPPORT EXPANSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. HOW NOW TRANSITION TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS WHICH HAD ONE REQUEST
IT'S FOR INCREASED COMPENSATION
FOR CIVIL SERVICE PSYCHIATRISTS
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
NINE POINT ONE MILLION. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND ELEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO SUPPORT
AN ACROSS THE BOARD SALARY
INCREASE OF 15% FOR CIVIL
SERVICE PSYCHIATRIST. TO REDUCE
PSYCHIATRISTS VACANCIES AND
BOLSTER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION EFFORTS. NOW
TRANSITION TO THEIR REQUEST THAT
COVER MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND THERE EIGHT
OF THOSE. SO THE FIRST ONE IS
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY AND
READINESS OPPORTUNITY INITIATIVE
. FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND AT
THE AYE YOU CALIFORNIA REQUEST
TOTAL GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY AT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
AVAILABLE FOR UP. TO FOUR.
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING
COMPONENTS ONE PUBLIC HEALTH
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STATEMENTS TO WAITING PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE CERTIFICATION FEES.
THREE INCUMBENT WORKER UP SKILL
TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH ATHLETES TRAINING. FIVE
CALIFORNIA MICROBIOLOGISTS
TRAINING SIX PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
INSPIRED AND SEVEN CALIFORNIA
ACADEMIA LOGIC INVESTIGATION
SERVICES. THE SECOND IS FOR A
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH PEER TO
PEER PILOT PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY A TEN MILLION AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO
IMPLEMENT A STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH PEER TO PEER HEILIG
PROGRAM FOR ONE. SCHOOL YEAR.
THE THIRD IS FOR CONDOM ACCESS
IN SCHOOLS. THE AND THE
ACADEMICS COALITION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY TO
ESTABLISH A CONDOM ACCESS
PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN ORDER
TO MAKE FREE CONDOMS AVAILABLE
TO ALL PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS THAT OPT INTO THE
PROGRAM. THE FOURTH IT'S FOR
SELF HELP PROGRAMS TO FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS. THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AT TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT SELF
HELP PROGRAMS TO FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. PERFECT IT'S FOR
PHYSICIAN SCHOLARSHIP AND
NAVIGATOR PILOT PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REQUEST GENEAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWENTY MILLION
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY THIRTY SIX TO PROVIDE
SCHOLARSHIPS TO INDIVIDUALS
UNDER REPRESENTED. AND MEDICINE
FROM THEIR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION THROUGH COMPLETION OF
THE GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
IN EXCHANGE FOR A COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT CARE WITH
A MEDICALLY UNDER SERVED
POPULATION AND OUR AREA FOR A
SET PERIOD OF TIME. THE SIXTIES
FOR THE NEW HOSPITAL BILLION AT
UCSF BENIOFF CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
IN OAKLAND. UCSF BENIOFF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OAKLAND
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE TO HELP FINANCE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW HOSPITAL
PAVILION AT THE HOSPITAL
INCLUDING COMPLIANCE WITH
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
MODERNIZATION OF FACILITIES
ENHANCEMENT OF PATIENT SERVICES
AND CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
INPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH UNIT.
THE SEVENTH IT'S FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY REFORM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATE ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION WHICH IS A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND A HUNDRED AND NINE
POINT NINE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS. IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY POINT FOUR MILLION
WHICH IS TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
POINT SEVEN MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
WHICH IS TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING REFORM
PROPOSALS FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ONE INCREASED WAGES
FOR CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT.
AND INCREASED HOURS FOR
REGISTERED NURSES TO WORKFORCE
TRAINING FOR CNA AND THREE A
STUDY TO ESTABLISH APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF CLINICAL CARE. THE
EIGHT IT'S HER FAULT IS FIND THE
CALIFORNIA MOM THE BEST ACT. THE
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND MARCH
OF DIMES NAY ROTH PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL HEALTH LAW
PROGRAM AND WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
SIX MILLION AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
IMPLEMENT COMPONENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOM THE BEST ACT SB
SIXTY FIVE A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INCLUDING THE FETAL INFANT
MORTALITY REVIEW COMMITTEES
MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DO LESS SERVICES. I TRANSITION
NOW TO THE REQUEST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THERE ARE
TEN OF THOSE. SO THE FIRST ONE
IS FOR AS A VEHICLE ON REQUEST
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE TO COMPLETE THE
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHY AGING
CAMPUS. THE SECOND IS A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR VILLAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE VILLAGE MOVEMENT
CALIFORNIA REQUEST NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN
BOTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. AND ONE MILLION AND
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR VILLAGE
COMMUNITIES AND SERVICES TO
THIRD CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE OLDER ADULTS. THE THIRD
IS FOR THE HOW LONG TERM CARE
COMPARE CONSUMER INFORMATION
EQUALITY. HOW HAVE HEALTHCARE
COMPARE REQUEST ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE TO EXPAND AND
IMPROVE THAT HOW LONG TERM CARE
WEBSITE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE FEET
FREE RELIABLE TRUSTWORTHY
CONSUMER INFORMATION ON PROVIDER
PERFORMANCE IN THE LONG TERM
CARE SERVICES AND SUPPORT ARENA
USING PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
FROM MULTIPLE FEDERAL AND STATE
SOURCES. THE FOURTH IS A BRIDGE
TO RECOVERY FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES COVERED NINETEEN
MITIGATION AND RESILIENT BRECHT
RESILIENCE GRANTS TO COMBAT
SENIOR ISOLATION. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES REQUEST SIXTY ONE POINT
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO ADULT DAY
HEALTHCARE CENTERS AND ADULT DAY
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY NEEDS RESULTING FROM THE
COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT IS
FOR ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA
CAREGIVER EDUCATION AND SUPPOT
PILOT PROGRAM. THE ALZHEIMER'S
LOS ANGELES ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE
COUNTY AND ALZHEIMER'S SAN DIEGO
REQUEST TWENTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT OVER
FIVE YEARS FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
AND DEMENTIA CAREGIVER EDUCATION
AND SUPPORT PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD SUPPORT EXPANDED ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE SUPPORTED DEMENTIA CARE
GIVER AND EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
PROGRAMS. FIFTY SIX IT'S FOR
TARGETED HOUSING SUBSIDIES TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES.
JUSTICE IN AGING CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
DISABILITIES. UNITED WAY OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES REQUEST
TWENTY MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
INCREASING IN THE OUT YEARS
THREE TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN.
TO PROVIDE HOUSING SUBSIDIES FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES ACCESS OR KEEP
THEIR HOUSING. SEVEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. ALAMEDA
OUNTY REQUEST THIRTY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS FOR A
STATE WIDE REQUEST TO RESTORE
STATE FUNDING FOR TWO OLDER
ADULTS SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. CASE
MANAGEMENT AND VISITING PROGRAMS
. EIGHT IT'S FOR HELP YOUR HOME
AGING PLACE NURSING PROGRAM
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA AND LYFT
STEPS REQUEST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER FIVE
YEARS TO ESTABLISH A FIVE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM. IN EIGHT COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO DELIVER
SERVICES TO RESIDENTS AT SENIOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SITES. THE
NINE IS FOR GRANTS FOR CITIES
COUNTIES AND LOCAL MUNICIPAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DEVELOP AND
ACHIEVE AGE FRIENDLY GOALS. A RP
CALIFORNIA REQUEST FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER
THREE YEARS TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO PLAN AND
DEVELOP AGE FRIENDLY ACTION
PLANS. THE TENTH IS FOR
INVESTING IN OLDER ADULTS AND
MODERNIZING THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING REQUEST FUNDING TO
RESTORE. FUNDING TO TWO THOUSAND
NINE LEVELS FOR A VARIETY OF
INITIATIVES AND REESTABLISH THE
BASIC OLDER ADULTS
INFRASTRUCTURE. I TRANSITION NOW
TO A REQUEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES THERE
IS ONE OF THOSE. I IN ITS FOR
INCREASED LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
FUNDING TO ADDRESS FUNDING
INEQUITIES IN OPERATIONAL COSTS
. THE CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
STATE COUNCIL REQUEST TWENTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND FIFTY EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS. ONGOING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES TO FIND LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES FOR BOTH
EXISTING AND UPCOMING WORKLOAD.
TO IMPROVE THE ECONOMIC WELL
BEING OF A VULNERABLE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. AND WITH THAT I
WILL TURN IT TO MY COLLEAGUE
ANGELA SHORT TO BEGIN WITH- TO
WALK THROUGH THE REQUEST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AS WELL- WELCOME
MISS SHORT AND LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE US HOME HUH. YES
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING ANGELA
SHORT WITH THE L. A. L. AS MY
COLLEAGUE NOTED I WILL BEGIN. BY
READING THE PROPOSAL'S FALLING
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THERE ARE
NINE OF THOSE. OTHER FIRST IS
DDS RATE STUDY AND TANDEM AN
ONGOING UPDATES- INTERMENT
COALITION REQUESTS FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND ONE
POINT ONE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. ONE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND ONE POINT ONE
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M
GOING. TO UPDATE THE RATE MODELS
BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITION TO AN
OUTCOME BASED SYSTEM AND TO
ENSURE SERVICES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL H.
CBS SETTING ROLE. Q. DIRECT
SUPPORT WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. THE
LETTERMAN COALITION REQUESTS
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND. AND
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS. IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AM
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ACCELERATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE DDS RATE STUDY. TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
THE RESULTING IN SERVICE
DISRUPTIONS. THE PROPOSAL IS
SUPPORTED TECHNOLOGY AND REMOTE
MONITORING DEMONSTRATION PILOTS
. IS BAY INNOVATIONS AND
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
REQUESTED A TOTAL OF SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT OF
PILOTS TO TRAIN AND EQUIP AGENCY
PROVIDERS OF SUPPORTED LIVING
AND INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
TO IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY AND
REMOTE MONITORING SOLUTIONS AND
TO COLLECT DATA ON REPORT
OUTCOMES. OF COURSE PROPOSAL IS
MODERNIZATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS BUDGETING METHODOLOGY
. THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND TO TWENTY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND AND TEN
POINT SIX MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
INCREASING ACCORDINGLY ON AN
ONGOING BASIS TO REALIGN THE COR
STAFFING FORMULA WITH STATE
COSTS AND ENHANCED STABILITY FOR
THOSE SERVED BY REGIONAL CENTERS
. THE PROPOSAL IS ELIMINATING
REGIONAL CENTER FAMILY SHE IS.
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES REQUEST FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ELIMINATE FAMILY
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE ANIMAL
FAMILY PROGRAM FEET. AND THE
FAMILY COST PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM ALL. THESE PROPOSAL IS
THE VILLAGE HOUSING FOR ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES. ERA
CORNERSTONE REQUESTS A TOTAL OF
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
COMPLETE THE FUNDING FOR
CORNERSTONES PROJECTS THE
VILLAGE WHICH WILL SERVE AS A
PILOT PROJECT I AM HEARING AND
NEW MODEL FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND WITH LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. A SEVEN
PROPOSAL IS PLANNING FOR THE
RECORD NEEDED FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES PILOT PROJECT.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
REQUEST BUDGET BILL AND OR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ACCOMPANY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR NEEDED FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES PILOT PROJECT.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
REQUEST LANGUAGE THAT SPECIFIES
THE SCOPE OF SERVICES AND HOW
THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO TARGET
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. THE
PROPOSAL IS SUB MINIMUM WAGE
PHASE OUT PILOT PROGRAM.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
REQUEST MODIFICATIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ACCOMPANYING ITS
PROPOSAL FOR A SUB MINIMUM WAGE
PHASE OUT BALLOT PROGRAM.
SPONSOR REQUEST ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THE NATURE
OF COLLABORATION WITH SB SIX
THIRTY NINE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
INCORPORATE AN EVALUATION OF THE
PROJECT AND IDENTIFY TARGETS FOR
METRICS FOR PROGRAM SUCCESS. AND
THEN I PROPOSAL IS DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB SIX THIRTY
NINE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION SB SIX
THIRTY NINE UNTIL MORE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA IS PROVIDED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
REGARDING THE CURRENT STATUS OF
EMPLOYMENT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AS
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THIRTY
EIGHT PROPOSALS FALLING UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE FIRST
PROPOSAL IS CONTINUATION AND
ENHANCEMENT OF ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES TRAINING FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS. DO YOU COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION CREDAI
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS GUARDIANS
AND CONSERVATORS CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION REQUEST FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION ONGOING BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THEIR
CURRENT TO TRAINING STRUCTURE
AND PROVIDEEXISTING AND NEW EPS
SOCIAL WORKERS WITH THE
NECESSARY EDUCATION AND PRACTICE
SKILLS TO SURVIVE USED NEGLECTED
OLDER ADULTS. AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. ALL I CAN PROPOSAL
IS NATURAL DISASTER RELIEF FOR I
HSS PROVIDERS. AS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS VW ASK ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY I REQUEST FORTY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING TO PROVIDE A WAGE
DIFFERENTIAL FOR UP TO FORTY
OTHER CLIENTS ASSESSED HOURS
WORKED DURING A GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
AND THE SPECIFIED TO CHARITY OR
COUNTY. THREE ALL CAL SAVERS FOR
HSS PROVIDERS. AS YOUR YOUR
CALIFORNIA AND YOU D. W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
REQUEST THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO HELP I HSS
PROVIDERS USUALLY PARTICIPATE IN
THE CAL SAVER'S RETIREMENT
PROGRAM. THE FOURTH PROPOSAL IS
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP. IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA CHANGE
LAWYERS AND IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER REQUEST TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION EACH YEAR
OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR YEARS TO
EXPAND THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANTS LEGAL FELLOWSHIP.
FURTHER BUILDING LEGAL CAPACITY
AND RURAL REGIONS AND
STRENGTHENING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THE PROPOSAL IS FOR
ALL CLIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM EXPANSION TO CALL.
NOURISH CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER REQUEST FORTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE GROWING TO FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND ON
AN ONGOING BASIS TO EXPAND THE
STEVE ADAMS TO NONCITIZEN
IMMIGRANTS OF ALL AGES WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM CALFRESH
SOLELY DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. B. SIX PROPOSAL IS WITH
CARE FREE FREE MEALS FOR KIDS IN
PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CARE. NURSE
CALIFORNIA ANY CHILD AND ADULT
CARE FOOD PROGRAM BROWN'S TEEPLE
. REQUEST EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND SEVENTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING
TO PROVIDE FREE MEALS TO
CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE BY
ENABLING ALL CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO QUALIFY FOR
REIMBURSEMENT EQUIVALENT TO THE
HIGHEST FEDERAL RATE FOR ME. THE
PROPOSAL IS CALIFORNIA FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS EXPANSION. SPUR AND
NOURISH CALIFORNIA REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. TO SUBSTANTIALLY
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE EBT PILOTS WHICH WAS
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND IS CURRENTLY BEING
IMPLEMENTED. THE PROPOSAL IS
EXPANDED AB T. ACCESS AT
CERTIFIED FARMERS MARKET. NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA AND ALCHEMISTS
CDC REQUESTS TWENTY MILLION A
YEAR OVER THREE YEARS FOR GRANT
PROGRAM JOINTLY DEVELOPED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE BUT HOUSE IN ONE
AGENCY TO SUPPORT AB T. ACCESS
AND STAFFING AND CERTIFIED
FARMERS MARKETS. CAN PER
PROPOSAL IS- BANK RESOURCES
BOLSTER THAT CALVET PROGRAMS YOU
MEDICAID INCREASED HUNGER. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS REQUESTS AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY TWO MILLION ONGOING AND
TEN MILLION ONE TIME FOR CAL
FOOD TO SUSTAIN PUT BANKS
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR DUE TO A COMBINATION
STANDS COMMUNITY DEMAND. FOOD
INFLATION AND THE FEDERAL FOOD
CLASS. THE TEMPER IS FOOD BANK
PASS THAT HE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WITH
BANKERS REQUESTS ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TO HELP
FOOD BANKS STORE AND TRANSPORT
FOODS MORE EFFICIENTLY AND BE
MORE CLIMATE RESILIENCE. THE
ELEVENTH PROPOSAL IS PERMANENTLY
AUTHORIZE AND FUNDED STATE
DISASTER FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
. THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS REQUEST NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE IT TOUGH ON THE
STATE SASTRE FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DIFFERENTLY AUTHORIZE
THE PROGRAM AND STATUTES. THE
PROPOSAL TWELVE RAMP DOWN OF
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
REQUEST FUNDING TO PROVIDE IT
FOR RAMPS DOWN PERIOD AFTER THE
END OF THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. WE'LL
DO NOT SUDDENLY LOSE FOOD MONEY
THAT THEY HAVE BECOME DEPENDENT
ON. CURRENTLY IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS APPROVED SNAPPED
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS UNTIL THE
END OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. PROPOSAL THIRTEEN
CALFRESH EMBODIED CHARACTER
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA ANTI HUNGER RESPONSE
AND EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD PROVIDE STATE FUNDED
CALFRESH BENEFITS FOR ANYONE WHO
IS DENIED BENEFITS DUE TO THE
ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENTS TIME LIMIT. THE
PROPOSAL FOURTEEN FOOT BANK
EQUITY TRANSFORMATION PROJECT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK FOOD BANK OF CONTRA COSTA
AND SOLANO REDWOOD EMPIRE FOOD
BANK SAN FRANCISCO MARIN THE
BANK AND SECOND HARVEST SILICON
VALLEY REQUEST ONE POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE FOR THE FOOD
BANK EQUITY TRANSFORMATION PILOT
PROJECT PROBABLY WOULD HELP TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND OPTIONS
FOR CULTURALLY PREFERRED OPTIONS
. THE PROPOSAL FIFTEEN HOW FRESH
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING PATCH.
CWPA S. CI YOU AND CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES C.
REQUEST SIXTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND UNTIL THE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY BURKE COUNTY
CALFRESH ADMINISTRATION IS
UPDATED. ASSUMING THE BUDGET
METHODOLOGY FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CALFRESH
PROGRAM IS EFFECTIVE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FISCAL YEAR AS CURRENTLY
PLANNED. THIS REQUEST WOULD ONLY
BE NEEDED FOR ONE YEAR. THE
PROPOSAL SIXTEEN FOR ALIGNMENT
OF MONTHLY GROSS INCOME
CALCULATIONS. A COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS CCW ARE- REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CHANGE
HER MONTHLY GROSS INCOME IS
CALCULATED AND ONLINE THAT
CALCULATION FOR MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS. THE PROPOSAL SEVENTY
SEVENS FOR TOWERS BENEFICIARIES
WHO RECEIVE HIGH SCHOOL OR
COLLEGE DIPLOMA. CCW ARE-
REQUEST TWENTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONGOING AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CREATE THE TOWERS
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
ENTERTAINMENT PROGRAM. WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE STIPENDS TO POWER
IN A FISHERIES WHO RECEIVED A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR ENROLL IN
EDUCATION OR TRAINING PROGRAM
LEADING TO AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM CERTIFICATE OR
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. THE EIGHTEEN
PROPOSAL IS EXPANDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR EIGHT HOURS
CHILD TO COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL
IMPEDED BY THE CORBETT NINETY
BANTAM. C. C. W. R. O. REQUEST
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS AREN'T GOING AS
WELL AS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
ALLOW YOU ON THE COUCH PROGRAMS
TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE BENEFITS
IF THEY WILL COMPLETE THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS. BY THE AGE
OF TWENTY INSTEAD OF NINETEEN.
THE PROPOSAL NINETEEN PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES CALL CENTER
MINIMUM STANDARDS. CCW ARE-
REQUESTS THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET INCLUDES
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE CDS ASTRAKHAN
BEING A CALL CENTRE MINIMUM
STANDARD WORK GROUP. THIS REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD
INCLUDE STATEWIDE MINIMUM
STANDARDS STANDARDS ARE COUNTY
CALL CENTERS. THE TWENTIETH
PROPOSAL IS ISSUE AID PAID
PENDING A REHEARING. CZW ARE-
REQUEST STATUTORY CHANGES SO
THAT BENEFICIARIES CAN CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE BENEFITS WHEN THEY
MAKE AN APPEAL AGAINST A
NEGATIVE COUNTY ACTION AND ARE
GRANTED A REHEARING BY THE CDSS
. PROPOSAL TWENTY ONE HOUSE
SAULS REFORMS CCW ARE- REQUEST
STATUTORY CHANGES TO ENSURE THAT
CAL SALTS FUNDED FEATURES ARE
AVAILABLE TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES BENEFICIARIES IN ALL
COUNTIES ALL MEDIUMS RELATIVE TO
COUNCILS WILL BE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. PROPOSAL TWENTY TWO.
EMERGENCY AND DISASTER RESPONSE
FOR TOWERS AND HOW FRESH. CZW
ARE- REQUEST BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING CDSS TO
CONVENE A WORK WORK GROUP AND
PRODUCE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD PROVIDE
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS TO MEET THE
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE NAMES AFTER
HOURS AND HOW FRESH APPLICANTS
AND RECIPIENTS DURING ANY
DISASTER DECLARATION BY THE
GOVERNOR. PROPOSAL TWENTY THREE
STABILIZING AND STRENGTHENING
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS. THE
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. I REQUEST FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND ONGOING
AND TRAILER BILL- SKEWS ME FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE EIGHT
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS IN
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE COST
EFFECTIVE AND CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE SUPPORT TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. OR SOME OF THE
MOST MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
PROPOSAL TWENTY FOUR KINSHIP
GUARDIANSHIP ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS
CAN GAP PROGRAM EXPANSION. THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
AND CALIFORNIA LANDS OF THE
FIRST REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND FUNDING TO EXPAND
THE STATE IN GAP PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE ALL CHILDREN LIVING WITH
RELATIVES YOU'RE A GUARDIANSHIP
ORDERED BY THE JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY COURTS. THE TWENTY
FIFTH PROPOSAL IS EMERGENCY
TROUT CHILD CARE BRIDGE
EXPANSION. CHILDREN NOW CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CARE GIVERS C. WTA AND THE USC
SUZANNE TO WORK PACKED SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKER REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY EIGHT MILLION
TO INCREASE THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
FOR THE THREE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM AS
FOLLOWS ALL. THIRTY NINE MILLION
TO EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL VOUCHERS TO CHILDREN
IN CARE. FIVE MILLION TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL NAVIGATORS WHO ARE
WORKING TO FIND CHILD CARE FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN. AND FOUR
MILLION TWO SUPPORTS THE
DELIVERY OF ADDITIONAL TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAINING FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AS THEY CARE FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN IN THEIR LOCAL
EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS.
PROPOSAL TWENTY SIX IS CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM BRIDGING SERVICE
GAPS FOR FOSTER CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. C. W. T. A REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS GAPS
ACROSS THE CARE CONTINUUM. THE
PROPOSAL CONSISTS OF ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND. FOR A FAMILY BASED
SERVICES COMPONENT. TWENTY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR TRANSITION AGE TO USE AND
CARE GIVER INSURANCE COMPONENTS
. NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR A CONGREGATE
CARE SERVICES COMPONENTS. THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR A
COMPLEX CARE COMPONENT AND
THIRTY MILLION ENERAL FUND FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES
COMPONENTS. PROPOSAL TWENTY
SEVEN FULLY FUNDS THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL OR RFA PROGRAM.
SEE WDAM STFU FACED HEALTH I.
REQUEST ONE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO FUND
COUNTY ARE IF THEY COSTS THESE
COSTS HAVE NOT BEEN FUNDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO A
DISPUTED INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS OF
PROPOSITION THIRTY BETWEEN THE
COUNTIES AND THE ADMINISTRATION
. PROPOSAL TWENTY EIGHT SUPPORT
A CRUCIAL CARE COMPONENT IN THE
C. W. S. SERVICES CONTINUUM.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE CHINA THE
ONLY SERVICES AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER REQUEST
SEVENTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TWO AT A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE PORTION OF A CHILD'S
PLACEMENT RATE THAT GOES TO THE
FOSTER FAMILY. AGENCY THE
PROPOSED FUNDING WHAT AND WHEN
CDSS IMPLEMENTS A NEW RATE
SYSTEM WHICH IS EXPECTED BY THE
END OF THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL YEAR.
PROPOSAL TWENTY NINE TARGETED
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT FOR
USE IN LONG TERM FOSTER CARE.
THE CALIFORNIA LANDS A CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES REQUESTS ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND FORTY
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO CONNECT
YOU TO MEET SPECIFIC CRITERIA.
SUCH AS BEING IN FOSTER CARE FOR
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OR LONGER TO
FAMILY FINDING SERVICES.
PROPOSAL THIRTY. CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND FIFTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
TWENTY POINT THREE MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS ONGOING. BEGINNING
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO
DEVELOP A NEW CARE AND
SUPERVISION RATE. FOR SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
LAST YEAR TEEPEES. THE PROPOSAL
THIRTY ONE. INSTITUTIONS FOR
MENTAL DISEASE TRANSITION
FUNDING FOR S. YEAR TEEPEES
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES REQUEST TEN
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE TRANSITIONS S.
YOUR GP'S AT RISK OF BEING
DECLARED INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL
DISEASE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROGRAMMING AND MAINTAIN SYSTEM
CAPACITY FOR FOSTER. PROBATION
YOU. THE PROPOSAL THIRTY TWO
COVERT NINETEEN RELIEF FOR US
YEAR TEEPEES. CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REQUESTS SEVENTY THREE
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
BACKFILL EXISTING CORPORATE
RELIEF GRANT APPLICATIONS THAT
WERE NOT FULFILLED WITH THE
ALLOCATION PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
RIPPLES ALL THIRTY THREE.
BUILDING AND SUPPORTING FAMILY
HOMES FOR CHILDREN IMPACTED BY
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW REQUESTS SIXTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT OVER
THREE YEARS AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO USE
INNOVATIVE MODELS FOR COURAGE
AND SUPPORT FAMILY PLACEMENTS
FOR CHILDREN IMPACTED BY
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
THE THIRTY FOURTH PROPOSAL IS
PARENTS ANONYMOUS HELPLINE AND
ONLINE GROUPS. PERRANCE
ANONYMOUS REQUESTS FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS AND
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO SUPPORT
THE PARENTS ANONYMOUS HELPLINE.
THE PROPOSAL THIRTY FIVE. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES AUGMENTATION. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND STI YOU
REQUESTED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONGOING AND TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES DUE TO THE LOSS
OF FLEXIBILITY ASSOCIATED WITH
FEDERAL TITLE FORTY WAY FOR.
CRISTINA STANDARD FOSTER CARE
COSTS AND THE COSTS OF INFLATION
. THE PROPOSAL THIRTY SIX
INCREASING ACCESS TO POSITIVE
PARENT PROGRAMS AND FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. COUNSELING
OPTIONS AND PARENT EDUCATION
FAMILY SUPPORT CENTER FIRST FIVE
CONTRA COSTA FIRST FIVE SAN
BENITO FIRST FIVE SANTA CLARA
FIRST FIVE SANTA CRUZ FIRST FIVE
SOLANO FIRST FIVE. HAMMOND
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF SAN
DIEGO NAPA COUNTY TRIPLE PEAK
ELABORATIVE L. A. COUNTY LIBRARY
AND TRIPLE P. REQUESTS TWENTY
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO BE SPENT OVER THREE
YEARS TO INCREASE ACCESS FOR
PARENTS. AND CAREGIVERS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND FAMILY
SUPPORT AND DIRECTOR SPONSORED
THE INCREASED NEED. PROPOSAL
THIRTY. EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
DISASTER RESPONSE FUNDING FOR
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENT. CWPA
AND CHILDREN NOW REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND I'M GOING TO
FIND AT GENERAL FUND ONGOING
ISSUES NEED TO FUND DISASTER
RELATED WORK OUTSIDE OF REGULAR
COUNTY WORK ACTIVITIES.
COMPONENTS OF THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES FUNDING TO COORDINATE
EMERGENCY PLANNING RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY SUPPORT. JANE COUNTY
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS DEVELOP A
FUND TO SUPPORT COUNTIES
AFFECTED BY DISASTERS DURING A
DISASTER RESPONSE. GRANTS TO
MITIGATE URGENT NEEDS OF YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS. EIGHT I HSS
RECIPIENTS ESTABLISH A STATE
COUNTY PLANNING GROUP TO IMPROVE
DISASTER RESPONSE FOR PERSONS
LIVING IN POVERTY. AND CREATE A
TASK FORCE WITH COUNTIES AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ESTABLISH
DISASTER SUPPORT BENEFIT TO
SUPPORT TOWERS FAMILIES DURING A
DISASTER. THE PROPOSAL THIRTY
EIGHT INVESTMENT FOR STATE BY
DIAPER AND WIPE DISTRIBUTION.
CLYDEBANK DARTBOARD AND THE
NATIONAL DIAPER BANK NETWORK
REQUESTED TOTAL OF THIRTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT
OVER THREE YEARS AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXPAND THE DIAPER
BANK PROGRAMS STATEWIDE TO SERVE
THE REMAINING COUNTIES OUT. AND
THAT CONCLUDES THE STATE COURT
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SHORT AND THANK YOU TO THE
ENTIRE DIVISION THERE OF- THE L.
A. O. WE APPRECIATE- YOU DOING
THAT FOR US TODAY OKAY NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND I'LL REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
YOU DO HAVE ONE MINUTE TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS- WE'RE GONNA START
HERE WITH THAT PEOPLE IN. IN THE
CHAMBER BUT AS THE FIRST PERSON
TO COME FORWARD AND LET'S GET
STARTED. GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
OUT OF CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT.
THE PROPOSAL UNDER THE H. CHI.
NUMBER FOUR- IT'S A PROPOSAL
THAT CAN'T KEEP UP WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF.
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION. AND
WE'RE LOOKING FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WE'RE CALLING IT OUR
LICENSURE PIPELINE SUPPORTED TWO
TWO ONE. FOUR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN LOAN FORGIVENESS FOR
THE CURRENT WORKFORCE. FROM
THESE DOLLARS WOULD ARGUMENT
EXISTING LOAN REPAYMENTS FOR
STUDENTS WORKING IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. AND NONPROFIT AGENCIES.
THAT COULD BE. DONE THROUGH
DIRECT PAYMENTS FOR A QUOTE. FOR
PAYMENTS TO QUALIFYING
PROVIDERS. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR CLINICAL STIPENDS FOR THE
SEARCH WORK FORCES WE SEE SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE AND SB TWO TWO
ONE BEING IMPLEMENTED IN THE
ELEVATED NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES IN THE STATE. IN THE
LAST THREE HUNDRED NINE FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR CURRENT
STUDENTS PURSUING LICENSURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT.
NEXT PERSON PLEASE. HE COULD
MORNING CHAIR THANK YOU FOR US
CALL US WORSE THE CAL CYCLE SO-
TO PIGGY BACK ON THAT WE ARE
ALSO SUPPORTING THE LICENSEE
APRIL HEALTH PROVIDERS WORKFORCE
PROGRAM LISTED UNDER H. GUYS THE
NUMBER TWO ITEM. ALONG WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT OTHER MERGING
FAMILY THERAPIST THE LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
AND OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS. WE DO THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT AS THE INCREASED
NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS BECOMES CLEAR AND
APPARENT THAT WE- PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
HOMEGROWN PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
TANGIBLE SUPPORT TO THOSE WHO
WANT TO WORK IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH. PUBLIC WORK OF THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
AS WELL AS ADDRESSING THE
CURRENT WORKFORCE NEEDS- AND
FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS TO
RESEARCH WORK FORCES. AND FUTURE
WORKFORCES PRETTY CLEAR PIPELINE
FROM GRADUATE EDUCATION TO
LICENSE PROVIDER IN THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SPACE. AND
OBLIGATE THESE FUNDS ONE TIME SO
THAT WE DO NOT OBLIGATE FUTURE
BUDGETS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS PERSON PLEASE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- COUNTY
DELGADO BEHALF OF TWO CLIENTS
WITH COMMENTS TODAY. ON BEHALF
OF THE THIRTY THREE DISTRICT
HOSPITALS OF THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR. BRIDGE LOAN PROPOSAL AS
THESE HOSPITALS TRANSITION FROM
THE PRIME TO Q. I. P. PROGRAM.
DID YOU ALSO SUPPORTS A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PROPOSAL ON THE MEDIKAL
EQUITABLE PAYMENT MODERNIZATION.
AND THE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION IN ADDITION THE HLF
ALSO REQUEST. SUPPORT FOR THE
PABLO VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. AND ON BEHALF OF
COLLECTIVE MEDICAL WE WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE I. T.
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. A GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED REDUCE HERE I'LL BE OF
THE- HIGH. SO AND THE OF TWO OUR
POLLS- FOR ITEM NUMBER NOW. FOR
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES-
THE MEDICAL- GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL THAT'LL HELP
ADDRESS THE STATE'S DIRE HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. BY
EXPANDING MEDICAL GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
INCLUDE COLLEGE BALL HOSPITALS-
WHICH WILL BRING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS AND YOU FEDERAL
FUNDING. A SECOND IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN- FOR DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE MEDICAL ADDICT
EQUITABLE PAYMENT MODERNIZATION
PROPOSAL- THAT ARE CREATED EQUAL
EQUITABLE ACCESS CREE MEDIC COW
FOR- FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES-
SYSTEMATIC UNDERFUNDING MEANS
THAT THOSE WHO. CARE FOR MEDICAL
PATIENTS ARE BEING BURST AT-
JUST SEVENTY FOUR CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR FOR THE COST OF CARE-
THIS RESULT IF YOU'RE RESOURCES
FOR KAREN CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- THIS
PROPOSAL MODERNIZE PAYMENT.
METHODOLOGIES AND MAKES PROGRESS
TOWARDS CREATING. EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- WE ALSO LACK OF
ECHO THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORMS. A SUPPORT FOR
THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
BRIDGE LOAN PROPOSAL THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING EGGMAN MALIR HERE A
SPOT. WHAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD OF
CALL. HERE IS A SPONSOR FOR
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO ABORTION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT IS CURRENTLY REVIEWING A
DIRECT CHALLENGE TO THE LONG
STANDING LEGAL PROTECTIONS AND
RUBIO WADE. SHOULD THE COURT
OVERTURN ROE OVER HALF THE
STATES IN THE COUNTRY GOING TO
LOSE ACCESS TO ABORTION.
IMPACTING OVER THIRTY SIX
MILLION AMERICANS. OF CALIFORNIA
PREPARES FOR THE INFLUX OF
PATIENTS COMING TO CALIFORNIA
FOR CARE WE'VE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE AND EXPAND ACCESS WHILE
ADDRESSING EXISTING BARRIERS TO
KERR CALIFORNIA. HAS HAD PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
THE FOLLOWING REQUESTS. FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THE EQUITY IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PAYMENT FOR
MEDICAL ABORTION PROVIDERS AND
EACH HAS. TWENTY MILLION FOR THE
RAPE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT ABORTION
ABORTION PROVIDERS WHO SEE
PATIENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY. TWENTY MILLION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PORTION
SUPPORT PLAN FOR ORGANIZATIONS
TO HELP PATIENTS WITH LOGISTICAL
PRACTICAL SUPPORT. AND TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE L. A. COUNTY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PILOT
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT. THE WORK OF
THE COUNTY TO ACT AS A HAVEN FOR
PATIENTS SEEKING ABORTION CARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE LOOK
FOR TO FUTURE DISCUSSION ON
THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PERSON PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR JUST AROUND
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION TO LEND SUPPORT FOR
TO THE PROPOSAL THAT WE ARE
SPONSORING. TO INCREASE- ACCESS
TO CARE FOR VULNERABLE
UNDERSERVED AND RURAL
POPULATIONS IN THE STATE. WE
ORDER SUPPORTER ON THE STRATEGIC
ONE TIME INVESTMENT. TO INCREASE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS THE FIRST A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR TO. BUILD
NEW AND EXPAND EXISTING I'M
DENTAL CLINICS AND OUTPATIENT
SURGERY CENTERS FOR PATIENTS
WITH SPECIAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
UNDER LUMINOUS I TO TREAT A
PATIENT HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS RIGHT NOW AND THEY'RE
OFTEN WAITING OVER A YEAR TO BE
IS- GIVEN ROUTINE DENTAL CARE.
THE EXPANSION OF SITES WILL
INCREASE SPEED. AND CAPACITY TO
TREAT THESE PATIENTS- WHO CAN'T
RECEIVE DENTAL CARE IN
TRADITIONAL SETTINGS EITHER
BECAUSE OF THEIR SPECIAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED. THE
SECOND IS A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
ASKED. TO CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM
FOR NEW COMMUNITY BASED CLINICAL
EDUCATION ROTATION PROGRAMS FOR
DENTAL STUDENTS. EXHORTATIONS
WILL- PLEASE THAT'LL STUDENTS IN
DESIGNATED UNDERSERVED AREAS
WHERE THEY WILL GAIN REAL A REAL
EXPERIENCE SERVING UNDERSERVED
PATIENTS AND THEN- ALSO-
INTRODUCING TWO NEW CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES- WHERE THEY OFTEN.
END UP STAYING IN THE STATE
AREAS AFTER GRADUATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE- PROPOSAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. THE MORE MANAGER
MATTHEW GALLAGHER ON BEHALF
COWBOY. OF THE THIRTY THREE PAGE
OPPOSE. FIVE PROPOSED I'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT THIS. THE FIRST IS AB
NINETY DAY TO PAY FOR HEALTH
CRISIS LINE. CALIFORNIA ONCE
DIVERT PEOPLE FROM OUR JAILS AND
HOSPITALS. AB NINETY DAYS A
GREAT PLACE TO START IT'S A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH WE URGE
FUNDING FOR THAT PROPOSAL.
SECOND AND THIRD PROGRAMS AND
LIKE THE OR PROPOSALS I'D LIKE
TO SUPPORTER THE LICENSE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. AND THE
PUBLIC BEHAVIOR HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE FOR LICENSE BE APRIL
PROFESSIONALS. AS ILLUSTRATED BY
THE AUDITOR'S REPORT IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE LPS HEARING THAT.
NINE CHAIR OVERSAW IT'S WE'VE
GOT THAT THOUGH THAT THE FUND.
THE FOURTH AND FIFTH PROPOSALS
I'D ASK THAT THEY BE FUNDED OR
THE MEDIC HELP YOUR SUPPORT
SPECIALTY CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
AND THE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
PEER TO PEER PILOT PROGRAM WE
KNOW PEER SUPPORT WORKS NEEDS TO
BE FUNDED IN CALIFORNIA AND AS
WE ADDRESS BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS
TO CALIFORNIA'S CLIENTS. WE URGE
THAT THESE PROPOSALS BEHIND
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PERSON PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS KEVIN AS
THEY ARE WITH THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA OF RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS THE FIRST
TIME AT THE BACK OF THE BUILDING
IS NICE TO BE BACK- DURING THE
PANDEMIC. EVERYTHING SHUT DOWN
IN MARCH FIFTEENTH. SAYS THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY THE
BOEING COMPANY THE WELFARE
RECIPIENTS. AND DURING THAT TIME
WE'VE WHAT WE'VE COME UP WITH A
BUNCH OF PROPOSALS. THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT HAPPENED THE
PANDEMIC. IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN AND THERE ARE EMBODIED IN
THE PROPOSES THAT WAS. PRESENTED
TO YOUR WITH SUPPORT THEM. AND
WE APPRECIATE IT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS PLEASE LET US KNOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WELCOME BACK. OKAY NOW WILL
GO TO THE PHONES MODERATOR ARE
OU THERE. YES I AM HERE MADAM
CHAIR OKAY HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. I AM SURE WE
HAVE FIFTY SIX IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND JUST AS A REMINDER
FOR EVERYBODY. THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER TODAY IS 844-291-6364 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE
THREE ONE TWO EIGHT THREE AGAIN
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE. TO EXPRESS
YOUR THOUGHTS TODAY IN A FAST
ENOUGH TIME WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTACT THE- COMMITTEE STAFF. AN
OPERATOR LET'S GO AHEAD OF THE
FIRST CALLER. THANK YOU AND I'LL
BE LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
HERE TO RETRIEVE. TWENTY FIVE.
BY TWENTY FIVE YOU'LL HAVE TO
READ. THREE Q. UP PLEASE. AND
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND THAT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
NOT ABOUT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DONNA
DENTON I'M FROM THE LOS ANGELES
CARE GIVER RESEARCH CENTER AND
I'M REALLY CALLING TO SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTER STATEWIDE.
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
INITIATIVES- AND THIS IS REALLY
TO DEVELOP. BOTH INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL PARTNERSHIPS AROUND D.
I. OR D. UNPAID FAMILY
CAREGIVERS AND UPHOLD THE
OVERALL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND
CALIFORNIA- NOTED THAT C. R.
C.'S BASED ON OUR DATA I HAVE TO
SAY THE VERY DIVERSE. OF CARE
GIVERS TO PERSON TO HAVE.
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS KOLKATA
DISEASE AN ADAGE THAT THAT
AFFECT BRING. AND 48% OF THE
POPULATION CURRENTLY IDENTIFIED
NONWHITES WHAT THEY DO. IS THE
ABILITY TO HAVE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE TAILORED AND
ACCEPTABLE TO THEM AND THE
FUNDING IS BEING REQUESTED FOR
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS WOULD HELP
BUILD ON THE FORTY YEARS.
OPERATIONAL EXPERIENCE THANK YOU
VERY. LARGE THE FAMILY. ASIA
THANK YOU MUCH THANKS CALLER.
THANK AND NEXT WILL GO TO LINE.
BY TWENTY FIVE YEAR IS UP PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL GOOD MORE THANK
JORDAN MY NAME IS BIG ONE THE
TECHNICAL ABOUT PARK OF THE OF
HOUSING PROGRAM STUDENTS ALL
THEM. AND INDIVIDUALS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THE FIRST A LONG.
THE PROPOSAL SPEAKING FIVE
AMENDED BY COUNTY CARE SERVICES
THE FUND CRITICAL GAPS IN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY ALL OPEN AND BASS
. OF. GAPWEB IN THE- IS THE
COMMUNITY. TO CREATE A PERMANENT
THE HOME TO FOR WHICH WILL
REMAIN REDUCE. THE BY TWENTY
TWENTY SIX REVERSE RACIAL BEFORE
THE HOME THE- TO PULL DURING
COULD BE. THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU SPEAK.
PROVIDED FOR ALL NEIGHBORHOODS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OPERATOR. BY
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
MY NAME IS JOHN HOLBY. ON BEHALF
OF SEXUALITY MEASURE CHESTER
COMMUNITY HEALTH SERVICES.
REDWOOD COAST MEDICAL SERVICES
AND PLUMAS DISTRICT HOSPITAL AND
MOUNTAIN VALLEYS WE WANT TO
SHARE OUR- STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE PROPOSED NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT MEDICAL.
PROVIDER DATA SHARING INCENTIVES
AND THEIR PRESSURE THIS
INVESTMENT WILL HELP ADVANCE
TECHNOLOGIES AND A TRACK PLANS
AND PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE NETWORK. SHARING NECESSARY
DATA SO THAT THE WHOLE CARE
TEAMS HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO DELIVER QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. AND QUALITY CARE TO
ALL PATIENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU HAVE A COME FROM
MINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MELISSA. AND I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION- WE HAVE SUPPORTERS
WHAT- ITEM ON THE LIST. THE
FIRST YOU ARE RELATED TO
MATERNAL MORTALITY MORBIDITY AND
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN THE TURNED
OUT COMBINED TELCORDIA- WE'RE
REQUESTING MATERNITY OUTCOME
DATA COLLECTION. BE FULLY FUNDED
. OB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN- WHICH
WOULD ALLOW- A COMPLETE PICTURE
OF WHAT MATERNITY OUTCOME BY
DEFAULT COULD FIND. MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT. WHEN AND
WHERE AND ALL THAT MOBILITY
HAPPEN- THE. IT'S A ONE
CALIFORNIA MOM ARE. FIFTY FIVE
MONTH YEAH AGAIN WHAT ON ADOPTED
THEM ON WHAT HOW DO YOU TO BE.
IN THE RANGE OF THE FAIR. IN THE
- CARE.
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GIVE US OUR MEALS. YES I
DID I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT WHEN IT
COMES TOMORROW I'M A POTENTIAL-
AND I'M GOING TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT TO FULLY FUND THE
PROVISIONS OF SB SIXTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA MONICA FACTS. HELLO
CALIFORNIA MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE TO DECREASE TO THIRTY STILL
THE BLACK INDIGENOUS RESIDENTS
OF HIGHER MORTALITY RATE THAN
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS WE
FUNDING TO. PROVISION WILL
INVEST IN A LONG HOW THREE
CLOSELY I CAN DISPARITIES IN
BIRTH OUTCOMES. I THAT YOU FROM
AND WHAT THREE THREE. WORK FOR A
FACT THE COUNTY. INTO MARCH HOW
IF YOU CAN USED INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF. ALL I
JUST ON BUDGET THEY ARE YOU TO
KEEP A WITH THE TO HER YOU'VE-
WILL BE AT THE- OF THE DECISION
. I THINK OF MY GANDHI WHO. THAT
YOUR MEASUREMENTS. CAN BE FOUND
IN HOW IT TO LOOK MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU FOR MUCH
THANKS CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU
HAVE COME MIND. YEAR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH- MY NAME IS GOING BROWN I'M
THE OF- OPEN WORLD ENTERPRISE.
WE'RE GOING TO. THE PROJECT
SEVENTY NINE YEAR REPORT UNITS
30% A ON MY BELOW IN WESTOVER
YOU CRY AREA. JOINING THEM ONE
PROPOSAL WHICH IS THE L. COUNTY
HEALTH CARE THIRTY ASIAN PEOPLE
CALL THEM. THAT MONEY THAT.
ALLOCATE CRABS NINE MILLION
DOLLARS THE THIRD NINE YEAR
BUILT PORTABLE HOW UNITS WE HAVE
THIRTY NINE. THE BALLOT WE NEED
SUPPORT UPPER TO KEEP THE RENTS
. WE'RE GOING TO READY TO GROUND
ABOUT ALL OF OUR AGENTS ON WE'RE
SO GRATEFUL TO TELL ME THE
HEALTH CARE. AND THE AGE HE
DIRECT CALLING GOING A IN OUR-
QUEST THAT WE ARE HOPE TO GET
ENOUGH TO OPERATE YOUR THIRTY
NINE YEARS SO WE CAN KEEP THE
RED THAT 30% AND BELOW WE WILL
HAVE A- BROUGHT LEVEL WILL HAVE
A MARKET AND OTHER BUSINESSES
THAT WILL BE SUPPORTED THAT WE
FINANCE FOR THE OWNERSHIP BUT-
CARS OTHER.
FUNDING AND OTHER CRITICAL
SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS. IN
PAST YEARS ONE OF MY MESSAGES
HAS BEEN THAT WE NEED TO ELEVATE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT OLDER
ADULTS. I THINK THAT HAS
HAPPENED AND WE'RE AT A POINT
RIGHT NOW WHERE THE IMPORTANT
THING TO DO IS ACTUALLY TAKE
ACTION. AND ELEVATE THE
INVESTMENT IN OLDER ADULT
PROGRAMS SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS ABOUT THERE'S FIVE
PIECES TO IT. CAN'T SPEAK TO ALL
OF THEM IN A MINUTE BUT I DO
WANT TO CALL OUT THE VOLUNTEER
AUGMENTATION COORDINATION.
PROPOSAL BECAUSE VOLUNTEERS ARE
ACTUALLY MANDATED TO DO
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL SERVICES IN A
VARIETY OF AGING PROGRAMS. AND
THIS WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COORDINATE AND ELEVATE THAT
EFFORT AND ALSO ADDRESSED THE
LOSS OF VOLUNTEERS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED DURING COPAYS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AT A
COMBINED FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS JEFF ONE
DOLLAR ON ELEMENT CERTIFIED
CHILDBIRTH EDUCATOR AND BIRTH
DOULA ISLAND HERE WITH OPEN
BETTER BIRTH FOUNDATION AND A
PROSPECTIVE PARENT MYSELF. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
FULLY FUNDING THE PROVISIONS OF
SB SIXTY FIVE CALIFORNIA
MONUMENTS ACT RT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED YOU DISPARITIES IN
MATERNAL HEALTH CRISIS ACCESS
NATIONALLY IS. NO EXCEPTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND HOW YOU GOT COME CAN IMPACT
NOT ONLY IMMEDIATE HEALTH BUT
ALSO FOR THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND
LONG TERM BUT I THINK HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO THE DISCUSSION OTHER
PROPOSALS. THAT WE'RE OFFERING
THAT YOU FUNDS THE MIDWIFERY ACT
WHICH IS TO EXPAND A VERY
EVIDENT BASED FRAMEWORK FOR. I'M
ALSO TO FOR THE COUNTY PEOPLE IN
IT WORKS REVIEW TO BETTER DAMAGE
PREVENT FETAL AND INFANT LOSS.
AND OFTEN TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT HELP ON A SO
THAT BETH CENTRAL. CAN RECEIVE
CARE AND REIMBURSEMENT THANK
SUPPORTING FAMILIES IN GETTING
HEALTHY EQUITABLE AND CHOICE
THANK OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
COME MINE SIXTY ALAINA OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHEN
CHARLES RIGHT ON BEHALF OF SOME
BY- IN STRONG OF PROPOSED ONE
POINT BY BILL DOLLAR. TAKEN THAT
FUNDING CREEK NINETY CUTTING
EIGHTY TWO SCHOOLS. SANTA PER
OTHER INSPECTION DISEASES. MY BY
A WITH IN TWENTY TWENTY OF MAY
IN TWENTY TWENTY IN RESPONSE THE
PAN WE SPECIFIC GOAL HELPING
BECAUSE VOLUME QUALITY PCR
TESTING. WELL WE BELIEVE THERE'S
A YOU CASE FOR ANTIGEN WITH PC
ARCHITECT WITH THE GOAL STANDARD
BECAUSE THE. THE FACT OF THE
CASE THAT THERE WILL BE A-
TOWARD THAT END WE BELIEVE THAT
RESULTS AROUND KIND OF WHAT THAN
TWENTY HOURS CRITICS FOR THE
RESULT TO BE MEANINGFUL. AFTER
THE DELTA AND- MAKAN SURGES
THANK BUT LAB NEED CAPABLE. THAT
IS TO BE SCALABLE QUICK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE ABILITY
TODAY THANKS CALLER PLEASE CHECK
BUT THERE. THANK YOU THAT'LL
COME FROM MINUS SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YES MEAN PALETTE ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN AGING WE
SUPPORT MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
HERE TODAY THAN A DENNIS THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
BUT PROVIDING COMMENT ON TO
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL. FIRST WITH
SUPPORT RAISING THE MAINTENANCE
NEED INCOME LEVEL 210038% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IN THE
MEDICAL SURE OF COST PROGRAM
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES SHOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO LIVE ON SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE CENTRAL CARE. SECOND
WE SUPPORT CREATING A RENTAL
SUBSIDY PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES WE ARE
IN A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. THE
MORE LIKELY TO BE ON HOUSE AND
IN NEED OF THIS CRITICAL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU VERY MUCH CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER COME
FROM NINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS. FIRST
THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SPONSORING CONTINUOUS MEDICARE
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
BETWEEN ZERO AND FIVE. PROVIDING
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE IS A
CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS ACHIEVING
HEALTH EQUITY FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
EXPERIENCING THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC DISPROPORTIONATELY.
MEDICARE COVERS A GREATER SHARE
OF FAMILIES OF COLOR INCLUDING
HALF OF ALL YOUNG CHILDREN AND
NEARLY HALF OF ALL BIRTHS
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA. REMOVING
ACCESS BARRIERS MEDIC HOW CAN
PLAY A UNIQUE AND CRITICAL ROLE
IN ADDRESSING THE STRUCTURAL
RACISM THAT HEALTH DISPARITIES
REPEAL AND THAT CO THAT HAS
EXACERBATED. THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IS ALSO SPONSORING
THE PROPOSAL FOR A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN INFANT AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE THAT DOES NOT CLEARLY
OUTLINED HOW IT WILL SERVE THE
CRITICAL NEEDS OF INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AS THE MAJORITY OF
FUNDING DIRECTED TO PROGRAMS
RELY ON PARTNERSHIPS WITH T. K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL SETTINGS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S GOING TO COME
FROM LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BUT I
THINK HE IN ON BEHALF OF THREE
CLIENT. SPONSORING BUDGET
REQUEST TODAY. FIRST CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTABLE COMMUNITIES FOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE ON PAGE THREE
QUICK QUESTION FIFTEEN MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. HUSSEIN AN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF INTENSIVE
COMMUNITY BASED AND DIRECTED
LOCAL HEALTH COALITION TO
IMPROVE SYSTEMATIC HELD OUT. IN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS.
NEXT FOR HELP PAYS THE STATE
ASSOCIATION PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
ON PAGE FOURTEEN. ASKING FOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE YOU NEED
TO PAY SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES THE PH
CS WITH INDICATED THEY WILL
ALLOW FOR OTHER PROVIDERS. THAT
HELP US ACCOMPLISH PATIENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND WE'D
LIKE TO KEEP THOSE. MAINTAIN
DELIVERY SYSTEMS MODERNIZE.
STAND FOR THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP ON PAGE NINETEEN
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
ON HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL. TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING PROGRAM
THAT'S PROVEN PROGRAM CARES
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS WITH
YOUNG FAMILIES TO IMPROVE
MATERNAL AND CHILD IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT OUTCOMES.
WE CAN REACH THOUSAND FARM
FAMILIES THE LIFELINE ABOUT
YOURSELF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CLEAR CONSIDERATION MAX.
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU GOAL
LINE OF EIGHTY THREE OH ONE OPEN
. BREXIT BEYOND HOW OF SEVERAL
FIRST UPON HER ABOUT HELPS
PROTECT PROJECT AND THE PANIC
CAN BOARD OF TO PROVIDE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE MILLION TO THE FOR.
LOOKING AT HOW. BOB DOLE
INCIDENTS HEALTHCARE PROVIDER IN
REGION PRIMARY LOW AND UNDER A
I'M SURE POPULATION OF COLOR.
SECOND THE CALIFORNIA AT THE POP
PUBLIC PUBLIC. IN SUPPORT OF THE
FUTURE PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING PROVIDE MEDICAL. AND THE
FUTURE MEDICAL AFFORDABLE HIM
THAT MOTHER. PROPOSAL WELCOME
COUPLED HOSPITALS THEIR FINANCE
CHALLENGES- THE CHILD SUPPORT
WITHOUT THE ASIAN COUNTY CAL AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOR THE TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR AND
UPCOMING CHILD OR EVEN PEOPLE
OUT URBAN COUNTY COMING. A
CALLED AND THANK ALTHOUGH BIRTH
PUBLIC HEALTH HERO AND INSTEAD
BY FONG MEDICAL CARE SUPPORT
ALAMEDA COUNTY FIVE NINE DOLLAR
A HOW MUCH OF THE AGRICULTURE.
AND THE CAB DURING FOR A THE
PROPOSAL FINALLY URBAN HOW.
BOARD IF YOU GET A PROPOSAL
ADDRESS GAP IN ON AND IF YOU A
DATE COULD. FOR RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL THANK YOU BOOM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR.
TWENTY EIGHT. EMERGENCY SOUTH
THIRTY. FORMER THING THERMOSTAT
THE BOSTON CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
PAGE THIRTY BOYFRIEND RESEARCH
FAMILY APPROVAL PAGE THIRTY AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND DISASTER
RESPONSE FUNDING NINETY ONE FOR
DEPARTMENT AGE THIRTY TWO YOUR
COMMITTEE AND STAFF HAVE PAPER
ON ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS WE
SUPPORT COMMENTS ON- WITH THE
RATE THE BANK WHAT A NO OF OTHER
BY THE EXTENT AND WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP IN WRITING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THOSE ITEMS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WELCOME
MY NAY TWO LINE OF THE- THANK
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS THE ONE
THAN AT THAT CALIFORNIA'S.
POLICY CENTER I AM CALLING TO
COMMON SUPPORT OF THREE ISSUES.
FOR A THREE SHOT LEAD URGING
ADOPTION FOR ALL IN REMOVING THE
GREEN INCLUDING THE FACT FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF AGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
THE POWER TO MAKE FEEDBACK MARK
WITH THAT AND BE A MODEL FOR THE
REST OF THE NATION. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING ON THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR TO MAINTAIN AND
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL POLITICAL
INVESTORS FOR HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR TO AT LEAST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. OF COURSE
THEY WANT PROGRAM COULD SPEND
AFFECT INNOVATION PARABLE IN
UNDER THIRD RURAL REGION OF THE
STATE INVESTMENT WHEN SHORT AT
THE REPORT THAT WE STOP AREAS
THAT NEED IN OUR- FLAG WE ARE
FOR TWENTY FOUR MILLION. FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AND MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT. AND
THE WITH COMPETENT OUTREACH AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AND
INDIVIDUAL THE ONLY FOR MEDICARE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN DURING ACT THAT THE
MEDICARE. WE ARE PLEASED THIS.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MEXICO
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT A
COMPROMISE ONE HOW. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH GOOD MORNING
REPRESENT CHILDREN IN THEIR
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL THAT WORKS
AND I JUST WANTED BECOME ONE
TODAY THEY THE CHAPTER BRIDGE
FOR- CHOLISH REQUIRE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY EIGHT NINE.
RENDON THE GAP IN RETIREMENT NOT
MUCH BETTER. FORTIETH YOU.
INTERNET NEED THIRD THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED. ON YEAR YEAH FIVE
HUNDRED OF THESE ARE PERCENT OUT
AND HIT THEIR MONTH. CAP. IN
NEED OF SUPPORT THEY MIGHT BE
SIMPLY OF DO YOU RESEARCH SHOWS
ANYTHING STAGE OF. AND I WENT.
THE FUND FOR TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING THAT FOCUSED NOT ON
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. AND THINK
OF A RESILIENT THINKING OF THE
CHILDREN ABOUT THE GOOD THING ON
YOUR ENERGY. TRAUMA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT COME FROM
EIGHTY SIX AIRLINERS- OPEN. I
WAS THE JACKSON GARRETT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT WE SUPPORT SO I'M
JUST GONNA LIST THEM OFF
QUICKLY. AS THE SECOND
COSPONSORING THREE PROPOSALS
THAT CALIBRATION MINISTRATION
FUNDING PATCH. ONLY FROM THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROGRAM
AND INCREASE LOCAL TRANSPORT
FUNDING TO ADDRESS FUNDING
INEQUITIES IN OPERATIONAL COSTS.
IN ADDITION WE SUPPORT
CONTINUATION ENHANCEMENT OF
MIDDLESEX SERVICES TRAINING
SOCIAL WORKERS. ACCORDING TO
SERVICES AND DISASTER RESPONSE
FUNDING FOR COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT. CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM BRIDGING SERVICE GAPS
ACOSTA CHILDREN FAMILIES. PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE MEDI CAL
PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EQUITY AND READING THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE.
AMERICANS MINUTE ONE HOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CAN BE
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN MUST BE CARE COALITION
VOICING OUR SUPPORT FOR
PROPOSALS THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN AND YOU. FIRST WORK.
YEAH TRICKS FACULTY CARE
PHYSICIAN NETWORK WHICH PROVIDE
CARE TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
CHRONIC AND COMPLEX CONDITIONS
MANY OF WHOM ARE INVOLVED IN PCS
THE MEDIC HELD AND A MAJORITY OF
WHOM WERE CHILDREN OF COLOR.
THERE ARE WIDESPREAD RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION CHALLENGES THAT
ARE HAVING A CONSEQUENTIAL
IMPACT ON ACCESS TO CARE. IT'S
RATE READY PROVIDER HAVE NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED AND TWENTY. AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL INCREASE THE CURRENT
PCS RATE AUGMENTATION. TO BRING
RATE COMPARABLE TO MEDICARE
LEVELS IT WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED
STABILITY TO THE POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION NETWORK. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE FOLLOWING PROPOSAL.
MEDIC HOW EQUITABLE PAYMENT
MODERNIZATION CONTINUOUS MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
INCREASED ACCESS TO SPECIALTY
CARE AND MEDIKAL REFINING THE
HEARING AID FOR CHILDREN PROGRAM
AND SPECIAL NEEDS DENTISTRY
EXPANSION THANKS SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU COME FROM ONE
TEN LINE IS A- GOOD MORNING
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY COMING ON
MULTIPLE ITEMS WE REQUEST
FUNDING TO UPDATE THE MEDICARE
SHARED COST PROGRAMS SO THAT LOW
INCOME SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. ARE NOT EXPECTED
TO LIVE OFF OF SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH AND PAY OVER
HALF THEIR INCOME TAX THAT'S
MEDIC HEALTH SERVICES IT'S TIME
TO DITCH THE DEDUCTIBLE AND MAKE
THAT A CALIFORNIA LAW WE REQUEST
BOTH FUNDING SB SIXTY FIVE TO
ADDRESS DISPARITIES IN BIRTH
OUTCOMES BY FINDING THE FETAL
INFANT MORTALITY REVIEW
COMMITTEES. MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND MEDICARE DO A
SERVICES FINALLY WE ALSO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR CONTINUE WITH
MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
SERVICES PROGRAM EXTENSION
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS
HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU COME FROM ONE TO YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
EGGMAN DARBY KERNAN I THINK THAT
THE FIND ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
PLANS ON SEVERAL ISSUES BOTH
FITTED INTO ONE MINUTE. ON
BEHALF OF FIRST BY THE BILL
SEEKING ONE WHICH ARE SUPPORT
THE COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
SERVICE PROGRAM EXTENSION ON
SPENDING AND SPENDING ON PAGE
SEVEN THE MEDIC CAL CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
THERE ARE FIVE ON PAGE NINE.
WELL THE INTERNET EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND PROVIDER TRAINING PROPOSAL
ALSO ON PAGE NINE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FOOD MEDICINE
COALITION ONE OF WHICH ARE
SUPPORT FOR THE NO COST
EXTENSION. OF THE MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS INTERVENTION
PROGRAM ON PAGE EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
NETWORK WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL. IT YOUR HOME
THAT PROVIDE THE INDIVIDUAL WITH
DEVELOP DISABILITIES PAGE ALLY.
IN ADDITION TIME FOR TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE BAY BUT IT GOT THE
NEEDS OF THE WITH. AND BY. ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND IF
YOU WANT TO BUY SUPPORT FOR THE
FOURTH. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA YEAH
REGISTRY. ON EIGHT EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. NINE O'CLOCK TO WORK
IN THE WELL I JUST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
HAVE COME FROM ONE. YEAR LINE
OPEN. THANK YOU CHEN PROBABLY ON
A BENDER POLICY AFFAIR WITH BY
WHICH STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
BUDGET FOR PROPOSED FROM THE
THAT BUT- SHIN NURSE FOR. AND
CAL SO SHE OF BANKS FIVE THE
SOCIAL WORKING LOW IN FRANCISCO
AND NEEDS. PROVIDE A VARIETY OF
LOS COFFEE SERVICES TO THE MOST
PHONE COMMUNITIES OUR DAILY FOR
ELSE FOR HAVE NO ELIGIBLE- FOR
PROVIDING THREE MAJOR MEALS DAY
. THE FOURTEENTH YEAR AN ENTRY
FOR MANY OF OUR OTHER THAT ARE
HARM REDUCTION CONDUCT OUT
ACTIVITIES OFFERS OF YOU. OVER
FOR THE FIVE APPALLED. THANK IT. AND REPRESENTATIVE FOR BETWEEN
. TO MEET THE GROWING OR DOING
LAST WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE
CALIFORNIA THREE IMPACT. TRUST
THE ON CRISIS BUBBLE OVERDOSE
DEATH ACTUALLY I HIV AND BY
HEPATITIS IN FACT. WEISBERG'S TO
CARRY AN IMAC WITH IN EARNINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU. THANK
YOU ARE COME FROM MINE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINER OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MY NAME IS
BRODER AND I'M STILL ON BEHALF
OF FIRST BY PERCENT INCREASED
WHILE HE'S A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU. WE WANT A
HIGHLIGHTER SUPPORT FOR A FEW IN
PER FOR CAN TO MEDIC COVERAGE
FOR YOUNG. THE PROPOSAL FOR-
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH IN
PROVIDERS. AND IMPORT TO PROPOSE
FUNDING FOR THE POWER VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DOES TO PURCHASE THE
WATSONVILLE COMMUNITY HOSPITAL I
ALSO WANT TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAMS AND FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. IN NINE
COUNTIES INCLUDING OUR OWN IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WE HAVE HAD
REMARKABLE SUCCESS IMPLEMENTING
POSITIVE PARENTING AND FAMILY
SUPPORT PROGRAMMING WOULD
DEMONSTRABLE REDUCTIONS IN
PARENTAL STRESS ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION ALL THE WHILE
WATCHING OUR COUNTY'S RATE OF
SUBSTANTIATED CHILD MALTREATMENT
FALL FROM SIGNIFICANTLY ABOVE TO
SUBSTANTIALLY BELOW THE
STATEWIDE RATE. THE FUNNY
PROVIDE IN THIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS
TO EXPAND. AND ENHANCE THIS
PROGRAM TO THE BENEFIT OF MORE
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL BE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SNYDER ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STAKEHOLDER ITEMS
TODAY THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY REFORM PROPOSAL AND
ALSO INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED RIGHT
EQUITY PROPOSAL WITH RESPECT TO
THE FIRST ITEM STILL THERE IF
YOU REFORM THE PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES A CALF BELIEVES ARE
CRUCIAL FIRST STEP STRUCTURE THE
NURSING FACILITY CAN BETTER
SUPPORT. AND GROW THEIR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE INCREASED CLINICAL
QUALITY AND STUDY APPROPRIATE
CLINICAL STAFFING STANDARDS THE
LAST TWO YEARS OF THE
CODEPENDENT MAKE IT FURTHER
DEVASTATED LONG TERM CARE
WORKFORCE WITH THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED TEENAGE LEAVING THE
PROFESSION BUT JUST BETWEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE. SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH
100% GOVERNMENT FUNDED AND THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERFUNDS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND MAKES IT NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO PAY
COMPETITIVE WAGES SO WE REALLY
HOPE THAT THE ADOPTION OF THIS
REFORM PROPOSAL WILL ADDRESS THE
CURRENT WORKFORCE CRISIS THE
WESTERNERS INCOMES BEYOND. THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC RELATED TO THE
SECOND ITEM AND INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED STUFF
LIKE OUR NURSING HOME THEY'RE
DEVASTATED THE FINDING AND
TRYING TO FIND THEIR NUMBERS AND
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO THAT THE
COMPANY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL
HAVE ONE THAT FULLY. RELIANT ON
THAT. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AT A COME FROM ONE TWENTIETH
YEAR LOSS IS OPEN. MORNING CARE
EGGMAN CHAIRED CALL WITH CAL
COMMENT HE THE PORT OF THE FOOD
AND NUTRITION PROPOSED ON TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SPECIFICALLY WE
SUPPORT THE FOOD FOR ALL
EXPANSION TO ALL WHO WOULD CARE
THREE MEALS FOR KIDS IN
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE ALONG
WITH OUR CO SPONSORS THAT THE T.
EIGHT YEAH THE ROUNDTABLE. THE
CALIFORNIA FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS EXPANSION
AND INCREASING RESOURCES FOR OUR
FOOD BANK THROUGH THE HELP THE
PROGRAM WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE HEALTH FOR ALL OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM ON PAGE TEN.
REPORTER WORKING WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ENSURE OUR STATE
HAS AN EQUITABLE NUTRITION
SAFETY NET THAT IS THERE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY NEED HELP
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEDICAL MINE ONE
TWENTIETH. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON THE TWO BORING THANK
YOU CALLING ON BEHALF BOTH THE
COUNTY FORM AND THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE REGARDING OUR
ORGANIZATION COSPONSORED NINETY
HERE HEALTH CRISIS LINE PLANNING
AND SPENDING PROPOSAL.
CONFOUNDERS WE HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL SHORT TERM
FUNDING FOR CALL CENTERS AND
THREE ONGOING A COORDINATED
DONALD OUTCOME NINE EIGHT WILL
FIT WITHIN OUR BROADER HEALTH
REFORM AND THE INVESTMENT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY MADE. CALL
CENTERS MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS
INCREASES THE BUILDINGS ARE
BEING BUILT NOW AND THEN
CRISTINA COORDINATION BETWEEN
THESE SOCIAL COMPONENTS WITH
URGENT THAT'S WEIRD INCLINATION
OKAY MICHAEL PROCESS. THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTED FIANC
ONLINE EARLY FROM THE GAPS IN
OUR NINETY AM OF AUTHORIZED BY
THE NATIONAL HOTLINE EDUCATION
ACT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND IT CONNECTS. THANKS
CALLER COME FROM MINE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS IN A ONE. A. R.
P. CAL. ON BEHALF THE AIR JOHN
THREE IN THE MEMBERS AND ALL
ADULTS IN THE STATE. THERE ARE
PEOPLE. ONE TIME FOR FIVE
MILLION ALLOCATE FROM THE FUND
OVER THREE YEARS PROVIDE
STUDENTS CAN THE LOCAL BILL ON
UNITS OF ALL THE- FOR THE PONS
OF PLANNING DEVELOPING FROM.
PLANS ARE GOING OKAY R. O. I
WOULD CAL THE NEW PERCENTAGE OF
ALL CALIFORNIA VISITING RAPIDLY
. AND OF MOTHER IS DONE THE
DEMOCRATS SHALL SHIFT BE ON
AFFORDABLE AND ON TOP. THERE ARE
PEOPLE OF THE HEALTH. DROP
COUNTRY CAL. ON THE NETWORK OF
IT STATE THAT CAN BE IN A-
CENTER THREE THOUSAND FIFTEEN
OVER FIFTEEN FIVE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IS WHAT PERCENT OF
THE TWENTY THREE MILLION OF THE
POP FIT POPULATION HAVE ENROLLED. IN THE NETWORK. THE PRODUCT IS
NOW WORK ON. JOINING INVOLVE A
MULTI PROCESS. THE REASON THAT
WE OVER FIVE CALIFORNIA GIVE ME
. ARE DEVOUR HAVE THAT MAY CAL
COMMUNITY DO NOT HAVE VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU I ONE TWO FIVE OF THE
- THANK. GOOD ON AFTERNOON IS A
MAC MILLAN- MARCH OF DIMES I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF FOR- THE
COLDER PROPOSAL. THE FIRST ONE
IS A- PERINATAL SIR PRO OR SEPIA
P. X. THE NEXT OF THE KIN.
MEDICAL FOR AGES ZERO TO FIVE.
ON THE NEXT ONE IS THE MATERNITY
OUTCOMES DATA COLLECTION. AND
ALSO WE SUPPORT FULLY FUNDING
THE CALIFORNIA MOM THE BUS ACT
SB SIXTY FIVE AND FINALLY MARCH
OF DIMES WISHES YOU A VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY DEAR EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OF OUR LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO
HAVE A SUMMIT. I DID HI MY NAME
IS MICHELLE AND SURE BLACK
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE OUR
PROPOSAL TO REFINE THE HEARING
AID COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
PROGRAM IS SUPPORTED BY TWENTY
SIX ORGANIZATIONS IN PEDIATRIC
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE STATE-
THE PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO SERVE
SEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN UP TO
SIX HUNDRED. I'M PERCENT FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVELS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR CVS NINE ONE CANNOT ONLY
FORTY SIX CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
ENROLLED AND THERE ARE ONLY
SEVEN CHILDREN WE KNOW A LOT OF
THAT HAVE RECEIVED HEARING AIDS.
THERE'S NO- PROVIDERS IN FIFTY
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY I
CENTERS WHO HAVEN'T SIGNED ON
STATE ESSENTIAL PEDIATRIC CODE
HAVEN'T BEEN APPROVED AND RATES
ARE EVEN LOWER THAN GPS WILL DO
NOT SUPPORT PEDIATRIC CARE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY LAW
PROVIDERS MUST BE A LICENSE
AUDIOLOGIST TO SEE CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF FIFTEEN AND
WITHIN PCS YOU NEED TWO YEARS.
OF EXPERIENCE WITH CHILDREN THIS
ISN'T HER CHILDREN ARE SEEN BY
PROVIDERS WORK IN PEDIATRIC CARE
BACK PRACTICES HACCP
REIMBURSEMENT SHOULD ACCOUNT FOR
THE EXTENSIVE PROFESSIONAL TIME
AND RESOURCES NEEDED TO SUPPORT
PRENATAL AND INFANT CHILDREN
SHRINK THAT IS READY MONEY TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH PCS IN ORDER TO
MAKE IT. FINANCIALLY VIABLE FOR
MORE PEDIATRIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR THREE LINE
A OPEN. GOOD MORNING NOW CHAIR
ON WITH THE HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CAN'T WAIT COALITION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR HERO
INITIATIVE THIS INITIATIVE
REQUEST ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
I IN GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC HEALTH RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. TRAINING FOR SKILLED
POSITION AND INVEST IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINE
FOR CALIFORNIA LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN
PROTECTING LIVES ENSURING HEALTH
EQUITY AND AVOIDING ACCESS
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC DESTRUCTION
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK THAT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE BE
PRIORITIZED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE-
COME FROM MINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR PRESTAR
PRETTY IN BEHALF OF YOUR CLIENTS
FIRST DHS PROPOSAL THIRTY ONE
AND A HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS. WILL PROBABLY
JOIN OUR OTHER POSITION CALLING
FROM THE HEALTH MEDICINE
REQUESTING FULL RESTORATION THE
10% MEDICAL POSITION RATE CUTS
INSTITUTED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN BY WAY OF AB NINETY
SEVEN. SDL JUST SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ON THE FRONT LINES THE
COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
MANAGING CARE FOR THE SICKEST
PATIENTS IN THE ICU SECOND THE
ACS PROPOSAL NUMBER SIX I'M
HAPPY CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN
PROSTHETIC ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
REQUEST FULL RESTORATION THE 10%
MEDICAL PROVIDER RATE CUTS FROM
PRODUCT PERSPECTIVE LIFE IS. IN
REQUESTED MEDICAL REGIONAL
REPUBLICAN PERSPECTIVE I CAN BE
SET AT 80% OF THE MEDICARE
ALLOWABLE RATE. I CAN PROSTHETIC
MY BREAK RANGE FOR NINE OUT OF
FIFTY ONLY OUT ON BY FLORIDA.
WHAT PRESIDENT PROVIDERS THE
INFORMATION. CUP MINDS OF THE
BROTHER BY. AND RESTORING THE
FUND FOR MEDIC PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM DEFECTS. AND
DIABETES WITH INTO. THANK YOU.
THREE SECONDS LEFT PLUS A HAPPY
THANK BRYCE CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU DON'T COME FROM NINE ONE
THIRTY NINE YOU'RE GOING TO
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
COMMITTEE MONEY BECAUSE ARE AND
I AM AND I THAT PROVIDER FROM
I'LL DRAW COUNTY. DURING LAST
YEAR'S COVER MAKING MY HOW YOUR
BACK. FOR SIXTEEN. IN ADDITION
TO KNOWING IF WE HAVE HOW TO
KERR HOME TO THE UNEXPECTED
EXPENSE OF HOTELS EATING OUT
ADDED TO THE STRESS OF THE
SITUATION I RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL FOR DELYLAH DISASTER
RELIEF. FOR IHS THAT PROVIDERS
DURING EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOURTIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT'LL
COME FROM WINE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT AFTERNOON
THANK YOU JACQUELINE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HOPE CAME ARE CALLING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NINE TWO
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BRINGING FORTH
PROPOSALS THEY'LL THE CARE
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN TO THAT
AND WE ARE PROUD TO CARRY THE
FOLLOWING BEGINNING PAGE THIRTY.
STABILIZE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
TARGETED FAMILY FINDING AN
ENGAGEMENT DISCREPANCIES AND ASK
YOUR GP CARE THE PROVISION I
INDEED CONDITION PUTTING
PRESSURE TEEPEES COVERED REALLY
PRESSED YOUR GPS AND
STRENGTHENING FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER. FURTHER WE PROBABLY
SUPPORT THE NINETEEN EIGHTY REAL
HEALTH CRISIS LINE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS VERY
CRUCIAL ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS COLOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU AT A COME FROM MY ONE- OH
FOUR LINE IS. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
REBEKAH GONZALEZ FOR THE NASA
ANTHEM OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER RIGHT NOW I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND CALTECH
CALIFORNIA LICENSE PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELOR. ALONG WITH I
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
AND CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION ON THE SECOND ITEM
UNDER H. CHI- THIS IS THE TWO
TWO ONE PROPOSAL FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. I DON'T
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE
MANY WORTHY WORKFORCE PROPOSALS
OUT THERE BUT THIS ONE IS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON IS A
LICENSED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
WORKFORCE THE OTHER ITEM I WANT
TO COMMENT ON IT IS THAT SUPPORT
FOR CRUCIAL CARE COMPONENT IN
THE C. A. W. AFTER BIRTH OF
CONTINUE ON WE ARE CO SPONSORING
THIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. THAT'S WHAT ADDED COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
PORTION OF THE CHILD PLACEMENT
RATE THAT GOES TO FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES. ADDED AS ONE PDF THAT
IMPLEMENT THE NEW BRAKE SYSTEM
I. ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT SYSTEM THE C. TEN
PROPOSALS AS TO FOR ALL AND
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WELFARE
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL. TODAY NEXT CALL
PLEASE. BETTER COME FROM MINE
TWENTY SIX CAROLINA OPEN. BANNON
I'M ON BEHALF OF THE DIRECTOR OF
THE TYPE OF THREE IN I YEAH.
THERE IS A VITAL NEED FOR A RARE
THAT IS DISEASE THAT BY COUNCIL
ARE JACQUI. OR IN ME ONE OUT OF
TEN PEOPLE LIVE WITH THE RAID.
OUR BUDGET REQUEST BECAUSE
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF FROM
LAST YEAR'S EVENT APPROACH
ACCIDENTALLY SB TWO SEVEN TO
CREATE AN ORDER WITH THE-
SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY BUT WITH THE
HELD Y THE GOVERNOR WITH
ACTUALLY UTILIZE THE BUDGET
PROCESS. BEYOND HUMAN SUFFERING
RARE DISEASE PLACE OF THE
FINANCIAL UPON PATIENTS FAMILY
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
YOU CAN ADVOCATE THANK RECEIVER
HIKE YOURSELF WITH THAT TESTS
PROCEDURE TOPFLIGHT BASINS TRUST
ME DARK IN. 35% REGULATORS HAVE
THAT FTA THERAPIES IN THE LATE.
AND PROPER CARE DOCTOR THE
FINANCE BURDEN FAMILIES IN THE
STATE. A RECENT STUDY AT THE
CALL READY IN THE U. S. B. AND
NINE FIFTY BILLION. I REQUEST
PALES IN COMPARISON TO THE-
FINANCIAL ABOUT THE- MIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL TODAY MEXICO PLEASE.
AT NE POINT EIGHT MILLION FROM
THE REGISTRY REPRESENTING
TWENTY. 27% OF THEIR OVERALL
BUDGET WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU
REJECT THEM CUT THEM GOODBYE SIX
POINT SIX MILLION TO MAKE THE
REGISTRY CALL. REGISTRY ALSO
DRAWS DOWN SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDING. BY PROVIDING A MATCHING
FUNDS BY CUTTING THE BUDGET.
WILL BE PUTTING THEM AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR FEDERAL MATCHING
FUNDS- WE DO AS A REMINDER HOW
THE LARGEST REGISTRY IN THE
CANCER REGISTRY IN THE NATION.
ONE OF THE LEADING CANCER
REGISTRIES IN THE WORLD. WITH
THE APPROPRIATE ONGOING FUNDING
THE REGISTRY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES THAT WOULD
PROVIDE. REAL TIME DATA FOR
RESEARCHERS IN CLINICAL TRIALS.
BUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MAKE
OUR REGISTRY AND OUR FUTURE
CANCER CARE. COLD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LETTER
COME FROM MY ONE FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS UP. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRICKIER TRADES ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AT LEAST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION I'M GOING TO CREATE A
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND. THE FUND WILL INVEST
DIRECTLY IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
INEQUITIES. IN RACIAL INJUSTICES
AND DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THEM IN THIS TIME OF THE
TREMENDOUS BUDGET SURPLUS WE
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR BOTH
GOVERNMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO ADVANCE
EQUITY AND JUSTICE. IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE AN EITHER OR WE ARE
ALL PUBLIC HEALTH WE ALL HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY AND WE WORK BEST
AND FOR THE MOST PEOPLE WHEN ALL
THE PUBLIC HEALTH IS FULLY
FUNDED AND WORKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I GET A COME
FROM LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THERE'S
THEMSELVES- CHECK THEM AT THE US
I'M A DIRECTOR AT TLC CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. FOR BUT IF YOU
ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT A
CRUCIAL CARE COMPONENT IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES CONTINUE
ON- SPECIFICALLY TO STABILIZE A
FACE WITH A COLA- THAT BEING
SAID AS TO WHY- WE I PERSONALLY
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN FOSTER
CARE FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I'VE SEEN- COME AND GO I'VE ALSO
SEEN THE INCONSISTENCY OF
SERVICE- THE CRIME ON THE
INCREASE FROM OTHER CAUSES TO
OUR- YOUNGEST- AND MOST.%
VULNERABLE CHILDREN SO- WITH
THAT SAID- WE'RE ALSO AN
EMERGENCY FAMILY AND WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE OF REFERRALS.
FOR KIDS THAT ARE COMING INTO
OUR SYSTEM SO WITH THAT AGAIN
YEAH ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND OUR SOCIAL WORKERS THAT. YOU
WOULD CONSIDER SUPPORTING. THANK
YOU VERY FOR YOUR TODAY. THANK
YOU WELL COME FROM MINE ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SURE BRIAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STITCH NINE SPORT THE SEVENTEEN
HALF MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
HALF WHICH A FEDERAL FUNDS.
INCLUDE MEDICAL GLOBAL OBSTETRIC
LATE SO THEY LINE WITH MEDICARE
IT ALSO SPORTS NURSE MIDWIFE
PROPOSAL THE FUND MATERNITY
OUTCOMES DATA COLLECTIONS DETAIL
THE TWELVE THREE SEVEN. AND THEY
JOINED THE CALIFORNIA KODIAK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE RESTORATION OF
THE E. B. 9017% MEDICARE
REDUCTION PREPOSITION SERVICES
ON A GLOBAL PAYMENT POLICIES GET
INTO DRIVING PROVIDERS HAVE THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM. ALL THREE LEAD
TO A SMALLER POOL OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS CARING FOR THESE
OCCUPATIONS WHEN YOU BETTER TO
SERVE IN TREATING FORMAL
POPULATION AND THIS COLD WILL DO
JUST THAT I APPRECIATE
CONSIDERATION THANK EVERY TIME
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RIGHT THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE IN A CALL
WILL COME FROM ONE. TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TARA GAMBLE EACH MEMBER OF THE
SPINE BERG INSTITUTE REQUESTING
SUPPORT FOR SPONSORED PROPOSAL
TO STABILIZE AND REVITALIZE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. IN
THE AGENDA OF THE PROPOSALS WILL
SET UP A REQUEST RELATED TO THE
MEDIC HOW PEER SPPORT
SPECIALIST CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE REQUEST TO
THE BROADER COMPANION CHART
BARTERED BELL AT THE NINE SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR WIENER SHREDDING
COMPASS IS A HOLISTIC PACKAGE
AND THE MEDIA AT MEDIUM AND LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS. TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE THESE INCLUDE EXPANDING
THE- PROGRAM STATEWIDE AS WELL
AS CREATING A FRENCH RETAIN
WORKERS PROVIDING SOCIAL WORK
SPACE AND CREATING XCELERATED
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND MORE. COPY
THE PROPOSAL WILL BE SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE MILLION GENERAL
FIND OUT OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS AND SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ON GOING FURTHER
CLARIFYING THAT WEIRD THAT
DEFINED AGAIN IF YOU THAT. BUT
QUIET THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU B.
ONE FIFTY FVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE. NINE WERE DELL OKAY
GIVER FIRST NOT I CALL AND THE
COURT OF THE CALIBER CARE GIVER
BRIEF CENTER DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION IMAGE THAT. HELLO
HELLO TEST. WEIGHT PROGRAM INTO
SOME CRITICAL TARGETED CALENDAR
SIR GRAMLEY CAREGIVERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IN TOWN
THIS REQUEST REPORT THE CALL FOR
YOU MASTER PLANNED FOR EIGHTEEN
EFFORT TO BEAT THE ICE CREAM
MARKET ALL SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
FOR OLDER ADULTS. YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON
BIRTH THAT MARA DINNER POLICY
COORDINATOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
ADVOCATE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ADVOCATES WHO REPRESENT
MORE THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TWENTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA. WELL I DIDN'T SEE
THE FOR BACK IN CALIFORNIA
CALLED WORK WORK. MORE TARGETED
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
WORSENING WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
THAT EXISTED BEFORE THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE SHORTAGE
JEOPARDIZING THE CARE I THANK
YOU FOR PATIENCE AND WELL
CALIFORNIA AND AREAS OF UNMET
MEDICAL NEEDS. THE SHORTAGE AND
pASKED THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO SUPPORT THE
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUNDS FOR PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING EDUCATIONAL DEBT
RELIEF ABOUT MARKET CLINICAL
TRAINING AND GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FOUND ON PAGE FOUR.
THE PROPOSAL SUPPORT PROGRAMS IN
LEADERSHIP AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACT THE COMMISSION-
COSTING TWENTY NINE POINT THREE
MILLION FOR LOAN REPAYMENT AND
COLLEGE PROGRAMS AND SIXTY
MILLIONPREVENT PARKING
CLINICIAN TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND
EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN AND
DIVERSIFY THE PRIMARY CARE
ALLIED HEALTH. HEALTH WORKFORCE
THANK YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLOR
PLEASE. THANK CAR IS ONE FIFTY
THREE OR ONE OF THOSE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON IT'S THIRD SHORE TERM
SPEAKING ON A OF ITEMS THAT
AFTERNOON. FROM BEGINNING WITH
PAGE NOT THE PROPOSAL FROM HOW
MINERS FOR HEALTHEQUITY. THE
LEAD. SPOKEN ON AND COMMITMENT
TO HEALTH EQUITY I BELIEVE A
CRITICAL STEP TO SUPPORT OR
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE. I THINK
THE FUNDING MECHANISM FOR
COMMUNITY SAFETY NET PROVIDERS
TO ADDRESS THEIR SOCIAL
COMPLEXITIES- AND- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF PEACH THE PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL ACTIVE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL ADVENTIST HEALTH THE
ALLIANCE THE CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE
BEVERLY HOSPITAL IN LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY HEALTH. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF ONE MELINDA UNIVERSITY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WE ARE HERE
TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ONE PAGE
TWELVE TO DEVELOP A PEDIATRIC
TRAUMA INFORMED MULTI
DISCIPLINARY MEDICAL HOME MODEL
OF CARE FOR CHILDREN. WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF ABUSE NEGLECT AND
MALTREATMENT- AND WE SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION PROPOSED ONE PAGE
THAT. DIFFICULT THE WORKFORCE
FUNDING FOR CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU EYELINER BE NINE THREE LINE
IS OPEN. ANYONE THAN BEING
CALIFORNIA- THINKING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT RELATED
TO COGNITIVE ABILITIES WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR SPONSOR
COUPLE BECAUSE THAT WAS JUST
GONNA QUALITY STANDARDS BOARD.
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE END OF THE
FACILITIES THAT I WORK WITH A
VOICE IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS RELATED TO AGE EFFECT
BECAUSE WE REQUEST THE COURT R.
COOK BUCKET ITEMS THAT YOU W. TO
PROVIDE NATURAL NATURAL DISASTER
THAT THE PROVIDERS OF ALL OF OUR
SPONSORS- PROPOSAL TO REPROGRAM
SEEM UPSET ABOUT HELPING THOSE.
RETIREMENT PRODUCTION RELATED TO
COPE WITH EVERYTHING ACROSS THE
GLOBE ON THE PORCH FIFTY MILLION
FOR CALFRESH A HUNDRED MILLION
FOR COUNTY ARE GETTING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION VALLEY- WELFARE
SERVICES AUGMENTATION. RELATED
TO CHILD SUPPORT WITH THE
QUESTION BEFORE OR CALL BACK TO
THE BORDER WITH THE FDA TO FIND
L. B. AS THEY BOTH EXISTING AND
UPCOMING WORKLOAD. RELATED TO
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SUPPORT
THE LEARNING COALITION PROPOSAL
TO UPDATE THE LATE MODEL AS WELL
AS ACCELERATE IMPLEMENTATION
COSPONSORED WITH ARC TO SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE MUCH
NEEDED UPDATED TO THE COURT THAT
THE FORMULA. THE PORTABLE WBRC
RELATED TO SB SIX THIRTY NINE
THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED THE
PROPOSAL TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIRTY SIX THIRTY NINE. AND
THEN FINALLY RELATED DEBATE THE
HERE WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
COUNTY BE ABLE DIRECTOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL.
TODAY ANOTHER CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'LL COME FROM.
AWAY OH THREE. WE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TRIPLE JUMP
THE CALLING ON BEHALF OF STATE
THAT PATIENTS LIKE HATRED AND
HEALTH ME CATCH ME TOWN
ADOLESCENTS THAT HIDE. AND WE
SUPPORT NINETY EIGHT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH LINE TRAINING TO UNDER IT
AGE AT WHICH I SUPPORT THE DISH
ON THE- FOR COLEMAN IN THE- I
THINK IT LIKE PLANNING PROCESS
AHEAD OF THE NINE EIGHT. NUMBER
GOING BY IN JULY THANK SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE
. THANK YOU ONE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. PETER TELL US
ON BEHALF OF- TO CLIENT ON TWO
ISSUES WITH COURSES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME ON PAGE
SEVEN MEDI CAL RATE INCREASE FOR
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING WHICH IS
CONTINUOUS SKILLED NURSING CARE
PROVIDED HOME KERR MEDICALLY
COMPLEX MULTIPLE PEDIATRIC AND
ADULT POPULATIONS AND LESS
COSTLY THAN FACILITIES OR-
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS. WEST A
LONG TIME APPROPRIATE OF GENERAL
FUND FIFTY FOUR MILLION PLUS
AUTOMATIC HELLO A PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING SKILLED CARE. DESPITE
PAST EFFORTS TO SUPPORT THIS
NURSING REMAKING THE RATE
REMAINS NON COMPETITIVE IN PT
ANDERSON'S CONTINUE TO SEEK
EMPLOYMENT ELSEWHERE. I THINK
THE ISSUE IS ON PAGE TWELVE OF
ITS FOR THE PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH
CARE COLLECTION. UNDER EACH PSD
TEACH CHILDREN WHO ARE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE MAY RECEIVE- PRIVATE
DUTY NURSING CARE AT HOME OR AT
A PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CENTER.
AT CREEK TWENTY ONE THINK IT
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE CARE AT HOME
BUT PDN SERVICES AT THAT
FACILITY THERE IS NO RATE AND
THIS WOULD STRUCTURE HER RATE.
FOR THOSE SERVICES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GENERAL YOUR CALL.
CENTER AS ITS COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU A COME FROM LINE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINER OPEN. THANK
YOU CLIFFORD MADAM CHAIR OF A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY HE WANTED A
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU. THE VIDEO ON
HEALTHY AGING CAMPUS REQUEST IN
SAN RAFAEL THAT BUDGET REQUEST
FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR
ONE TIME ONLY CAPITAL OUTLAY-
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD A
HEALTHY AGING CAMPUS. WHICH WILL
HOUSE SIXTY SIX UNITS A SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER HOUSING FOR OLDER
ADULTS ADULTS IN MARIN COUNTY
SAN RAFAEL AND THE ONE TIME ONLY
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUESTS FOR
DATA. FOR BUILDING HOUSING
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES FOR
FAMILIES WITH DISABILITY SPECIAL
SERVING ADULTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
LASTLY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WENT
TO A REQUEST. FOR BACK FIELD FOR
FUNDING THREE FORTY B. LAW UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S OUR ACCENT AMER
COUNTY LOSE OVER FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS SO FOR
OTHER FORMULAS WE SEEM TO NOT
EVEN CLOSE TO HOLDING US. UP
HARMLESS LITTLE- MATCHING DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR THE REQUEST IS FOR
TWO MILLION DOLLARS- AW. WITH A
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
LOSS UNDER THE PROGRAM THAT
FUNDS REPORTS CLINICS. IS
CREDITED SEASON THANKS VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THEY GET A
COME FROM NINETY YEAR LINE IS
THAT. MADAM THANK YOU I AM YET
TO HEAR SENIOR DIRECTOR PABLO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS
HEALTH NETWORK. IN ELGIN
SPEAKING IN FRONT THE PORT OF
THE FIFTEEN MILLION PROPOSAL
WITHIN H. HIGH TO SUPPORT
RECRUITMENT TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP PLACEMENTS ARE
DIRECTING REPRESENTATIVE HEALTH
IT WORKFORCE AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINIC. AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES ON OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. EVEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC COMMUNITY
CLINIC EXPERIENCE PERSISTENT
SHORTAGES OF TRAINED ON
OPERATIONAL. SUPPORT STAFF. KNOW
HOW TO USE DATA AND DATA
SYSTEMS. MS OUR FOUNDATION PHD.
DATA AND OWNER OP CALLED CARL
ANY MENTION THE HELP FOR ME
EXCHANGE AFTER. THE CLAIM IN THE
PROGRAMS WITH A CLEAR LADDER
INDIVIDUAL THAT HE I THOUGHT THE
COMMENTS WELL PAID CAREERS WITH
BENEFITS THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK WERE
GOING ON EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE MY NAME IS LANA HARD
UNION I'M A PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
A NEW SEMI DEVELOPING HEALTHCARE
CENTER IN NORTHRIDGE IN LA
COUNTY. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BRIDGE TO RECOVERY FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES CALL THE
NINETEEN MITIGATION AND
RESILIENCE GRANTS TO COMBAT IN
YOUR ISOLATION SPONSORED BY CAT.
OUR CENTER CURRENTLY SERVES TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO OLDER ADULTS
WITH CHRONIC ILLNESSES DURING
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
INEXPERIENCED IS THE GOAL AND
MENTAL DECLINE WITH THE
POPULATION AT THE SHELTER AT
HOME. WITH GRANT PROGRAM WILL
HELP US BRING BACK TO THE CENTER
AND WITH REGARD TO PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH IN A STATEMENT BY
MEANT THE SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR ACT WILL HELP CENTERS
LIKE MINE TO UNDERGO. UP TO
UNDERGO. A GREAT THANK GOD BUT
NOT. LIMITED TO. EQUIPMENT
REPLENISH ARE OUT THERE EIGHT
FIFTY GATHERING AND HIRE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF AT A
COMPETITIVE. RATE OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND THE ENTIRE STAFF IS READY TO
GET BACK IN THE CENTER TOGETHER
AND BASICALLY AS POSSIBLE. AND
IT'S SIXTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
ASK WILL HELP WITH YOU ALL OF
THAT. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL
COME FROM LINE ONE THIRTY LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS THE NEED A STRONG BRAND
AND I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR A. R. P.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AT THAT HEARING ON BEHALF
OF THE A RP. THREE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIA MEMBERS AND
ALL OLDER CALIFORNIANS I'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT TWO ISSUES TODAY
FIRST THE MEDIC HAL SHERIFF COST
ON PAGE FOURTEEN OF THE
COMMITTEE AGENDA. AARP SUPPORTS
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ALLOW LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE JUST OVER THE INCOME LIMIT
FOR MEDICARE NOW TO ACCESS THE
MEDICAL CARE THEY NEED WHEN THEY
NEED IT. THE BUDGET REQUESTS
RESOLVE THE ISSUE OF AN
IMPOSSIBLY HIGH MEDIC COW SHARE
OF COSTS BY INCREASING THE
MAINTENANCE THAT NEED LEVEL TWO
HUNDRED AND 38% OF POVERTY. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST A SECOND ISSUE IS
THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER D.
E. I. PROPOSAL ON PAGE FIFTEEN
OF THE COMMITTEE AGENDA. H. A.
R. P. SUPPORTS THE REQUEST FOR
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION OVER
FOUR YEARS TO DEVELOP TEST AND
EVALUATE PROGRAMS AND PROTOCOLS
TO INCREASE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION OF FAMILY CARE GIVERS
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTER OR THE C. R. C.
SERVING THEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THESE ARE. THE ONLY STATE
PROGRAM THANK YOU. OPPERMAN CARS
WE HAVE LEFT IN THE QUEUE- MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE SIXTY TWO LAST.
OKAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU NEXTEL COME FROM MY NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DONNA YOKOHAMA ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND OUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CALLED
SPONSOR OF THE PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY TO
MAINTAIN CHILD WELFARE SERVICES.
MULTIPLE FACTORS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS BUDGET
DEFICIT INCLUDING THE LOSS OF
THE TITLE FORTY WAIVER AND
INCREASED EXTENDED BOXSTER CARE
COSTS WITHOUT THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATION WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT REDUCED CRITICAL SERVICES
TO OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND KEEPING
THEM AT HOME. SAFELY ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND YOUR PARTNERSHIP TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THE
DEPARTMENT STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
AND ITS POTENTIAL HARMFUL IMPACT
OF VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OVER ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
THE BILL ARE QUITE ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
IN FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH EQUITY
IN RACIAL JUSTICE FUND ONE
EIGHT. EIGHT INITIATIVES
OUTLINED IN THE HEALTH EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE AND- REDUCE
HEALTH AND SOCIAL INEQUITIES
THAT IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND OTHER HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
TRANSFORM COMMUNITY CONDITIONS.
INSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT AND-
ABOUT RACIAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'LL COME FROM MINE
A ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAURA
RICHARDSON AND I WORK FOR A
STATEWIDE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
AND AT THE P. R. T. P. PROVIDER
WE SERVE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN EACH YEAR
INCLUDING PROVIDING INTENSIVE
SERVICES FOSTER CARE. AND
SERVING COMPLEX CARE NEEDS
HUGHES I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE SPONSORED
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT
RELATING TO THE CRUCIAL CARE
COMPONENT. IN CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. STABILIZER TEAM AT
THAT STAGE WITH THE COLAC
ADDRESSING THE DISCREPANCIES IN
THE S. P. R. T. P. AND C.
PROVISION RATE. I. N. D.
TRANSITION FUNDING FOR S. P. R.
T. P. AND COVERED NINETEEN
RELIEF FUNDING FOR S. P. R. T.
P. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AT THESE CRITICAL BUDGET
REQUESTS. THANK YOU MEXICO
PLEASE. THANK YOU ORDERLY ONE
SIXTY- A LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ADMIN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARY SHERIDAN FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER AND
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION INITIATIVES HAVE THE
C. R. C.'S SERVE A DIVERSE
POPULATION OF CAREGIVERS OF
ADULTS WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS LIKE L. SIMONS
DISEASE. AND OTHER DISORDERS
THAT AFFECT BRAIN FUNCTION 48%
IDENTIFY AS NON WHITE MOST
PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE MEDICAL OR
NURSING TASKS IN THE HOME AND
RECEIVE NO PAID HELP. BUILDING
ON THE C. R. C.'S FORTY YEARS OF
OPERATIONS EXPERIENCE IN
PROVIDING EFFECTIVE SUPPORT TO
UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS THE
FOUNDATION IS IN PLACE. TO
EXPAND STATEWIDE PARTNERSHIPS
INTO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
INCREASE TARGETED OUT REACH THAT
WILL MEET THE CULTURAL AND
LANGUAGE NEEDS OF DIVERSE
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM MINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE MAN
AND I LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NERAL
PROJECT CALIFORNIA IN A NUMBER
OF ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
THE FIRST- WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF FUNDING THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM PROPOSAL
REFLECTED IN THE B. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR- THE CARE ACT FOR
WHICH YOU WERE OUT OF THE CROWD
AND COUPONS- ALTHOUGH WE'RE
QUESTIONING FOR THE DATA
COLLECTION AND THAT B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN- BYSTANDER DIED
WHICH- BECAUSE- COLLECTING THE
DATA- IT IS VITAL- JUNE CREATING
PARITY IN CONSISTENCY WITH THE
DATA HOSPITAL COLLECT FOR OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. AND YOUR
OUT OF STATE ALTHOUGH I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF FUNDING THAT
CALIFORNIA UNDER THIS ACT AND
MUST BE FIFTY FIVE FROM LAST
YEAR BASED ON YOUR SCANNER TO
DRASTICALLY GET RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
BLACK AND INDIGENOUS BERGEN
PEOPLE INSIDE. AND I THINK IF I
CREATE A DISPATCHED RESTRUCTURE
BORN INTERVENTION MEETING NEEDED
TO MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THE
MATERNAL INFANT MORTALITY AND
MORBIDITY CRISIS IN OUR STATE.
AND LASTLY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF-
THE CALIFORNIA PORTION SUPPORT
FINDING RALLIED THE CROWDS
DURING COMMITTEE MEMBER. IF
YOU'RE A PORTION DOWN. THERE
PLEASE THINK YEAH. THANK YOUR
NEXT CAR COME FROM MINE SO. YEAR
LINE AS A- THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR
I'M DOCTOR IN BEYOND YOUR BOOK
AMERICA. UNBEATEN COUNTY AND
WORK WITH THE PARENTS PROVIDER
ACROSS THE- EUROPEAN AMERICA.
COURT THE TWO POINTS OR MILLION
DOLLARS PHOTO SHOULD INCREASE
ACCESS TO PRODUCT- ARE KEY
PROGRAM. IN FAMILY COURT THIRTY
NINE POUND. ITEM APPEARED YEAH
YET THAT SECTION OF THE AGENDA
BUT THAT THAT THAT. CENTRAL BOTH
CHILD. HEALTH AND CHILD WILL BE.
I NEED TO LOOK OP PPO STRESSED
BY. MARKERS YEAH- BAND HAND
PROGRAMMING THE MODERN THAT WE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY MOM DAD DO THE
WORK WE YOU- PERSON THAT HOME OR
ON MY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS COLOR. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO LINE OF- NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY NINETY
SEVEN YOU HAVE A SON YOU. LOTUS
WILL BOND THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
RACHEL BLEACHER FROM NELSON MARC
MARON BEHALF OF THREE CLIENTS
FIRST ON BEHALF OF TENET
HEALTHCARE IN SUPPORT OF CJ'S
MEDICAL GRADUATE MAGIC MEDICAL
EDUCATION AND- MEDICAL AND
EQUITABLE PAYMENT MODERNIZATION
PROPOSAL. SECOND ON BEHALF OF
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
ADDICTION MEDICINE PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER TRAINING IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS. AND THE SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
HEALTH AND WELLNESS COACH
TRAINING FOR UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AND FINALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IS THE PART OF THE
FORGIVE PHARMACY RECRUITMENT
PROPOSAL. COMMUNITY PHARMACIES
CONTINUE TO BE ONE. OF THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
THEY'RE LOCATED IN MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE AS WELL NOW THAT WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
IN THE STATE. WE HAVE A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO NOT LOSE AN ACCESS POINT OF
CARE. AT COMMUNITY PHARMACY IS
NOT REALLY TO BE THEIR
COMMITMENT THE FINANCIAL IMPACT
WILL FORCE MANY TO THIS CAN YOU
JUST CONTINUE PROVIDING CARE TO
THEIR MEDICATION OTHERS WILL
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OF THE LAW ONE
FIFTY NINE. WE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
KAREN TO CARRY ON BEHALF OF
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA- WERE CO SPONSORS OF
THE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT CRISIS
LINE- COMPANY PROPOSE ON PAGE
TWO. MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT CRAIG WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH WITH A PREVENTION
PLAN FUNDING PROPOSAL UNDER HHS
. AARON JOHNSON OF THESE. OF THE
STATEWIDE PLANNING CLASSES IN
ADVANCE OF THE NATIONAL JULY
FIRST NINETEEN EIGHT LINES START
DATE. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT FOR CALL
CENTERS AND THE TELEPHONE
SURCHARGE TO FUND THE NINE EIGHT
SYSTEM. BUT I NEED GRACE LINE
WILL SAVE LIVES AND INCREASE
ACCESS TO NEEDED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOUR LINE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KAREN MILLER AND I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE REQUEST
FOR THE SIXTY FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
STATE FUNDING TO CREATE THE
BRIDGE TO RECOVERY FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES CODE NINETEEN
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM. ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PAINT TAYLOR
CENTER FOR ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
IN CHICO AND SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC SEA BASS PROGRAMS
HAVE ABOUT VALIANTLY ASSISTED
PARTICIPANTS OUTSIDE OF OUR
FACILITIES. NOW WE'RE BRINGING
THEM BACK TO OUR CENTERS AND
MUST BE ABLE TO KEEP THEM SAFE
AS WE PROVIDE THE IN PERSON
SERVICES THEY SO URGENTLY NEED.
THAT TO DO THIS WE MUST HAVE A
GOOD BUILDING VENTILATION BASED
ON TODAY'S STANDARDS FOR THE PEG
TAYLOR CENTER HERE IN BUTTE
COUNTY THIS MEANS REPLACING OUR
THIRTY YEAR OLD H. FAQ UNITS
THAT WENT THROUGH THE CAMPFIRE.
AFTER SEARCHING EXTENSIVELY WE
CAN'T FIND FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THIS AND OTHER URGENT UPGRADES
AND WE HAVE A WAITING LIST OF
OVER ONE HUNDRED COMPARABLE
PEOPLE ASKING TO JOIN OUR
NONPROFIT PROGRAM. THE
MITIGATION FUNDING BEING
REQUESTED IS THEREFORE CRITICAL
TO CENTER AND FAR AS WE GO IT
WILL ENABLE US TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OLDER ADULTS AND
FUTURE FIRE DISASTERS AS WE DID
DURING THE CAMPFIRE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOUR CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL A
LINE OF. FOUR ONE OPEN.
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AND
GIVING MY NAME'S JOHN MCCORMICK
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE A LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
AND PLASTER COUNTY A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF HIM ARE AT RISK OF
OR HAVE EXPERIENCED COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. WE ARE
PROBABLY COSPONSORED BUILDING
ACCORDING TO FAMILY HOMES FOR
CHILDREN IMPACTED BY COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. YOU CAN BUY
ON PAGE THIRTY TWO BUT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
THIS REQUEST IS FOR A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION OF SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE INNOVATIVE
POWER THROUGHOUT THE STATE OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD. AND ITS
COURT REBUT. ROBOTS EVALUATION
OF THESE PROGRAMS. DESPITE THE
EFFORTS THE KING OF CARE FORM.
THE CHALLENGES AGREE KEEPING
ABOUT OF COMMERCIAL EXPLOITATION
WITH THEIR FAMILIES OR FIGHTING
FAMILY HOMES. WHEN THEY BECOME
INVOLVED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT REQUEST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OVER LINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AUBREY
SWEENEY AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF RANCHO SAN ANTONIO
BOY FROM ONE OF THE LARGER
EXTERIOR TEEPEES AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THAT HAD BEEN FORCED TO
REDUCE POPULATION TO DEVELOP
KOBE AND I INDEED A TERMINATION.
I AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCES
SPONSORED PROPOSALS AIMED AT
MAINTAINING STABILITY FOR YOU
CARED FOR N. F. T. R. T. P. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SHARE MY SINCERE APPRECIATION
FOR THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT
WAS AWARDED IN THE LAST FISCAL
SEASON IS SUPPORT AT P. R. T.
PEAS. THAT PROVIDE CARE AND
TREATMENT TO OUR. STATE
MONTHLONG HERBAL USE. FIRST
ROUND THE FINANCE WITH. WITH
HIGHLY YOU. AND EVEN CUT SOME
PROGRAMS OPEN BUT DID NOT
PROVIDE LONG TERM RESULTS SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WE ARE EIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
PICTURE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS MONIQUE
BACON AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
COALITION OF ONE HUNDRED BLACK
WHEN THE LOS ANGELES CHAPTER AND
I'M CALLING BECAUSE WE'RE AT THE
PORT OF FULLY FUNDING THE
PROVISIONS OF SB SIXTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA MONEY BUT ACT. BILL
MEANING THREE ADDRESSES MATERNAL
AND INFANT MORTALITY MARKET
PRICES IN OUR STATE AMONG BLACK
AND INDIGENOUS WOMEN WHO
CONTINUE TO DIE OR HAVE SEVERE
ISSUES HIGHER THAN THE STATE
AVERAGE OF OTHER RACES BUT WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO RESPOND TO
MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE ACT EXPANDS
THAT NEEDED WORK FOR ATHLETES ON
THE COUNTY DO AND INFANT
MORTALITY REVIEW COMMITTEE.
RECLUSIVE DATE ALL DATA
COLLECTION AS MUCH NEEDED AND
PLEASE INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
DELIGHT MEDICAL- KNEW A MEDICAL
BENEFITS SO THAT THEY TOO CAN
RECEIVE EQUITABLE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT ARE FAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME HAVE A GOOD.
DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT HEADLINE
NUMBER ONCE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AFTERNOON HAPPY BIRTHDAY
MADAME CHAIR THIS IS VERY DIRTY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES-
PRIMARILY CALLING IN SUPPORT THE
LAMBING COALITION PROPOSALS
FIRST TO ACCELERATE THE TIMELINE
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RIGHT MODEL GREATLY APPRECIATE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT IN GETTING
OUT THROUGH THE LAST BUDGET
SESSION. BUT WE STILL FACE A
SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE CRISIS
WHICH IS LEADING TO A SERVICE
ACCESS CRISIS I'M NOT GETTING
PEOPLE THE SERVICES THEY NEED-
THIS INVESTMENT WOULD ALLOW US
TO RAISE OUR WAGES TO TRY TO BE
MORE COMPETITIVE. THE OTHER LANA
COALITION PROPOSAL IS WE OFFER
SUPPORT TO UPDATE THE RATE THE
RATE STUDY TO PERFORM THE DENIM
TO- ADDRESS LESSONS LEARNED AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE COVERING
ALL THE SERVICES INCLUDING SOME
THAT WERE OMITTED DURING THE
ORIGINAL- RATE STUDY AND
ADDITIONALLY TO PUT IN AN
AUTOMATIC ADJUSTMENT- PROCESS
EVERY THREE YEARS TO AT A FAST
RATE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FUNDED AT AN ADEQUATE LEVEL SO
WE DON'T FALL INTO A HOLE.
FINALLY JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE ARK OF PROPOSALS
TO BOTH ELIMINATE THE FAMILY
FEES AND ALSO TO UPDATE FROM
CORE STAFFING FORMULA TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I KNOW
CAR FROM MY NEW ONCE. SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND-
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TOURNAMENT MY
NAME IS OSCAR SENSIBLE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS SENIOR
MANAGER WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA OR L. C. H. C. GOING
TO VOICE OUR ORGANIZED
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT FOR THE
ALLOCATION OF ONE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
STARTS THE IF THAT WAS MEANT TO
BE HELPED EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND- THE CALIFORNIA
COULD ASSISTANT PROGRAMS
EXPANSION TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ALSO KNOWN AS FOOD FOR ALL AND
THE DEDICATION OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MEDICARE OUT MENTAL
HEALTH OUTREACH AND EDUCATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
THAT'S SORT OF WHY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE WHO FATHER OF TWO BOYS
AFFECTED BY A RAGING AT NBC I
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. BY THE COUNCIL ALL
OUR BACKS COALITION TO SUPPORT
THE BUDGET REQUEST THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BACK. THANK YOU
BATTLING WITH THE RED WITH THE I
HAVE EXPERIENCE MANY CHALLENGES
THAT REDDIT COMMUNITY FACES
EVERY DAY. OUR GOAL IS TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT RARE DISEASES
ARE ABOUT KNOWLEDGE AND
INFORMATION TO POLICYMAKERS. AND
TO BE A RESOURCE TO INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES LIVING WAS ALREADY
AT THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS WILL
SUPPORT THEIR PATIENTS. WE HOPE
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN THE TWENTY
ONE OTHER STATES. THAT HAVE
ENACTED ON BACK TO HELP GIVE A
VOICE TO THE RENTED THIS
COMMUNITY. IN OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MANAGER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. X. LINE ONE. EIGHT
PLEASE CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR
DISABILITIES AND CHARLES ON
BEHALF OF HOW TO MANAGE THE
LARGEST FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER IN CALIFORNIA
COMING FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND LATINO MULTI ETHNIC AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY.
WELL WE SUBMITTED MORE
SUBSTANTIVE WRITTEN COMMENTS I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
ITEMS FIRST OFF STRONG SUPPORT
FOR INCREASING MENTAL PAYMENT
FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ENSURE EXTENDED HOURS OF
OPERATION FOR BOTH PRIMARY CARE
SITES. AND PHARMACIES REMAIN IN
PLACE AND SECONDLY WE STRONGLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO COMMIT
TO FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FUNDING FOR EDUCATIONAL DEBT
RELIEF ADVANCED PRACTICE
CLINICIAN TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS WITH
RECOMMEND THE FUNDS TO BE
DISBURSED THROUGH THE TARGETED
PROGRAMS UNDER THE NEW
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. BY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND
ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON AN OPERATOR HELLO
INTENT PLEASE PERCENTAGE. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHIANG SAID COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS LINDSEY GRAHAM BOBBY ON
BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD CALIFORNIA
I'M REGISTERING BLUESHIELD
SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS HEARD
TODAY FIRST BLUE SHIELD SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSED BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR MEDI CAL
PROVIDER DATA SHARING AND
CONTENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
SOLUTIONS CURRENTLY SUPPORT THE
STAFF RUSHING ESTATE WHITE
INFORMATION EXCHANGE TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM PROVIDES
ACCURATE AND RELIABLE
INFORMATION TO IMPROVE THE
CORONATION FIFTY EXTRA INTO
PATIENT CARE MEDICARE PROVIDERS
ARE A KEY PART OF THIS CORE
NEEDED SYSTEM AND THIS PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT TOOLS TO
ESTABLISH A STRONGPROVIDER
NETWORK PARTICIPATING IN THE
SYSTEM. SECOND BLUESHIELD
SUPPORT FULLY FUNDING SENATE
BILL SIXTY FIVE ALSO KNOWN AS
THE CALIFORNIA MOM THE BEST ACT
ACT PROMOTES POSITIVE MATERNAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES THAT ADVANCE
YOUR MATERNAL HEALTH EQUITY ALL
OF WHICH ALIGNS WITH BLUE SHIELD
MISSION TO CREATE AN EQUITABLE
AND SUSTAINABLE AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
EXCLUDING NUMBER SIX NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS SHOWING UP BY A
POLICY DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF OUR
SPONSORS MEDIC HOW MENTAL HEALTH
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION PROPOSAL
ON PAGE SEVEN. ARTICLE WHERE
NOTHING CONFUSION OVER THE CUP
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
PERSPECTIVE MY MEDIC HOW MEMBERS
IMPLICATIONS AND BRING THE
CAPABILITY TO IMPROVE
UTILIZATION RATE HAD BEEN EQUITY
THAT THAT YOUR REQUEST WILL
INVEST IN CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT
EDUCATIONAL MATERIAL FOR
MEDICARE MEMBERS AND EDUCATE
PATIENTS ON THE RIGHT TO TIMELY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. UNDER
THEIR RESPECTIVE MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
SIX WHAT ONE NUMBER ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- MY NAME
IS FELIX- WITH MATHEMATICS IN A
NONPROFIT HEALTH PROMOTION
NETWORK I'M HERE O SPEAK ABOUT
THIS WONDERFUL LITTLE ON THE TOP
OF PAGE THIRTEEN MEDICAL
PROVIDER DATA SHARING INCENTIVES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. WE ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE MANY OTHER
HEALTHCARE STAKEHOLDERS TO
STRONG SUPPORT DOCUMENTS
STARTING WITH NINETY FIVE
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR. IT
WILL ENABLE AND MOTIVATE GET
SHARING AND IT IS CRUCIAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE KALYAN EMISSIONS
AND IT WILL DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR AN ENHANCED MATCHING
RATE CAN HAVE A POWERFUL
MULTIPLIER EFFECT. EACH WORK
THANK YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY I'M
SURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ACCIDENTAL NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS DR NICK AND WHAT MAKE
THEM A MEDICAL GENETICIST
INTERNET COLLEGES LICENSED TO
PRACTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THIRTY YEARS I AM
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
H. THE- ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWO. I AM TWENTY ONE
IS TO PROVIDE FUNDING NECESSARY
FOR MEDICAL COVERAGE A GENETIC
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING FOR PEDIATRIC
PATIENTS INCLUDING NEWBORNS
THERE REMAIN HUGE INEQUITIES
ACTIVE SUBJECT THAT INFORMATION
DEPENDING ON THEIR INSURANCE
TYPE OF YOUR ECONOMIC STATUS IS
DIFFICULT. ARE CURRENTLY A
NEWBORN SCREENING PROGRAM
ALTHOUGH EXCELLENT DID NOT
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS FOR
CONFIRMATION OF TESTING MANY
MANY PEDIATRIC PATIENTS ARE
BEING. TREATED FOR CONDITIONS
THAT CANNOT BE. WE BELIEVE THAT.
COUNTRY TEST. FOLLOWING A
POSITIVE GREW YOU'LL WELL YOU
THE MINIMUM. OF MILIEU DOLLARS A
YEAR. AND A HALF MINIMAL THANK
HEAVEN FOR PEDIATRIC TESTING FOR
RARE DISEASE ABOUT TWO FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. I DID SEE A SIDE OF
NUMBER TWENTY TWO WILL IMPLEMENT
TO PUT THREE PILOT PROGRAM.
AIMED TO EXPLORE IMPLEMENTATION
GENETIC SERVICES FOR MEDICAL AND
ALL THESE. INCLUDE YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COLOR YOUR HAIR THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MY NAME IS
BAILEY AGAIN I'M A CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASE OF THE
MAINTENANCE NEED INCOME LEVEL
FROM SIX HUNDRED TO THE 110038%
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. NO ONE
CAN LIVE ON SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
ALONE TO INCREASING THE
MAINTENANCE NEEDS LEVEL WOULD
ALLOW OLDER ADULTS AND DISABLED
CALIFORNIANS TO KEEP MORE MONEY
TO PAY FOR EACH OF THESE LIKE
FOOD CLOTHES AND SHELTER LOOKS
FINE QUALIFYING FOR THAT
ACCOUNT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
EXTRA LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HI EVERYONE- ON JAN NUMBERS ON A
CANAL AREA HERE ON TWO ITEMS
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAME CHAIR SO THE
FIRST ONE IS ON PAGE TWENTY ON
Q. AND HAD. GIVEN ALL TEN
O'CLOCK ANGELA. TONY AND I. GOT
THE TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR CARE GIVER RESOURCES. WE
THINK THIS IS A CRITICAL PROGRAM
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
CAREGIVERS PARTICULARLY DURING
COLD BAD. HE'S BEEN THE BACKBONE
OF ENSURING. THAT THOSE WET ON
WHETHER IT'S ON THE CARD LOOKS
AT THE CONDITION THAT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE DOING WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DEAL WITH A FAMILY. THE
SECOND ONE OF ON PAGE TWENTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE ALLEGHENY
COUNTY. HOWEVER THE LIKE OF
THOSE ALL AT THIRTY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION OVER THREE YEARS.
FOR CASE MANAGEMENT AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THE PROGRAM
WITH FUNDING. AND PRIOR.
220-008-0009 HOWEVER MADE FLAT
DUE TO HAD GREAT RESPECT. THAT
WE THINK YOUR CONSIDERING.YOUR
YOUR STAFF AT A GROUND THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO FOLLOW UP WITH
LIKE. THE CORPS AS WELL
DISLOCATION THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GOOD CALL. THANK YOU VERY THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT T A LINE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS TASIA WATSON
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND I'M MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTED
THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR SIXTY
MILLION AND GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE TO BE ALLOCATED OVER
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT PRIMARY
CARE AND FAMILY MEDICINE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. THE SONG ABOUT THE-
GRAHAM ACCORDING TO THE FINAL
REPORT OF THE CALABRIAN FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA IS PROJECTED TO HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF FOUR THOUSAND A
HUNDRED AND THREE PRIMARY CARE
CLINICIAN BY TWENTY THIRTY THE
STATE POPULATION OR GROW BY SIX
MILLION BUT WITHOUT AN INCREASE
IN PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. ALL
THE SHORTAGES WILL IMPACT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO CURRENTLY LIVES
AND HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE
AREAS WELL FOR THE BEST ITS
BIGGEST IMPACT IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES THAT
EQUITY CALIFORNIA'S INVEST. MORE
IN BUILDING IS. IN WE SHALL URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THEM THAT BECAUSE
BY DOING SO WILL HELP EXPAND
THE- CARE IN THE TO HELP. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOU CAN. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE
CALIBRATING THINGS ABOUT THE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN. WILL
HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS
TO A LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING OR A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
WORKING TO STOP HOMELESSNESS. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL FOR TARGETED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES ON PAGES TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY THREE. THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING INCLUDED A GOAL
OF ENDING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
OLDER ADULTS AND OTHER AT RISK
POPULATIONS. HOLDER DOES ARE ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATIONS OF HOMELESS
CALIFORNIANS. WHEN HOMELESS AN
OLDER ADULT OR PERSON WITH A
DISABILITY IS LIKELY TO DIE
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS
YOUNGER. AND THEY'RE BOTH AT FAR
GREATER RISK OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THAN HOUSE
COUNTERPART. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES EACH YEAR TO THE
MOST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING SUBSIDIES.
IT WILL HELP PARTICIPANTS
TRANSITION FROM STATE FUNDED
FEDERALLY FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR
THIS ONE TIME ASK IT'S FULLY
SUSTAINABLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE. EXHORT A LINE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
THE MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS SUCH
ABOUT THE FELLOW WITH ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY ABORTION FUND
IN HERE TO SUPPORT THE FOUR
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE FUNDING FOR
ABORTION ACT UP IN CALIFORNIA.
EQUITY IN INFRASTRUCTURE PAYMENT
FOR MEDICAL ABORTION PROVIDERS
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA. WHEN THE
ABORTION SUPPORT AND ELLIE.
PROTECTED HEALTH PILOT PROGRAM A
DIFFICULT PRACTICAL TO OBTAIN AN
ABORTION IMPACT THE MAJORITY OF.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO GET THE
CALLER. WOULD JUST IMPRACTICAL
BERRIES INCLUDE TIME AWAY FROM
WORK WHICH CAN RESULT IN LOST
WAGES TRAVELING. PROVIDERS
COORDINATING CHILD CARE DURING
THAT TRAVEL LODGING.
TRANSPORTATION FOOD AND DO IT.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT BEING FUND IT
WILL THE IMPORT OF BOTH THE
PRODUCTIVE HELPED BECAME A RIGHT
. BUT PRACTICAL LOGISTICAL
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA. HE COULD
BE A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM DATE
THANK YOU WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
EXETER LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SURE MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH COLLECTIONS AD
I'M ALL POVERTY HUNDREDS OF PART
OF- FOOD FOR CARE YOU KNOW FOR
KIDS PROPOSAL- FOOD FOR ALL
PROPOSAL THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE PROPOSAL THANK YOU
AND PRETTY CRITICAL KIND OF
MANAGER. ASSISTS NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JESSICA
BLAKE MORROW AT ALAMEDA COUNTY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AGENCY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE ABOUT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
HOMELESSNESS ENHANCED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM ONE TIME THIRTY
FIVE MILLION BUDGET REQUEST. THE
FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER
LEVERAGE RESOURCES ASSOCIATED
WITH CALAIS M. AND HSA THE H. P.
I. T. TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MOST URGENT AND ONGOING HOUSING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND MEDICAL
NEEDS FOR COUNTY RESIDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. ADULT
ENTERTAINERS TO CREATE
SUSTAINABLE PRGRAMS OF A TERROR
FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE PER YEAR FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS. OKAY THING ON
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. WELL OUR STREET TEAMS
TO INCREASE ENGAGEMENT AMONG
UNSHELTERED CLIENTS PROVIDE
CERTAIN PATHWAYS TO INCLUDE
HOUSING. INCLUDING TOP MEDICAL
THAT'S THAT UNITECH I'LL NEED A
POINT COLLABORATED IN THE CITY
OF ALAMEDA. IN PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR THIRTY
NINE UNITS AT SEVENTH AND
CAMPBELL IN OAKLAND. CAPITAL AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING ALONE ARE
NOT ENOUGH CAN YOU COMPLEX
NEEDS. HELP IN HOUSING NEEDS I
CREATING A LONG TERM OPERATING
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING TO PURCHASE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT FOR YEARS TO
COME THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS LINE OF ONE A
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CAROL FOOL ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION AND ALSO REPRESENTING-
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
GUARDIANS AND CONTRIBUTORS ARE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING- WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THE
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONGOING ALLOCATION FOR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TRAINING. WE URGE YOU TO APPROVE
THIS ONGOING ALLOCATION WITHOUT
THE MONEY THE TRAINING BUDGET
FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY APS
AGENCIES REFERRED TO UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. THIS TRAINING MONEY IS
ESSENTIAL IN PARTICULAR WITH THE
EXPANDED ROLE THAT- WAS ASSIGNED
TO APS AGENCIES THAT WORK WITH
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ALLOCATION. BUT WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO A
LINE FOR ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT'S NOT. EXACTLY
WHILE. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS ON YOUR
MORTGAGE YEAH I WAS TALKING TO
ON THE ACTION PROJECT I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR FULLY FUNDING THE PROVISIONS
OF SB SIXTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
MOM THE BEST ACTOR AND MUSICIAN
AT THREE FIFTY FIVE REIMAGINED
MATERNAL HEALTH FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY REDEFINING
SUCCESS ALTHOUGH THE OVERALL
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE IN OUR
STATE HAVE DECREASED THE FAIRY
TALE PRINCESS. BLACK INDIGENOUS
WORKING PEOPLE CONTINUE TO DIE
YOU'RE STAYING INJURY FROM
PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES THAT
BREAKS FAR ABOVE THE STATE
AVERAGE I THINK THE FIVE CREATED
THE STATUTORY STRUCTURE THE
CRITICAL INTERVENTIONS NEEDED TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THE
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND MORBIDITY
CRISIS IN OUR STATE WE NOW ASK
THAT YOU FULLY FUND THEM FUNDING
THESE PROVISIONS AS AN
INVESTMENT TOWARDS ELIMINATING
CALIFORNIA'S RACIAL AND
SOCIOECONOMIC DISPARITIES IN
BREAKING OUT COME. ADDITIONALLY
I'D LIKE TO REGISTER OR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND HI MICHAEL
REPORT THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
ABORTION. ACCESS IS OUTLINED BY
MOLLY. HEDGE AND THE PROPOSAL
FOR CAR. PROGRAM PREVENTION
FINAL TO A FABULOUS NEW YEAR
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MATT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR. NEXT ONE
NUMBER ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DORIS MEYER
AND I'M CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
SORTS OF CHANGE A PROGRAM OF TO
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE. I'M
CALLING IN THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ON A FUND THAT WOULD
DEDICATE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS. WE NEED BASED
ORGANIZATION NAMED ONGOING
FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO DO THEIR
WORK. THEY KNOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES BEST AND ARE ABLE TO
SERVE UNIQUE LOCAL ME. IN A
CULTURALLY AND LANGUAGE
LINGUISTICALLY TAILORED WAY. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WE MUST
INVEST IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS AND TRIAL
ORGANIZATIONS. TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF THE CENTURY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT ONE OF FOUR
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TO RECOMMEND A DON CAP
KEY WITH MY CUTE CAT CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER.
IN CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION THE CAP CENTER AND
SEE FOR POLICE TO SUPPORT AND CO
SPONSOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SERVICES A FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING REQUEST TO STABILIZE AND
STRENGTHEN FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER. I REQUEST IS LOCATED ON
PAGE TWENTY NINE AND THIRTY TO
CONTINUE AND EXPAND
COMPREHENSIVE COST EFFECTIVE AND
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SUPPORT TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES STATEWIDE
MANY OF WHOM ARE SOME OF THE
MOST MARGINALIZED IN OUR
COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY AMID THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC AND
RESULTING ECONOMIC CRISIS.
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS HAVE
BEEN THE LIFELINES TO FAMILIES
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES
AND IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THEY
RECEIVE ADEQUATE ONGOING FUNDING
THE CONTINUED TO ADDRESS THE
URGENT AND GROWING NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EXCELLENT ONE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TELL
ME HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL MY NAME IS
DOROTHY THANK MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS CONFORM HERE
REQUESTING TO MEDIA IN GENERAL
CAN ANNUALLY I TOOK THE FAMILY
FAMILY COURSE. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UNDER BY THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA MY FAMILY HAS
BENEFITED FROM THIS PROGRAM BY
SUPPORTING MY FAMILY MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN PRODUCTIVE RECOVERY.
WENT OPEN UP MY MIND THE WEIGHT
OF COMMUNICATION BUT APATHY TO
ENABLE ME TO SUPPORT MY FAMILY
MEMBER YOU HAVE A PRODUCTIVE
RECOVERY BY HELPING MY FAMILY
MEMBERS WHAT CONSISTENTLY TAKING
MEDICINE. THAT WERE CORRECT I
DON'T CARE I HIDING THE FINDING. OF GOOD PEOPLE THANK HIGH
INTEREST. PRESCRIPTION ANOTHER
TO A BETTER. I FEEL EXTENDING
THE SCOPE AND I LIKE INTRODUCE
THE SCOPE A LOT OF. HAVE THEIR
LOVED ONES WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
TO HAVE A WAY OUT BY ACCESSING
THE MARKET IS PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY CALLER PLEASE. X. LINE TWO
SIX PLEASE CALL. ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANNETTE EARHART I AM A MEMBER OF
NAMI CALIFORNIA. I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE NATIONAL LINE
COMMENTS ON THE CALIFORNIA. I
PARTICIPATED IN THE FAMILY THE
FAMILY COURT IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN I HAVE BEEN ON
A TWELVE YEAR JOURNEY WITH MY
LOVED ONE. LIVING WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGE THE PROGRAM
BENEFITS. THEN AND CONTINUES TO
BENEFIT ME NOW WITH MY
COMMUNICATION SKILLS. AND ALL
THE EDUCATION TOOLS I NEED IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT A LOVED ONE.
WHO LIVES WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. I ASK THAT YOU CAN
HIGHLY CONSIDER THIS PROGRAM IN
. REALLY AN AMAZING PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET'S
MOVE ON AN OPERATOR. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TIM DAVIS SENIOR PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF NAMI WEBSITE AT LAKE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF NAMI
CALIFORNIA RECEIVING THE TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
FOR THEIR FAMILY PROGRAMS I TOOK
NINETY CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY TO
FAMILY CLASS IN THE SPRING OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. RIGHT
AFTER MY SON WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
BIPOLAR DISORDER THE CLASS MADE
AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON ME AND
ALONG WITH NANI CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILY SUPPORT GROUPS GAVE ME
VALUABLE INSIGHT INTO MY SON'S
CONDITION THE SUPPORT OF AN
INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY. AND HOPE
FOR THE FUTURE AT A TIME WHEN MY
FAMILY AND I DEARLY NEEDED ALL
OF THAT THEY ALSO BROUGHT ME AND
MY EX WIFE CLOSER TOGETHER THAN
WE'VE BEEN IN YEARS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO THAT ALL PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOVED ONES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. CAN ACCESS
THE SAME LIFE CHANGING
COMPASSION SUPPORT AND HOPE MY
FAMILY EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS THANK YOU AND THANKS
MADAM CHAIR FOR SPENDING YOUR
BIRTHDAY WITH US. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS COLOR PLEASE. ACTUAL
WRITTEN ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES OKAY THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI
MY NAME IS DR PHIL DETERMINED
DOCTOR CHIROPRACTIC I'VE BEEN IN
PRACTICE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS IN
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHIROPRACTIC ASSOCIATION
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE
CHIROPRACTIC MEDICAL OPTIONAL
BENEFIT FOR ADULT BENEFICIARIES
AND TO MODIFY THAT YOU LIVE IN A
MONTH CAP- FOR MEDI CAL AND
MODIFY THAT TO A TWENTY FOUR
VISIT ANNUAL LIMIT. I URGE YOU
TO APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL I HAVE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS I HAVE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE CONSEQUENCES
THAT OCCUR WHEN PEOPLE DO NOT
HAVE OPTIONS TO ALTERNATIVE
RESOURCES CONSERVATIVE CARE I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL TAKE A LOOK
AT OUR PROPOSAL AND LOOK AT SOME
OF THE DATA THAT WE PROVIDED
REGARDING THE VA'S USE OF
CHIROPRACTIC CARE. AND SOME OF
THE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED I'M STRONG MEDIC COW
OR A STATE FUNDED PROGRAM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GET PEOPLE ACTIVE.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO
ONE ROOM NINE NINE PLEASE CALL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR TIM
CALLED AROMA WITH THE WHITE MAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT
CAL CAIRO WERE ALSO COMING TO
SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF THE
CHIROPRACTIC OPTIONAL BENEFIT
MATAGAL. RESTORING THIS BENEFIT
TO LOW COST PROPOSAL THAT WILL
RESULT IN FEWER SURGICAL
INTERVENTION THAT WILL PROVIDE-
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES LIVING IN
PAIN A SAFE ALTERNATIVE TO
OPIOIDS. AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS
BENEFITS THE ONLY OPTIONAL
BENEFIT NOT TO BE RESTORED
FOLLOWING THE GREAT RECESSION
AND THE MILLION CALIFORNIANS ON
CAL. DESERVED ACTS THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALIFIED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND HAVE BEEN NOT
BEEN DENIED THAT CHIROPRACTIC.
BENEFITS ARE TOO LONG THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH CALLER PLEASE.
NEXTRADIO LINE NUMBER TWO OR
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS NICOLE
YOUNG AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF FIRST BY SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE ACCESS. THE
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAMS AND
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES IN NINE
COUNTIES INCLUDING MY OWN. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT POSTED WITH SECTION
OF THE AGENDA. OTHER PARENTING
PROGRAM ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIAL
FOR PROMOTING CHILD WELL BEING
AND THEY'RE EVEN MORE CRITICAL
NOW FOR JUST THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC. THE COUNTY HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF PROVIDING EVIDENCE
BASED PARENTING SUPPORT
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATING
POSITIVE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN PARENTS. AND
CONTRIBUTING TO A LOWER RATE OF
CHILD ABUSE NEGLECT IN OUR
COUNTY. THE FUNDING PROVIDED THE
PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW US TO EXPAND
AND ENHANCE OUR PROGRAMMING FOR
THE BENEFIT OF MORE FAMILY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE'S PROBABLY- HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATHY VAN
OSTERN REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU THAT NUMBER OF
ITEMS ALL JUST STICK TO THE
LEFT- THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA ABORTION SUPPORT FUND
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM YOU CAN DO WITH
MEDICAID MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN CLOSE S. CI GROUP
COVERAGE GAP FOR L. G.
POPULATION AND FAMILY PACK. LA
COUNTY REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PILOT
PROGRAM INCREASING ACCESS TO THE
PARENT PROGRAMS AND FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. MY TESTING
CAN'T TWELVE FULL. INCREASE
FUNDS FOR PELL VISITING PROGRAM
COME TO MAX OUT THE FULL. FULLY
FUNDED CALIFORNIA MOM THE BUT
FAST. AND MORE FOR THE CHILD
WELFARE SECTION TO KINSHIP
GUARDIANS JUSTIN PAYMENT PROGRAM
EXPANSION MARGINS YOU CARE CHILD
CARE BRANCH A MERCHANT SERVICES
AND LAUGHTER RESPONSE FUNDING
PER CAP COMING WELFARE
DEPARTMENT. AN INVESTMENT FOR
STATEWIDE BACKER. IN WHITE
DISTRIBUTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR
NEXT LEVEL TWO IS TWO OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LYDIA BOTTLE OF PRESENTING THE
BLOOD CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
WORLD OF NON PROFITS THAT
PROVIDE OVER 90% OF THE BLOOD
AND BLOOD PRODUCTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE WE ARE A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MEDICAL LAB TECHNOLOGY THE QUEST
FOR TWELVE POINT SIX. MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT GRANT FUNDING
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED-
COS IT'S AN MLT. AS THE PROVIDER
OF BLOOD PRODUCTS AND BLOOD IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN
ONLY- HIGHER COS THIS AND THEY
ARE IN. SHORT SUPPLY SECONDLY
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS OB REPRESENTING OVER
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEDIATRICIANS AND PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALTY- WE'RE INTO PORT OF
ONE PAGE NOT IN NUMBER ELEVEN
THE CONTINUOUS MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR YOUNG CHILDREN TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET
AND FORTY. MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING THIS WILL HELP TO ENSURE
NOT ONLY COVERAGE BUT ALSO
ACCESS TO KEY ON A CONTINUOUS
BASIS FOR THESE YOUNG CHILDREN.
NUMBER TWO IS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME YOU HAVE
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND I
CAN YOU TELL ME HOW MANY WIND
HOLES IN THE KEY UP FOR. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE FIFTY SIX PARTIES
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT A NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE DIFFERENT
ONE. BOB LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA SIROTA AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF NANI LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND I WANTED YOU TO
KNOW THAT MY SON WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL TWENTY SEVEN TIMES HE
HAS NOT BEEN IN THE HOSPITAL NOW
FOR OVER SIXTEEN YEARS YOU
SHOULD NOT NEED HELPING I TOOK
THE FAMILY TO FAMILY COURSE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND AGAIN
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU GET FROM NANI
IS. ACCEPTANCE LOVE CARING AND A
WONDERFUL COMMUNITY. PLEASE
PLEASE HELP THESE PEOPLE NOT ME
AND DID THE BEST IT IS
UNBELIEVABLE THEY FIGHT- STIGMA
AND DISCRIMINATION AND THEY
ADVOCATE FOR ALL OUR CHILDREN
AND YOU IN THE CODE THAT WE ARE
NEEDING SO MUCH MORE HELP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
IME TO DO THIS AND SAY THESE
WORDS. AND I HOPE. WITH
EVERYTHING THIS WILL WORK OUT
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR DAY WITH US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS CALLER
PLEASE. EXHORT A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
MACDONALD THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
NAMI CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM TO
HELP FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
AND THE LARGER COMMUNITY. HERE
WITH MY FAMILY WHEN A LOVED ONE
STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO. TOO
MANY OF US LEARN ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST HAND WHEN A LOVED
ONE IS STRUGGLING. OR WHEN THEY
REACH A CRISIS WE CAN ELL
TERRIFIED LONELY CONFUSED AND
HELPLESS. THAT CHANGED FOR ME
WHEN I TOOK MY- FAMILY CLASS IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. THE
TEACHERS. RANTING FROM THE HEART
AND THE CLASS HELP ME BETTER
UNDERSTAND MENTAL ILLNESS AND
HOW I COULD COMMUNICATE WITH. MY
LOVED ONES NOW I WORK WITH NOT
ENOUGH I NOT NOT THE END BUT
THAT THE FAMILY GROUPS- A FAMILY
GROUP SHOULD CONSOLIDATOR. I
WHENEVER WE RECOMMEND A CLASS
FULL OF WANT YOU TO JOIN WHEN
THEY JOIN OUR MEETINGS THERE
WOULD COME BACK GRATEFUL FOR THE
EDUCATION AND MORE HOPEFUL THAN
BEFORE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM SO THAT
WE CAN HELP MORE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR PLEASE. MEXICO NUMBER
TWO- TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JACKIE
GONZALEZ POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES AND
THE SPONSOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF APPEARING
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THIS PROGRAM TWENTY NINETEEN AND
I'M PROUD TO SAY. THAT THE
FUNCTION BEEN PROVEN SUCCESSFUL
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE HEY
MATTHEW PROTECTION DO NOT
DOMINATE HEADLINES BUT THE NEED
FOR QUALITY REMOVAL DEFENSE
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANTS AND THE
STATE HAS NOT ABATED. BASKETBALL
THE NATIONWIDE IMMIGRATION COURT
BACKLOG BUT THE LARGEST SPIKE IN
HISTORY DUE TO ARREST BY ICE AND
THE LARGEST BIKE EIGHTEEN WIDE
WITHIN THE ELLIE COURT MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS OF GROCERIES THAT
ARE STATE INCLUDING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND CENTRAL COAST ARE
AMONG THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO MUST APPEAR THERE WITH NO
LEGAL ATTORNEY BY THEIR SIDE.
SOLUTION TO THIS JUSTICE GAP IS
A COLLABORATIVE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM THAT DEVELOPS A PIPELINE
OF ATTORNEYS THAT THE PORT CAN
LEAD IN REMOTE REGIONS OF OUR
STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL AND YOUR NAME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND. I CALLED THE
POLICE. THANK YOU. MEXICO I
NUMBER TWO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR READING
THE THAT THE DIRECT DEEP IN OUR
AT SHEER GLASS NATURE DOESN'T
START THE PORT OF THREE ITEMS.
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION AT THE
BACK NONCITIZEN IMMIGRANTS OF
ALL AGES WE BELIEVE ACCESS TO
FOOD FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT I CAN'T
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT LEGAL FELLOWSHIP OF
WHICH IS THE PARK AT THE TENT.
THIS PROGRAM WAS BORN OUT OF A
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE REMOVAL
DEFENSE BECAUSE THE POOR IN
RURAL AREAS OF OUR STATE WE
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION AS IT
NEEDED ON THE INCREASE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. FINALLY AT THE
PROPOSAL AND SUPPORT FOR
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT OUTREACH IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR DOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS OR NEWLY ELIGIBLE
FOR THE MEDICARE PROGRAM HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR. I HOPE
SOMEONE MAKES YOU A DELICIOUS
SPREAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS A LOT
NUMBER TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
MY NAME IS RIGHT AT ELEVEN WITH
THE WHITE IMMIGRANTS ON BEHALF
OF OUR CLIENT MANAGEMENT MEDIC.
PLEASE AT THE CORE AND
COSPONSORED THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND
MEDI CAL PROVIDER DATA SHARING
AND GET AN EXTRACTION PROPOSAL
ON THE TOP OF PAGE THIRTEEN. THE
BASKETBALL THE BAMTECH MARGIE
BUT I TRACKED DOWN THE PROVIDERS
TO PARTICIPATE AND NETWORK
SHARING THAT DATA THAT WHOLE
CARE TEAM HAVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO DELIVER QUALITY.
CARE TO ALL PATIENTS THE GAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR FOR.
THAT SORT OF NUMBER TWO OR NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. AFTERNOON W. YOU
HAVE A BEAUTY W. AFTER. NINE
THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING
TODAY AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAM
CHAIR WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
TWO PROPOSALS WITH SEIU. FIRST
WE ARE SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE A WAGE DIFFERENTIAL
FOR ICE BUT PROVIDER DURING
DECLARES STATE OF EMERGENCY
AFTER IT PROVIDERS GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE CALL FOR CARE INSURE
THEIR CLIENT BASE DURING NATURAL
DISASTERS. WE OFFER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE IDEA THAT KATHY WITH
PROPOSAL TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
RETIREMENT PROGRAM. LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS ON THE
THEN CURRENT PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ACTUALLY LINE
NUMBER TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MAKING
THREE BIRDIES ON THE HAVE IT
HELP OR YOUR PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS UNDER HIS PART IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH. I'M SORRY YOUR
REQUEST FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME. TO CANCER
RESEARCH FOR FIREFIGHTERS CANCER
IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG FIREFIGHTERS IN THE UNITED
STATES. OUR RECORDS ARE EXPOSED
TO MANY KNOWN AND SUSPECTED
CARCINOGENS IN MY LINE OF DUTY
I'M OUR MEMBERS ARE WELL AWARE
OF THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEIR JOB AND DESPITE THE
STICKER FORM THEIR DUTY WITHOUT
A MOMENT OF HESITATION. KNOWING
THAT IN MANY CASES ARE MODERATE
BUT WHEN THEY WILL RECEIVE A
CANCER DIAGNOSIS THE BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH COMMUNITY DOES NOT HAVE
A THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EXPOSURE. AND THE BIOLOGICAL
MECHANISMS THAT COSBY ELEVATED
INCIDENCE OF CANCER AMONG
FIREFIGHTERS ABILITY BUILDING
OFF OF RECENT RESEARCH CONDUCTED
ANOTHER STATE. THIS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS WHO HAVE UNIQUE
CORRECT EXPOSURES WHAT WILL BE
HERE TO HELPING DATA DRIVEN
INTERVENTIONS DESIGNED TO REDUCE
EXPOSURE REDUCED RATE THAT
CANCER AND IMPROVE TREATMENT
OUTCOMES FOR THE FIRE SERVICE.
URGES SUPPORT FOR ADOPTION OF
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT I NUMBER ONE SO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES THIS IS
PAUL ANDREWS FROM BGM I A MEMBER
OF THE- ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL
PRODUCTS SUPPLIERS. I AM CALLING
. OR THE ADJUSTED FOR PETER OF
YOUR REIMBURSEMENT FOR DANNY AND
MEDICAL SUPPLIES. FOR ACTUAL
FORMULA ON PAGE FIFTEEN THIS
WILL ALLOW THE THIRD MOST
VALUABLE BOTTLE PATIENT IN OUR
STATE. AND WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN
A REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
SUPPLIERS OVER THE YEARS WHICH
HAD JUST BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. RECENTLY I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME MADAM CHAIR IN THE
ROUGHLY MEMBERS AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS FOR LINE NUMBER
TWO TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR PHIL
BEAUTIFULLY AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK WOMEN PHYSICIANS CAN
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR FULLY
FUNDING THE PROVISIONS OF SB
SIXTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA MOM
THAT WAS THAT. ALTHOUGH THE
OVERALL MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES
IN OUR STATE HAVE DECREASED
DISPARITY STILL PERSISTS
ESPECIALLY AMONG BLACK AND
INDIGENOUS BIRTHING PEOPLE AS
MEDICAL PROVIDERS THAT SOMETIMES
THE STATION'S OURSELVES BLACKMAN
PHYSICIANS ARE UNIQUELY INVOLVED
IN THIS CRISIS. WE NOW I ASK
THAT YOU FULLY FUND THE
MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE THAT COUNTY
FETAL AND INFANT MORTALITY
REVIEW COMMITTEES AND DO WHAT
MEDICARE BENEFITS FUNDING THESE
PROVISIONS IS AN INVESTMENT TOOL
IT'S ELIMINATING CALIFORNIA'S
RACIAL AND SOCIOECONOMIC
DISPARITIES IN BIRTH OUTCOMES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS JENNIFER MALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION I JUST WANTED TO-
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
FORTY ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS- TOWARDS H. AS- IN
NATIONAL DISASTER RELIEF. AS
WELL AS THE THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS HEALTH PAPERS
FOR PROVIDERS- I HAVE BEEN
ALIGNED I ARE COMMON WITH
BEVERLY YOU FROM U. T. W. THANK
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EXCELLENT NUMBER TWO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU REMEMBER I AM PLAYING
WITH A CALIFORNIA ACCENT
COALITION WE ARE A PROUD LOCAL
SPONSOR OF THE MEDI CAL CARE
THAT MENTAL ILLNESS IS BIPOLAR
THE WAGE WHILE IMPROVED ACCESS
TO CRUCIAL MEDICATION FOR
MEDICARE PATIENTS WITH- AND
MINE. WHY ALSO THE LIVES OF
THOSE AROUND THEM THE CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
ITEM THE EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE NINETY EIGHT TELEPHONE
SURCHARGE THE TWO MILLION TWELVE
THOUSAND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AGENT FOR A DEPARTMENTAL
LEADERSHIP POSITION. IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE POLIKARPOV IT
REQUIRES AN AWFUL THE ALLOCATION
FOR THE HELP EQUITIES RESEARCH
AS DEFINED THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
NUMBER TWO NINE. PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AARON AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
CAPTAIN KELLY FROM THE BEAR A
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER ASKING
FOR SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
REQUESTED NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR
INSTANT SHARING DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION WITHIN CAREGIVER.
RESOURCE CENTER SYSTEM THAT
WOULD OPERATIONALIZE D. I.
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES ACROSS
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
IN KEEPING WITH THE MASTER PLAN
WHILE INCREASING SERVICES TO A
DIVERSE UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS
OF ADULTS WITHOUT PLUMBERS AND
RELIGIOUS ORDERS. THE
COMPETITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLEASE. NEXT
TO A LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR ROB
LIMIT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY HEALTH AGENCIES OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
ITEMS EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS THE
NINETY DAY TELEPHONE SURCHARGE
TO EARN TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THAT APARTMENT AGENTS ARE
DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
ANNUAL FUNDING TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE ON. WE SUPPORT
THE WHOLE PROPOSAL AFTER THAT
ABOUT THE ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES FOR CRUCIAL
CHARACTER WITHIN THE CHILD
WELFARE CONTINUUM OR PROBLEMS OR
THE FAMILY MEMBER GETS PULLED UP
TO THE TEN MILLION. DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT A STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH. HI PROGRAM WHILE
PLANNING TO THEY ARE AND- INTO
THE- YEAH THANKS BE CONTINUE TO
BE THOUGHT PRIORITY. EVEN
WITHOUT CO THAT. IS NOT FULLY
ADDRESSING THE CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH OR PREVENTATIVE CARE. THE
PILOT PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
DELEGATES REPEATED FOR ALL
SCHOOL PILOT TO ADDRESS THIS IN
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SERVICES
OUR PROVEN MODEL OF. PUNDITS
DIDN'T TURN CLEANING OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TEXTURA Y.
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TOM FRANKLIN I'M SUPPORTING
THE NOMINEE REQUEST FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- DOWNEY
CALIFORNIA MEMBER AND PRESIDENT
OF NAMI SANTA BARBARA COUNTY I
TOOK. A LEAD A FAMILY CLASS IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND IT HAS
BEEN TEACHING. FAMILY TO FAMILY
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN. THE FAMILY
WAS A LIFESAVER MY FAMILY AND
MANY OTHER FAMILIES YOU DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO TURN. WHEN FACED
WITH A MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER
THANK YOU THE TOOL COMPETENCE
AND HOPE TO GET THROUGH THE
DEVASTATING ELDER. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM
SO THAT ALL PEOPLE WITH A LOVED
ONE WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER CAN ACCESS THAT PLACE
DATING PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN GALLAGHER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STEPPING
STONE HEALTH. IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULT DAY
SERVICES I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
REQUEST FOR SIXTY FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
STATE FUNDING TO CREATE. THE
BRIDGE TO RECOVERY- DON'T THINK
SERVICEMEN. OVER NINETEEN
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM. RESPONDING HELP BUT
DON'T THINK SERVICES GROUP
PREPARE FOR SAFE RETURN FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES TO ADULT DAY
CENTERS. ALTHOUGH IT DOES RETURN
TO IN PERSON SERVICES FOR MAYBE
EIGHT YEARS TO FROM A MOMENT IF
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING BUT THE
PAST TWO YEARS BUT EXTREMELY
DETRIMENTAL. TO THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. THE FUNDING IS
NECESSARY AS WE UPGRADE OUR
FACILITIES AND OF COURSE OHER
MITIGATION EFFORTS TO REDUCE AND
PREVENT CODE INFRACTIONS. AND TO
ENSURE A SAFE RETURN IN PERSON
SERVICES FOR THE VERY VULNERABLE
OLDER. ADULT POPULATIONS WHICH
ARE. THANK YOU THANK VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT JULY
NUMBER TWO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CRACKED
OPEN FOR ON BEHALF OF HLA HELL
IN THE END THE EPIDEMIC
COALITION OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA HIT THE
ALARMING INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS. SKYROCKETING RATES OF.
GENTLE HELLO AND I'M GOING
TRANSMISSION OF HIV AND
HEPATITIS. WE WELCOME THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN PUBLIC HEALTH BUT TARGETED
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING REMAINS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THESE
EPIDEMIC AFFECTED LATE WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE SIX
PROPOSALS FROM THE AND THE
ACADEMICS COALITION WE ARE ALL
TWENTY STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND. AS WELL AS THE PROPOSAL
TERMINATE HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
TO EXPAND TESTING FOR HIV
HEPATITIS B. AND EPILEPTIC
HOSPITAL ER'S THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THEY CAN EXCEL BE FLY
FROM TO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- KEVIN TO DRIVING ON
BEHALF OF MAXIM HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. WELL WE'RE STILL IN
SUPPORT OF ON PAGE EIGHT THE ONE
TIME INCREASE FOR PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING HOME HEALTH CARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLEASE
. THANK YOU AND LINE TO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND WORKING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
TO OFFER SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR BRIDGE LINE FOR
DISTRICT HOSPITALS THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION FOR HOSPITAL
MEDICAL EQUITY PAYMENT. TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ALLOW PROPER
VALUE IT IS SURE TO PURCHASE
WHAT INDUCTION UNITY HOSPITAL IN
ADDITION ATG GENERALLY SUPPORT
THE NUMBER OF HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND EDUCATION PROPOSALS
INCLUDING. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
FUNDING FOR MEDICARE GME FIFTY
ONE MILLION FOR LONGER PAYMENT
PROGRAM IN TRAINING CLASS TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS
FOR PRIMARY AND FAMILY MEDICINE
GME PROGRAM TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY. MILLION PRINT COPIES
UNTIL NINETEEN THIRTY. I THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR BEING
HEALTH WORK FOR EXPANSION AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU WINE AT
TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YEAH I HAD. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT TO SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SUE EVANS AND I'M
CALLING UP FROM WALDEN FAMILY
SERVICES WHICH PROVIDES THE
FUNDING AGENCY SEVENTY DROP UP
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CALLING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE CAROLINE
COLA TO FULLY FUND THE OFF OF
THE TIME THE AGENCIES OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. WE HAVE HALF THE
FUN THE AGENCIES ARE WORKING
WITH SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
THE CHILDREN MANY WHO ARE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE MANY WHO HAVE
STUCK WITH A LOT OF TRAUMA. AND
WE HAVE FIVE EATING IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN ALL SOCIAL WORKERS TO
WORK WITH THIS VERY NEEDY
POPULATION. BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
ABLE AND- TO BE INVESTED RATE WE
WOULD LIKE FOR SOCIAL. I'M
ASPIRE TO STAY THAT WE ARE BEING
THAT ON THE- OF TOOK BY A HIGH
TENNIS WITH A SHORT WHILE. SO I
. THAT WE CAN OF FUNDING. MUCH
NEEDED COLOUR TO HELP PROVIDE.
STABILITY SOCIAL WORKERS WHO
OFFERED TO CHILDREN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
THIRTY THIRTY A LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KERRY SANDERS SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA PEN
I THINK HEALTH NETWORK URGING
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
REQUEST ENHANCING DATA TO REDUCE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE ON PAGES SIX AND
SEVEN. THE PROCESS OF
ELIMINATING HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN RACIAL INEQUITIES STARTS WITH
HIGH QUALITY DATA UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE STATE LAW THE QUALITY OF
HEALTH PLAN DATA VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM PLAN TO PLANT
WHICH IS UNDER THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO MEASURE AND HOLD
HEALTH PLANS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
DIVERSE POPULATIONS. THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR FUNDS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE WILL IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING FOR SMALLER
POPULATION SUCH AS ASIAN NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
LGBTQ CLASS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CLEAR
ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS AS WELL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
PLANTING PROVIDERS. ON HOW TO
PROPERLY COLLECTED DATA. WITH
HIGH QUALITY DATA CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLAN CAN BETTER IDENTIFY
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND ADDRESS
HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS
LEADING TO BETTER. HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLER.
THANK YOU THAT'LL COME FROM MINE
TO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE I
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KATIE AND
CHERYL WITH CHILDREN NOW. AS
NOTED IN OUR MUCH MORE DETAILED
WRITTEN COMMENTS CHILDREN OUT
FOR THE FEDERAL STATE. LOCAL
TODAY I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT OUR
SUPPORT AND JUST A FEW INCLUDING
OUR COSPONSORED ATHLETICALLY THE
INCIDENT EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND PROVIDER
TRAINING. CONTINUING MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN AND
REFINING THE HACCP TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO TIMELY AND APPROPRIATE
PEDIATRIC HEARING WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT.
SPECIAL NEEDS DENTISTRY
EXPANSION AND THE MEDIC HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAME CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY THANKS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I NOT ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE ASSIGNMENT HI HI SORRY
YEAH HI MY NAME IS DR MAKE FRIED
HER ID ON AM I PRACTICING DOCTOR
OF CHIROPRACTIC IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE IT CAN'T HELP FALLING
IN I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE BACK AT THE STATION
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE
CHIROPRACTIC. MANY CAL. OPTIONAL
BENEFIT FOR ADULTS. I ADULT
BENEFICIARIES MODIFYING THAT YOU
VISIT A MONTH MEDI CAL MANAGED A
TWENTY FOUR GET THAT MONEY I
HEARD YOU APPROVED IT OKAY-
PROPOSAL. I'M VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE
OF THE COST EFFICIENCY AND COST
SAVINGS. I THANK YOU UNDER
MEDICAID DETERMINED THAT THERE
WOULD BE COST SAVINGS AND THE
DATA VERY CLEAN FOURTEEN POINT
ONE AND FORTY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION ONE PRIOR FACTORS. ARE
INCLUDED AS COVERED PROVIDERS
UNDER MISSOURI MEDICAID THE
STUDY ALSO SUPPORTS IMPROV
PROPOSITION THAT TREATMENT BY.
OUR BACKYARDS FOR NEXT AND LOWER
BACK PAIN MAY REDUCE THE USE OF
ABUSE OF OPIOID RESTRICT
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AND THEY'RE
ALSO FOUND THAT ONE
CHIROPRACTIC- CARE PROVIDE
BETTER OUTCOMES AT A LOWER COST
YOU ARE PACKING TREATMENT AND
CARE LEADS TO REDUCTION IN COST
OF SPINAL SURGERY AND THREE.
IRAQI CARED NEED TO COST SAVINGS
AND REJECTED THE VIEWS OF THE
EIGHT OPIOID PRESCRIPTION
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. I HIGHLY-
YOU YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THAT THAT A LOT OF PATIENCE IN
MY COMMUNITY WHO ARE ON MEDICAID
AND THEY'VE LOST THEIR JOBS OR
WHATEVER. THEIR STREET IS VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL TODAY. AND IF I CAN
SEE TO PEOPLE SAID THERE ARE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVING TO GETTING
INTO THE QUEUE- SO HAVE YOU MADE
YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE HANG UP-
AND CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO THE
HEARING WHILE YOU'RE NOT WAITING
IN THE QUEUE TO ALLOW. FOR OTHER
PEOPLE ALTHOUGH I WOULD NOTE
THERE'S ONE CHAIR AND WE'VE NOW
HAD THREE OPERATORS. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU-
NECKLINE WILL BE FROM TWO TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LUCY QUESTION ELLA I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MATERNAL AND
CHILD HEALTH ACCIDENT TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THREE MEASURES OF THE
FIRST TO THAT PAGE NINE
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE IN MEDICARE
HEALTH FOR YOUNG CHILDREN THE
SECOND IS THAT PAGE ELEVEN
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS THEY
ARE SO ESSENTIAL TO LINKING
PEOPLE. NOT ONLY TO COVERAGE BUT
TO ACCESSING CARE MUCH RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH
NAVIGATORS HEALTH OUTCOMES
IMPROVE THIRD PAGE SEVEN THE
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM EXTENSION A MADAM CHAIR
YOUR VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE A
FEW YEARS AGO AT THE ONE OH FOUR
KICK THIS OFF WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE. AND THEN
THE FEDS- GOT BLUE STEM FROM
THAT EXAMPLE AND NOW HAVE
PROVIDED FOR AN OPTION FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES TO
COVER. INDIVIDUALS POST PARTUM
FOR A FULL TWELVE MONTHS BUT CPS
P. IS THE LINK WE NEED TO HAVE
THOSE WARM HAND OFF SO THAT
PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET TO THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS THAT
THEY GET TO THE CARDIOLOGISTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL THE. DAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IT TO
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EXCUSE ME TO
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REBECCA MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
AND LIVE STATS AND SUPPORT OF AN
INITIATIVE THEY'RE COSPONSORING
TOGETHER TO HELP YOUR HOME AGENT
PLACE NURSING PROGRAM IS NOT
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A LINK
SOCIAL AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING
FIGHT. ENABLING OLDER RESIDENTS
REMAIN LIVING INDEPENDENTLY AND
AVOIDING UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES SUCH AS
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY STATE OF THE
CODE BONDS ARE LEADING H.
CALIFORNIANS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE TARGETED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. TO PREVENT AND AT
HOME AND HOMELESSNESS AMONG
ADULTS AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES PROPOSAL FOR ALL
THE REASONS ALREADY CITED BY
GENERAL CORPS WHISKEY S. H.
ADDITIONALLY LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS THE
GERIATRIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
LEADERSHIP POSITION EXPANSION OF
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY FOR PAID.
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY REFORM
AND INVESTING IN OLDER ADULTS
AND MODERNIZING. THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. TWO FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T COME HERE ON
BEHALF OF C. PEN WE SUPPORT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR THE HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND WHICH WAS ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY PARTY LAST YEAR WE
URGE THE SENATE TO CONTINUE ITS
SUPPORT FOR RESOURCES DIRECTLY
TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. COMMUNITY
DETERMINED HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE INNOVATION
PROJECTS ADDITIONALLY C. BEEN
COSPONSORED REQUEST AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT OF AT LEAST FIFTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND WHICH COMES
WITH A FEDERAL MATCH DIRECTLY TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
BUT THE SERVICES OF HEALTH CARE
NAVIGATORS. MEDI CAL SUCH AN
INVESTMENT IS NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE NOT ONLY HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE RATES AMONG
LOW INCOME POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BUT ALSO FOR TIMELY ACCESS
OF CARE. FURTHERMORE NAVIGATOR
SEVEN ESSENTIAL RESOURCE TO
REDUCE RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HELPING PROVIDE THE STATE WITH A
LOW COST AND EFFECTIVE WAY OF
IMPROVING ACCESS TO CARE THROUGH
COMMUNITY INFORMED APPROACH ONE
TIME FUNDING EIGHTY SEVEN FORCED
OUT WAS THE PREVIOUS PROGRAM BUT
THAT IN JUNE THIRTIETH THE
IMPLEMENTATION MODEL ADOPTED
PREVIOUSLY HAS PROVED OVERLY
BURDENSOME FOR ALL A FRESH START
IS NEEDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WHY AT TWO. FOUR YEAR
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SO THEY CAN SEE-
REPRESENTING ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH IN COMMON YOU KNOW
SEVERAL PIECES THAT WILL ADVANCE
HEALTH EQUITY IN THE STATE. WE
SUPPORT THAT THE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST BY THE ET
COALITION. TO CLOSE THE STI
COVERAGE THAT WOULD BE T.
POPULATION IN THE FAMILY PACK
PROGRAM BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE A
SEPARATE EPISODIC COVERAGE
PROGRAM. FOR LOW INCOME
UNINSURED PEOPLE THAT DON'T NEED
BIRTH CONTROL TO ACCESS FREE STI
SERVICES OKAY GOODLY IMPACTED BY
THE STRUCTURAL INEQUITY OUR
LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS. NEXT CONDOM
ACCIDENT SCHOOL YOU WANT TO NOTE
THAT BOTH THE CDC AND THE
SOCIETY FOR ADOLESCENT HEALTH
AND MEDICINE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ACCESS TO FREE CONDOMS IN
SCHOOLS. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REQUEST ESTABLISHED KIND OF
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM AND HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND THANK
YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAME
CHAIR. VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM. TO FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ANOTHER DONE ON BEHALF
OF NEXT AND CALIFORNIAN
ALCHEMIST CDC COOK FATHER SO THE
BUDGET REQUEST ESTABLISHING A
NON COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
ASSIST IN THIS DALLAS MAN
EXTENSION OF THE B. T. SERVICES
AFTER THE FINAL FARMERS MARKET.
CONSISTENT WITH B. NINE OF SEVEN
DR. THE CURRENT SYSTEM MANY THAT
OFTEN PREVENT FARMERS MARKET
FROM AFFECTING EVPCARD MARKET
THAT DO OFFER EASY P. ACCESS
TYPICALLY FIND THAT ADDITIONAL
ADMIN AT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
NEEDED TO FULLY WITH THE
BENEFITS OF THE B. KEY ACCESS.
BECAUSE ADDING COOKING ADD UP IN
A FARMER'S MARKETS OPERATE ON
SUCH THAT MARGIN MANY DID NOT GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF OFFERING
THE V. P. SERVICES. THE PROPOSAL
IS A WIN WIN FOR CALFRESH WHAT
RECIPIENTS AND OUR FARMERS
COVERAGE RECIPIENTS WILL BE ABLE
TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL VENUES
WHERE THEY CAN PURCHASE FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES AND
INCREASE ECONOMIC BENEFIT FOR
SMALL AND MIDSIZE FARMS
OPERATING A FARMERS MARKET.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR POOL
THE FOOTBALL PHOTO CREDIT LOCAL
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS
FOOD FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE TO
FOR THREE OR ONE OF THE-
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CLEAR
PARKER. SENATOR FAMILY OF EIGHT
AND THEN AGAIN THE POUT THE
PROPOSED COW ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO THE CHILDREN CRISIS
CONTINUING PILOT PROGRAM AS YOU
KNOW THE US IS EXPERIENCING AN
URGENT CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT HAVE. INTENSIVE
TREATMENT OPTION FOR CHILDREN
AND ADOLESCENTS OUR PROPOSAL
BUILDS UPON THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE EXAM OF THE LEGISLATOR
TO ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL
SHORTAGES BY EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM ACCESS CRITERIA TO
INCLUDE MEDICAL USE. ADDITIONAL
CONTINUE ON PILOTS TO MEET THE
NEEDS STATEWIDE AND SUPPORTING
PILOTS THROUGH THE DURATION OF
THE FIVE YEAR PROGRAM AT THE
STATEWIDE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
ANNIKA IS ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
SPONSORED PROPOSALS FOR TARGETED
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT.
THEY LIVE IN A STATE OF
PENSACOLA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LYING TO FORTY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MATT CHAIR BUT
DAN WHO PLUS FROM THE HELP
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS- CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE DDS- PROPOSAL
NUMBER NINE ON PAGE TWENTY FIVE
BUT DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION ABOUT
THE EXTREME NINE. WHICH IS UP TO
THE NEW AGE FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES WE'RE OPPOSED THAT
PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE- NOW IS NOT
THE TIME TO PUT THE BRAKES ON
THE WAY OF THAT MANY NON SEVEN
WHICH FADES OUT INSTEAD WE
SHOULDBE REPORTING ALL WORKERS
CAUGHT CALIFORNIAN WITH MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY. YOU
VERY MUCH AND COLOR PLEASE. THEY
GIVE OUT COME FROM MY TO FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU. CHARLOTTE
DIXON ON THE BUDGET DIRECTOR OF
BEVERAGE CALIFORNIA THE STATE
COALITION OF FORTY FOUR VILLAGE
COMMUNITIES INDIGENOUS WEALTH IN
OLDER ADULTS. INTERGENERATIONAL
VOLUNTEERS AND CAREGIVERS WE THE
ONE HUNDRED BLOCK OF ST JOHN
MORE FUNDS TO SELL OBJECTIVE
NUMBER NINETY. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. AMONG THE
DOCTOR WHICH MODELS VOLUNTEER
RECRUITMENT SERVICES ON PAGE
TWENTY TWO OF THE PACKET. WILL
SUPPORT A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP. I'M LOOKING FOR THE
VILLAGE. INFRASTRUCTURE ALLOWING
US TO EXPAND OUR PEER BASED
MODEL OF CARE WITH A FOCUS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THE
MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS. ARE
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME OLDER
ADULTS OF THE FORGOTTEN MIDDLE
DO NOT QUALIFY FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE. THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY THEIR WAY THROUGH THE AGING
PROCESS. STILL A CRITICAL GAP IN
THE AGING SERVICES NETWORK AND
LOOK FORWARD TO INTEGRATING OUR
MOVEMENT INTO THE DEPARTMENT
AGING NO WRONG DOOR. KNOBS AND
COKE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL. TO YOUR OFFICE. HE'S
THANK YOU OVER TO THIRTY SEVEN
YEAR LINE IS UP. FINE TOOTH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO YOU
HAVE A SOME YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I SPEAK TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHARACTERISTICS REQUESTS FOR
ACCESS TO. DOCTORS OF
CHIROPRACTIC FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. I'M DOCTOR LIGHT
FREEZING I'M A LICENSED DOCTOR
CHIROPRACTIC FOR FIFTY TWO
YEARS. OVER SIX DECADES I HAVE
PROVIDED CARE TO MINIMUM.
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. WITH THE
TO VISIT LIMITATION INSPIRED TO
RESEARCH THAT DEMONSTRATES THE
BENEFIT OF SERVICES PROVIDED BY
DOCTORS OF CHIROPRACTIC. ONE
ATTENTION DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
PRETREATMENT INTERVENTION
PROTOCOLS TO BE PROVIDED. AND IT
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS
DOCTORS OF CHIROPRACTIC PROVIDE.
NON PRESCRIPTION DRUG AND NON
SURGICAL SERVICES. THE SERVICE
IS IMPORTANT TODAY. PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THE A YES. YES YES SHE
ALSO SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF
THE ADULT BENEFIT. OBVIOUSLY
THESE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
RECOVERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL.
TODAY YOUR TIME IS UP NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO ONE AT SIX TWO LINE
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS HEATHER FOR COLIN I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
LIBRARY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE- TWENTY POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO POSITIVE PARENTING
PROGRAMS AND FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES. IN NINE COUNTIES
INCLUDING MY OWN THIS ITEM CAN
BE FOUND IN BOTH THE DH CS AND
DS THAT SECTIONS OF THE AGENDA.
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAMS HAVE
BECOME A CRITICAL COMPONENT IN
THE PROMOTION OF A CHILD'S WELL
BEING AND ADDRESSING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE NEEDS EXACERBATED BY
THE ONGOING PANDEMIC OUR
LIBRARIANS UTILIZE THE POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAM TO CONSULT ON
MANY. COMMON PARENTING AND
CAREGIVING ISSUES FOR CHILDREN
AND TEENS WE UTILIZE TRIPLE P.
DURING INTERACTIONS THAT ARE
EIGHTY FIVE LIBRARIES DURING
OUTREACH VISITS TO DAYCARE
CENTERS SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE OVER THREE THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES OF LA COUNTY. AND TO THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION RESIDENTS
THAT WE SERVE. THE BEST THE
FUNDING PROVIDED VERY MUCH IN.
YOUR TIME IS UP NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOUR TO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR HAPPY BIRTHDAY AMY
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THREE
ITEMS MEDI CAL EQUITABLE PAYMENT
MODERNIZATION WORKFORCE FUNDING
FOR CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS AND
MEDICAL GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
PROVIDE CARE TO OVER ONE MILLION
CHILDREN ANNUALLY INCLUDING
CHILDREN WITH SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS INJURIES AND ILLNESSES
63% OF PATIENTS ARE ON MEDICARE
HOW MEDICARE RATES FOR HOSPITALS
HAVE BEEN FROZEN SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE THIRTEEN AND URGENTLY
NEED TO BE INCREASED TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE QUALITY CARE TO OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY. IN THE WORK
FORCE FOR CHILDREN HOSPITALS
THERE SEVENTEEN PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
EIGHT PROVIDED BY CCSA MEMBER
HOSPITALS YOU TRAIN 45% OF ALL
PEDIATRIC. RESIDENTS AND 12% OF
ALL FELLOW. AFTER TRAINING
PROGRAMS LACK STABLE FUNDING ARE
NOT FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR MANY PROGRAMS H. K.
AND PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
YOU'LL SEE THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FROM THE VON BRAUN
PROGRAM. THESE FUNDS WILL HELP
PROVIDE CRITICAL TRAINING FANCY
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE TO FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM DORRIGO TOLD
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNOLOGY AND I'M ALSO A
CLINICAL LABORATORY SCIENTIST
AND I'D LIKE TO- OF VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIBER OF THE
CLINICAL LABORATORY SCIENTISTS
AND MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNICIAN INTERNSHIP. PROGRAM
AND IT'S ON PAGE- THREE YEARS
LEFT FOR FUNDING OF TWELVE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC DRAMATICALLY
EXPOSED THE NEED FOR MORE
CLINICAL LABORATORY TESTING
PERSONNEL RESULTING IN MASSIVE
TESTING THE DEMANDS PLACED UPON
CLINICAL LABS CURRENTLY THERE
ARE OVER. ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED VACANT TESTING PUT ABOUT
PERSONNEL POSITIONS
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
GRADUATES PER YEAR FROM
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE UNABLE TO
OBTAIN THE INTERNSHIPS NECESSARY
TO GAIN THE REQUIRED CLINICAL
LAB EXPERIENCE DESPITE BEING
QUALIFIED TO DO SO HOSPITAL
LABORATORIES AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS OKAY WELL WITH EXISTING
CREDENTIALS TO TRAIN CLINICAL
LABORATORY. PERSONNEL WOULD ADD
A FIFTY PLUS TRAINING POSITIONS
PER YEAR WITH THE SESSION
FUNDING FOR THE NEXT NINETY VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CALL. TODAY YOUR
TIME IS UP NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK LINE TO FACE SO YOUR IS
OPEN. THE DANGER ADMIN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME BENITO
DELGADO OLSEN I'M DIRECTOR IT'S
IMPLIED BANK DOT ORG SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE VERY LAST ITEM ON
THE AGENDA FOR STATEWIDE DIAPER
DISTRIBUTION. WHICH IS ALSO
CHAMPIONED BY FAMILY MEMBERS OR
VOLUNTEERS IN THE FAMILY THE
NATIONAL DIAPER BANK NETWORK IS
A CO SPONSOR OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA FIRST BY ASSOCIATION
DOZENS OF COUNTIES AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ARE IN SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
THANKS IN PART YOUR LEADERSHIP
HAS MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS ON
THIS ISSUE THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR THREE YEAR PILOT WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL REMAINING
COUNTIES IN OUR STATE HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND A
VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND THANK
YOU FOR SPENDING SO MUCH TIME ON
YOUR BIRTHDAY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ALL APPRECIATE IT THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU BLINDED TO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SERVICES PROPOSALS ARCA SUPPORTS
ITEM TO THE LANTERN IN
COALITIONS REQUESTS TO
ACCELERATE IMPLEMENTATION OF
REFORM TO ADDRESS THAT YES
PEOPLE ARE SURCHARGE. THAT ITEM
THREE D. B. I N. STEPS PROPOSAL
FOR ABOUT MONITORING
DEMONSTRATION PILOT. MARKET
INDEX YEAH YOU WERE CURRENTLY
REQUESTING THE MODERNIZATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS
BUDGETING LONG OVERDUE REFORM
WILL ENSURE REGIONAL CENTER.
FUNDING LEVELS MATCH REAL WORLD
COSTS- SERVE PEOPLE WITH. THE
SEPARATELY ARCOS REQUESTING THE
END OF THE ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM
FEET AND FAMILY CALLS FOR
CESSATION PROGRAM. THESE FEES
REASONABLE FUNDS BUT CAN CREATE
MAJOR BARRIERS TO SERVICE FOR
FAMILIES. LASTLY UNDER
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY. TARGETS
SUPPORTS ITEM ON THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION'S REQUESTS
DEVELOP SPECIAL NEEDS DENTISTRY
CLINICS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
GET A COME FROM MINE AT TWO
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY DIRECT MY NAME
IS JOANNE CAMPBELL I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE LA CARE HEALTH
PLAN. OR THAT THE PROPOSED
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR MEDICAL PROVIDER
DATA SHARING AND THAT AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE TWO SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR HAPPY BIRTHDAY TODAY
AND RE BAKER ON BEHALF OF COPE
FAMILY CENTER AND THE NAPA
COUNTY TRIPLE P. COLLABORATIVE
IN NAPA COUNTY SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAM AND
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES IN NINE
COUNTIES INCLUDING MY OWN. THIS
ITEM CAN BE FOUND IN BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE AND DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES SECTION OF THE GENDER.
AND HE PROGRAMS HAVE BECOME A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN COURT
PROMOTION OF CHILD WELL BEING
AND ADDRESSING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CARE NEEDS. EXACERBATED BY THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC. THE COUNTY
COLLABORATIVE HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF PROVIDING HOME VISITATION
TRIPLE P. POSITIVE PARENTING
PROGRAM AT NO COST TO FAMILIES
TO SUPPORT THESE NEEDS. HELPING
REDUCE CHILD ABUSE DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND STRESS. THE FUNDING
SUPPORTED. AND PROVIDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW US TO EXPAND
IN HAMPSHIRE PROGRAMMING THE
BENEFIT OF MORE FAMILY I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU LYING TO
SEVENTY YEAR ALLIANCE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GABBY
CADENCE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION TO ECHO R. D. COURT TO
FULLY FUND THE CALIFORNIA MIND
ABOUT THAT AT THE SIXTY FIVE AND
ALSO THE COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
SERVICES PROGRAM EXTENSION WHICH
CAN BE FOUND ON PAGE SEVEN.
THESE IT CRAMPED ARE VITALLY
NEEDED FOR FAMILIES WITH NE
BABIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE TO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT AFTERNOON
MADAME CHIANG MANY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CARISSA CALMER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PRESS YOU
KNOW LIFE IN LOS ANGELES I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR FULLY FUNDING THE PROVISIONS
OF SB FIFTY FIVE THINK HELPING
MOM NOT BEST ACT. LACKING
INCISION WORKING PEOPLE DIET
RATES THREE TO FOUR TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE STATE AVERAGE AS THE
FIFTY FIVE WILL ADDRESS THE
MATERNAL AND INFANT MORTALITY
CRISIS IN OUR STATE WE ASK THAT
YOU FULLY FUND THE MIDWIFERY
WORKFORCE PRACTICALITY IT ON
INFANT MORTALITY REVIEW
COMMITTEES AND THE DEALER. MEDIC
HEALTH BENEFITS AND I ALSO WANT
TO MY SUPPORTERS LIKE
COMPREHENSIVE HEARING ADULT
SERVICES PROGRAM EXTENSION ON
PAGE SEVEN EITHER VITALLY NEEDED
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES WITH NEW
BABIES AND ISN'T ON INVESTMENT
TOWARD LIMITING RACIAL AND
SOCIOECONOMIC DISPARITIES. IN
BIRTH AND BREASTFEEDING OUTCOMES
THANK YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
MADAME CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
OPEN. NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I NEED. ALL
RIGHT NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN CHOW I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF THE FICTIONAL
PROPOSAL ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. SECOND
HARVEST IS STILL KIND OF ALLEY
WANTED US REGIONAL FOOD BANK
AND- ISLAND HARVEST. USE
FAMILYSEARCH IS LA FEEDING SAN
DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD
BANK. AND WE URGE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO FULLY FUND
CONTROL TO PROVIDE FOOD SYSTEMS
TO CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE TO SEVENTY FIVE DELIGHTED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT EXACTLY
EXACTLY HALF OF THE ENTIRE. THE
POINT THE PROPOSED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT MEDIC
HELP PROVIDERS DATA SHARING
INSPECTED THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WILL HELP ADVANCE NOW THAT
TRACKS AND THEN PROVIDE. CHINA
VERY DATA ABOUT HOPE HE. YOUR
MISSION IS BEING DELIVERED CARE
TO ALL PATIENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR. THANK YOU
AND THAT WILL COME FROM LINE
SIXTEEN LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
SIX SIXTEEN YEAR WAS ON MUTE.
YOUR FATHER ACTUALLY CHARACTERS
FROM TWENTY YEARS AGO COUNTY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CALCAREOUS
QUEST TO REMOVE THE TREE THE
DIPLOMATIC CAP ON HOW TO CARE
FOR MEDICARE RECIPIENTS. IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE IT WON'T BE- AND
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
SERVING THE GREATER THAN FORTY
THOUSAND MEDICAL RETIREMENT
ACCOUNT RECIPIENT OUR LITTLE
COUNTY. EVERY MAJOR SPINAL WILL
RECOMMEND CARE OPTIONS WITHIN
THE CURRENT SCOPE THAT'S FOR
TWENTY INTERVENTION. AND YOU CAN
FIND EVIDENCE BASED
CAPITALIZATION PLACE LIKE A BA
THE MAYO CLINIC AND UNIVERSITY
HOSPITAL THAT TREATS EACH.
TECHNICAL GUIDELINES TO GET THE
STICKS TO THE TRIAL OVER SEVERAL
WEEKS HE DOESRESPOND TO MAKING.
CHANGES TO CARE AND EXERCISE
BECAUSE IT ALONG THE WAY UNLIKE
MANY CUSTOMER TWENTY FOUR DIGIT
YEARLY CAP ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT CAPT ARBITRARILY.
ANSWERING CALGARY YOU DON'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DATE QUICKLY
EFFECTIVELY HELP. BY LYING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR TIME IS UP
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
DO FORTY NINE YEAR AS THOUGH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THAT
DEBRIS IN A FOUR K. FROM DELAY
FOR RIGHTS IN ADDITION TO THE
FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM EXPANSION WHICH ARE
COSPONSORS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
EARLIER WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR CAN GET PROGRAM
EXPANSION WHICH WOULD ENSURE
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH FIND A PERMANENT HOME WITH
THE RELATIVE CAREGIVER. WILL
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS
IN CLOSING THE GAPS THAT HAVE
OFTEN LEFT RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
WITHOUT FUN TO MEET A CHILD NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AT LEAST A
CAL AND I SERVICE THE WESTERN
REGION STATE POLICY MANAGER AT
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
RARE DISORDERS. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BUDGET REQUEST TO CREATE A
RARE DISEASE ADVISORY COUNCIL IN
THE STATE WHICH WILL PROVIDE A
VOICE FOR THE ONE IN TEN
INDIVIDUALS. LIVING WITH RARE
DISEASE IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
MADAME CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR JORDAN AND
SEE WITH THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATING FOR CALIFORNIA'S WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES-
WE WANT TO CALL IN IN SUPPORT OF
MANY ITEMS ON THE AGENDA BUT
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO SUPPORT OF
THE ISLAMIC COALITION PROPOSAL
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS WITH IDG
. WORKING SERVICES RATIONED DUE
TO THE SHORTAGE OF WORKFORCE AND
WE ARE PROPOSING TO ACCELERATE
THE DDS RATE STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY SUPPORTING THE DDS
RATES TO THE ADDENDUM AND
ONGOING UPDATES SPONSORED BY THE
LABOR COALITION IN ARKANSAS
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT REGIONAL
CENTER CAN WE FEES. FINALLY A
FEW MORE QUICKLY SUPPORTING
MODERNIZATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS THEN THE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY. REPORTING UPDATING
THE MEDICAL SHARE OF COST
CALCULATION THE TARGETED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES TO REPENT AND
HOMELESSNESS. THE 10% RATE
INCREASE FOR ITF DD'S. COPING
NINETEEN MITIGATION RESILIENCE
GRANTS FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES
AND FAMILY SUPPORTING. THE
SPECIAL NEEDS DENTISTRY CLINICS
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH THANK YOU
NICE COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE OF OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE A SON MUTE TWO SEVEN
NINE. I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT MY
NAME IS BONNIE COOK WANTED US
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
IN SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA ME
CHRISTIAN LEGAL FELLOWSHIP. THIS
IS THE FIRST STATEWIDE PROGRAM
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO IMMIGRANT
COUNCIL IN THE MOST UNDERSERVED
RURAL REGIONS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WILL APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU TWO EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
HIS CABINET BAR IN THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH COUNCILS IN LOS ANGELES
FOLLOWING TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT IN A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS
PROPOSAL. HEALTH NAVIGATORS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING COMMUNITIES
CAN GET COVERAGE AND ACCESS TO
CARE ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA
EXPANDED MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY.
AND THE CALL THE PHD ONLINE.
ALSO CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE FOLLOWING PROPOSALS
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND.
FULLY FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA MOM
THE BACKPACK THE FOOD FOR ALL OF
THE TOP EXPANSION PROPOSAL AND
THE FOOD WITH CARE FREE MEALS
FOR KIDS IN PRESCHOOL AND CHILD
CARE PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU LINE TWO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU I'M
DELIGHTED TO SHARE A BIRTHDAY
WITH YOU SENATOR- AGAIN THIS IS
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE BUDGET HEARING
OUR MEMBERS ARE GRATEFUL THAT SO
MUCH ATTENTION OR RESOURCES ARE
BEING FOCUSED ON SELLING MASTER
PLANNED FOR AGENTS. AND BROKERS
FROM OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES THERE'S SO
MUCH GREAT STUFF WE'RE JUST
GONNA TALK ABOUT A FEW THINGS
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY QUALITY
STANDARDS BOARD GERIATRIC
BEHAVIOR HEALTHLEADERSHIP A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE VILLAGES.
INFRASTRUCTURE VERY PROUD MEMBER
BY THE WAY CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE CONSUMER. QUALITY WEBSITE
TARGETED HOUSING SUBSIDIES TO
PREVENT AND IN OUTLOOK AMONG
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING SUPPORT
SERVICES BACK INVESTING IN OLDER
ADULTS AUTHORIZATION OF THE
OLDER CALIFORNIA BACK I WOULD
LIKE SPECIAL ATTENTION. FOR THE
CONTINUATION AND ENHANCEMENT OF
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TRAINING. THIS FUNDING REQUEST I
WE WOULD ASK THAT IT IS A MINUTE
TO. CRUDE AS APPROPRIATE.
INCLUDING THE TRAINING OF LOCAL
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN AS
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO PROVIDE THE LONG
TERM CARE ABOUT ADVOCATE. IS
GREATLY NEEDED IN HAND THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR TIME IS UP
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ZERO
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO EIGHT
NINETY OF THE TIME YOU. I AM
SORRY I YES IT'S CARLENE HOLDEN
WOULD BE REPRESENTING MAJOR
HE'LL AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA-
WE OFFER SUPPORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY ISSUES
ARE SPECIFICALLY THE LETTERMAN
COALITION'S PROPOSAL TO UPDATE
MIXOLOGY. IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DETAILS RIGHT. AND ALSO THE
PROPOSAL FROM ARTWORK TO UPDATE
THE CORE STAFFING FORMULA AND
ALSO TO ELIMINATE THE FAMILY SEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY LINE
THROUGH NINETY YEAR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM MAUREEN
CASSIDY FROM ELDORADO COUNTY AND
I'M AN HSS PROVIDERS WHEN
WILDFIRES AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS HAPPEN THERE'S LITTLE
BEING DONE TO HELP DIGESTIVE
COMMUNITY THAT IS WHY I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE DISASTER RELIEF PROPOSAL
FOR A CHANCE AT. I WENT THROUGH
TO NATURAL DISASTERS LAST YEAR
WITH MY LIVING RECIPIENTS WE
WERE EVACUATED FROM THE CALIBER
FIRE FOR EIGHTEEN DAYS AND THEN
AT THE END OF DECEMBER. AND
SNOWSTORM CAME ALONG WITH OVER
THREE FEET OF SNOW AND KNOCKED
OUT POWER OUT FOR NINE DAYS-
THESE INSTANCES WERE VERY
CHALLENGING THAT TOOK A LOT OF
EXTRA TIME AND EFFORT AND MONEY-
AND ANY KIND OF RELIEF WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO MY
CELEBRATE THESE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M SORRY FOR THE
DIFFICULTY ENCOUNTERED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CARE REMAINS VULNERABLE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS CINDY HILLARY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON OUR
SUPPORT FOR OUR TEAMMATES
SPECIFIC PRIORITIES- HIV HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANT PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE LOAN FORGIVENESS.
RESTORATION OF PEDIATRIC
VACCINATION RATES. MEDIC HOUSE
SPECIALTY CARE READ THE
DIFFERENT COLORS AT NAVIGATOR
PILOT PROGRAM ALSO WE'RE ENGAGED
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
COURT OF THE MEDIC HOW PROVIDER
DATA SHARING PROPOSAL THE
RESTORATION EASY NINETY SEVEN
REDUCTION AND- STABILIZATION OF
THE PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTY
NETWORK AND FUNDING FOR THE PARO
VALLEY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE IN THE COURT
OF THE CALIFORNIA PORTION WORKS
FINE THE CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH EQUITY THE PROPOSAL THE
PRIMARY CARE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL AND EQUITY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PAYMENT FOR
COMMUNITY CLINIC ABORTION
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I HOPE THE REST OF
YOUR BIRTHDAY IS A LOT MORE FUN
THAN. THE YOU VERY MUCH COLOR.
NINE TO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MARIE AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE SELF HELP PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS ON ON PAGE TWENTY
OF THE AGENDA I KEPT THE FAMILY
THE FAMILY COURTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN THE STATE WORK
YEAH THIS EIGHT WEEK COURSE WAS
A LIFESAVER FOR BOTH MY WIFE AND
ME. WELL I'M HAVING A SON WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS UNDER THE
GUIDANCE AND TRAINED
FACILITATORS AND ACKLINS
RESOURCE MATERIALS WE ARE
OFFERED MERION SOURCES OF
INFORMATION ON HOW TO OFFER OUR
LOVED ONES- WAYS TO LIVE. WITH
THIS LIFE LONG GET THE- LITTLE
ELDER THINGS LIKE A HOPELESS
THAT YOU. BUT WE HAVE SEEN THAT.
YOU IS NOT CURABLE YET BUT
FAMILY AND FAMILY COURSE
ENCOURAGES US. TAKING THE COURSE
THE HOPE FOR OUR LOVED ONES
UNTIL THEY CAN HOPE FOR
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF THE FAMILY THE FAMILY PROGRAM. THANK YOU THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU TO AT NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON FAMILY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GEORGE RAYA. BOARD MEMBER OF
THE GLOBAL SERVICES ORGANIZATION
IT'S A SACRAMENTO HIV AIDS
AGENCY WORKING WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR I AM
CALLING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM THE N. B.
S. DENTAL COALITION. I SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST TO ESTABLISH A
NEW AND EXPANDED HEALTH EQUITY
AND HARM REDUCTION INITIATIVES-
WHICH IS SET TO EXPIRE I
BELIEVE- TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE- THANK YOU AND THEN-
HAVING BIRTHDAY SATURDAY A
MONTH. THANK YOU FOR MENTIONING
COLOR PLEASE. TWO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MANAGER THIS IS CARLA
DO A COMMENTS ON THREE PROPOSALS
FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT
FOR INCLUSION OF FUNDS UNDER
AUSTERITY BIT INCREASING SUPPLY
OF CLINICAL LABORATORY SCIENTIST
MEDICAL LAB TECHNICIANS. SECOND
ABOUT THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WITH IBD WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT HOLES BY THE LETTERMAN
COALITION SPECIALLY THE ITEMS
SPEED UP FUNDING. OF THE RATE
STUDY OUTCOME THESE PROGRAMS
CANNOT MEET THEIR STAFFING NEEDS
AND THE CURRENT RATE. LASTLY WE
URGE YOU A DOG TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION
SB SIX THIRTY NINE FROM LAST
YEAR. UNTIL DATA RECEIVED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT GIVING YOU AN
ACCURATE PICTURE OF THE
EMPLOYMENT OF CALIFORNIANS OF
IDT AS A STANCE TODAY THOSE
AFFECTED BY THIS LEGISLATION ARE
LIKELY TO LOSE THEIR JOBS. THAT
THEY'VE CHOSEN UNDER THE RIGHT
PPE RAISING THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE OF THIS POPULATION ABOUT A
SOLUTIONS TO FOLLOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE TWO NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXIS
REBELS FOR A POLICY ANALYST AT
AND CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL PROGRAM- HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WITH US TODAY I'M CALLING
TO CONVEY AND HELP SUPPORT FOR
SEVERAL ITEMS. FIRST WE ARE
PROUD BECAUSE DOCTOR DOCTOR AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU FULLY
FUND AT THE SIXTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA MONITORS BACK-
CONTINUED MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN. AND THE
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF ENHANCING DATA TO
REDUCE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE NO
COST EXTENSION OF SHORT TERM
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM. I'LL HELP
FOR ALL OUT REGIONAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM- UPDATE THAT MEDICAL
SURE COST CALCULATION. AND
HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WANT
ONE LINE OF THE. ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO HOW ARE YOU MY
NAME IS LEVI TEN AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP FOUNDATION I'M
WRITING WRITING TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN MAINTAINING AND
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP.
I'M ALSO CALLING TO EXPAND FOOD
FOR ALL- THE CALIFORNIA-
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP OF
THE FIRST STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO IMMIGRATION
COUNSEL IN THE MOST UNDER
DESERVE RURAL REGIONS OF THE
STATE. THE MODEL PROVIDED BY THE
POSSIBLE OFFERING ATTORNEYS TO
BE HOUSED IN RURAL REGIONS WHILE
BEING TRAINED IN A COLLABORATIVE
STRUCTURE BY THE BEST MENTORS IN
OUR STATE I MYSELF. AM A LEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND- EMIGRATION
LEGAL FELLOW. AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE NEED FOR REMOTE OFFENSE
EVERYTHING IN THE WORLD AREAS OF
THIS COUNTRY ABOUT THE REGION
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO. HOW TO
BUDGET AGAIN HAPPY BIRTHDAY
CENTER AND HAVE A GOOD DAY.
OPTIONAL THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO NINETY EIGHT
AIRLINES OPEN. BUT AFTERNOON A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA RIVERA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK. AND
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH
FOR ALL OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M GOING THERE AFTER FOR
TARGETED OUTREACH TO
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT WILL SOON BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE. I WOULD WELCOME MORE%
PEOPLE INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND ARE THE AGES OF
FIFTY AND ABOVE. THE STATE MUST
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO FIND A ROBUST
OUTREACH PROGRAM TO TARGET THESE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. RESOURCES
MUST ALSO BE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT FOR THAT
FOLKS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS CAN
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEW COVERAGE
HOW TO ENROLL AND HOW TO ACCESS
THEIR BENEFITS. AND ALSO THE OF
THE BUDGET ITEM. THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND. FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND ONGOING FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE CALL
TODAY YOUR TIME IS UP NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT%
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO SIXTY ONE
DO YOU HAVE A SON MUTE. YES
SORRY HELLO MY NAME IS- BOTHERED
ABOUT THE MENU FROM COMMUNITY
DOESN'T ALLIANCE. AND ONE SHOW
MY SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP. WELL I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO HELP MY COMMUNITY AND PROVIDE
THIS MVIE UNDER RESOURCE AREA
WITH NEW EXPORT COMPLICATIONS
AND REMOVE THE FENCE AT THE
THAT'S REALLY HELPED WITH THE
CANCELLATION OF. REMOVAL CASES
SH AND BURNED OVER THIRTY
COMPETENT JUST ON MY OWN THE
OTHER NINE COLORS THAT I HAD
DONE TO MUCH IF NOT MORE AND WE
CAN IF WE DO NOT GET REFUNDED
THE HALF INCH OF ALLEY AND THE
COUNTRY CODE WILL GO WITHOUT.
SUCH CRUCIAL LEGAL SUPPORT BUT
WE URGE YOU FOR YOUR HELP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX FIVE
AIRLINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. NINE ONE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS ERIN
CARUTHERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE CHEMICAL ON THE HEALTH
MENTAL DISABILITIES WERE
SPONSORS OF SB SIX THREE NINE BY
SYNERGY TORONTO TO ELIMINATE
SOME MINIMUM WAGE OF. CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE VEHICLES ON
PAGE TWENTY FIVE TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTING SIX THIRTY NINE
THIS LAW ONLY WENT INTO EFFECT
TWO MONTHS AGO EVERYTHING IN THE
LAW IS ON TRACK AND THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING THE NEED FOR
DELAYS. TO THE CONTRARY THE
PROPOSAL CULTURE DEALS WITH
SUPPORTERS HAVE NO CONSTRUCTIVE
TRIPS TO. BE SIX THREE NINE
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
REJECTING A PROPOSAL ON THE BUT
ONLY CONTINUE EXPLOITING. PEOPLE
DEVELOPED THIS ABILITY. THANK
YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE. WE HAVE
FOUR LINE NUMBER. TWO NINETY
NINE NINETY NINE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
HEPATITIS ALLIANCE. SPEAKING OF
STRONG SUPPORT ALL OF THE AND
THE EPIDEMIC COALITION COALITION
PROPOSAL FOR HIV VIRAL HEPATITIS
AT THE EYES AN OVERDOSE WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO FUND THE
REQUEST TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS
AND INTERRELATED EPIDEMICS HAVE
ONLY GOTTEN WORSE UNDER COBRA WE
ALSO KNOW THAT COMPREHENSION
HENCE THE PRO WHICH TO
SKYROCKETING OVERDOSE RIGHT
CAPTAIN COULD TEXAS DISEASE
PREVENTION CARE AND TREATMENT.
ALSO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND AND THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TESTING FOR
HIV HEPATITIS C. AND SETLIST.
HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION
LINKAGE TO CARE PROPOSAL
CURRENTLY HAVE QUITE A FEW
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES WHICH
SERIOUSLY UNDER FUNDED NETWORK
THIS REQUEST FOR ALLOWANCE TO
STABILIZE NOT TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
MOVEMENT TOWARDS ENDING THAT
HEPATITIS C. EPIDEMIC IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU CALLER BLIND NUMBER. YOU
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL CALLAHAN AND THE FOLLOW
UP THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE
CENTER IN SANTA BARBARA I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP PROPOSAL I URGENTLY
URGE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF THE FELLOWSHIP
THEY'RE GOING TO MENTALLY NEED
FOR LEGAL REPRESENTATION IN THE
CENTRAL COAST THIS PROGRAM IS
PROVIDED ME WITH AMAZING
RESOURCES AND MENTORSHIP TO
REPRESENT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
OF SANTA BARBARA VENTURA AND
FAMILIES WILL BE FULL COUNTIES
THE CENTRAL COAST ALONE HAS
WELCOMED OVER A THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND
DISTINCTIVE SCHOLARSHIP BUT
MYSELF AND MY ORGANIZATION HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT THESE
CHILDREN AND HELP THEM OBTAIN
IMMIGRATION WE CAN SURELY
SECURELY LOCKED OUT OF THE WEST.
THANKS TO THIS PROGRAM I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF REUNITING A
MOTHER WITH HER TWO CHILDREN
AFTER BEING SEPARATED FOR OVER A
YEAR THIS WORK IS SO VALUABLE
AND NEEDED I URGE YOUR
CONTINUED. EXPANSION OF THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MADAME HAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
WE WERE BOTH ONLINE AND THREE.
THAT IS FINE THREE THERE ZERO
BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
K. HOCKEY AND YOU'RE DIRECTOR
SAN FRANCISCO VILLAGE AND BOARD
CHAIR VILLAGE MOVEMENT
CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE COALITION
OF FORTY FOUR VILLAGES. VILLAGES
ARE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONNECT OLDER
ADULTS TO THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND EXPERTISE THEY
NEED TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN
THE PLACES THEY CALL HOME. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE PILOT
PROGRAMS VILLAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO EXPANDABILITY NETWORKING
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
AND I ASKED THE SENATE TO
INCLUDE IT IN ITS BUDGET. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER. TWO FIFTY FOUR.
GET YOUR TICKETS FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ADRIAN HAREL FROM
ACTRESS ADVOCACY AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE SICKLE CELL
COMMUNITY ICAL TELLS THE LARGEST
RARE DISEASE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
COUNTRY AND CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
GOOD TO US THAT'S ACTUALLY IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE CREATION AND
OF THE RARE DISEASE ADVISORY
COUNCIL. ON IT WELL. HOW CAN I
PUT THIS IT WILL SPREAD THE-
FACT AND THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE- FROM THE SICKLE CELL GROUP
TO MANY MANY- WHERE DID THESE
OTHER RARE DISEASES WHO AREN'T
AS FORTUNATE AS US AS TO HAVE A
NEWBORN SCREENING NEW TREATMENT.
I AM QUITE A BIT OF SUPPORT FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
OTHER THING IT WILL DO FOR SURE
IS IT WILL UP TO MINE THAT'S ALL
I HAVE FOR TODAY I THINK YOU MAY
RECALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER THREE OH SEVEN.
MY NUMBER THREE OH SEVEN YEAR
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MONA I.
JAKO I'M THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
THE GOVERNMENT AND ALL DAY
COMFORT CENTER IN LAGUNA HILLS.
I AM CALLING FOR A- THE REQUEST
FOR SIXTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION IN ONE TIME STATE
FUNDING TO CREATE THE BRIDGE TO
RECOVERY. ADULT DAY SERVICES. IN
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM FUNDING WILL HELP YOU TO
BE ONGOING EXPENSIVE BUT
NECESSARY SAFETY UPGRADES
RELATED TO. IN OUR HUGE EXPENSE
AND BURDEN AFTER WE. NINETEEN
HUNDRED COUNTED ON US AND THEY
ARE PARTICIPANTS ARE DYING TO
COME BACK AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STAFF AND OUR
PARTICIPANTS ARE SAFE AND
PROTECTED SO WE HAVE TO TAKE THE
NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S THE CASE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER Q.
SEVENTY SEVEN. HELLO. HI I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF APPEAL FOR
HELP IN SUPPORT OF THE EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT CENTER ADMIN
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL REVERT TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE TWELVE THAT'S FINE
AND THE THREE TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KELLY YEAH
BUT THE G. AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CENTRAL VALLEY
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE. AND I'M CALLING
AND STRONGLY WHAT DOES- THE
FOLLOWING. ITEMS HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE ONE. ENHANCE
ENHANCING DATA COLLECTION TO
IMPROVE HEALTH. OUTCOMES MEDIC
CALLED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION COMMUNITY
HEALTH NAVIGATORS. OUT FOR ALL
ORIGINATED PATIENT. ARE ALL
CALIFORNIA LEGAL SO. AND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CENTER WORK
FOR STRING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MY MANAGER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. IT WILL ROLL TO
THE LINE OF THREE CANNOT FIND
NUMBER THREE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S JOANNA HAIGH WOOD
WITH NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE FULL AND THE
EPIDEMIC PROPOSAL BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE HEALTH EQUITY
IN HARM REDUCTION INITIATIVES
WILL HARM REDUCTION IS A
LONGSTANDING EFFECTIVE AND
EVIDENCE BASED PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTION THE STATE'S CURRENT
INVESTMENT AND HARM REDUCTION
SERVICES IS NOT COMMENSURATE
WITH THEIR ROLE IN THE DRUG USER
HEALTH CARE CONTINUE ON.
CALIFORNIA REDUCTION PROGRAMS
HAVE AN AVERAGE ANNUAL BUDGET OF
ONLY THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND BOTH OPERATE PART TIME
AND TWENTY TWO COUNTY STILL HAVE
NO PROGRAM AT ALL. BOTH
CALIFORNIA HAVE COME A LONG WAY
IN EXPANDING ACCESS TO
MEDICATION FOR OPIOID USE
DISORDER NORTH BEING INVESTMENT
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER FROM
THE STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OVERDOSES CONTINUE TO RISE DRUG
USE TRENDS HAVE SHIFTED. AND WE
URGENTLY NEED EQUAL INVESTMENT
IN COMPLEMENTARY LOW BARRIER
SERVICES. PROVIDED BY HARM
REDUCTION PROGRAM WITHOUT THEM
OVERDOSE DEATHS WILL CONTINUE TO
RISE RACHEL AND HEALTH EQUITY SO
MUCH FOR YOUR. CALL TODAY TIME
IS UP NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
WE HAVE BY NUMBER THREE TWENTY
THAT BY NUMBER THREE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JIM ROGERS SORRY I WILL LEAD A
GROUP. AND WE CONTROL TWO SMALL
GRASS ROOTS NONPROFITS. THAT DO
MANY OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND
WHICH IS A UNIQUE. WORLD FARM
THAT. WOULD DEDICATE NO LESS
THAN A HUNDRED MILLION- TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THESE PEOPLE
DO GREAT WORK- AND HISTORICALLY
HAVE BEEN- UNDER RESOURCE AND
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BALANCE THE SCALES OF DEBT AND
HAVE MORE EQUITABLE FUNDING. FOR
THE SMALL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION- THAT SERVED UNDER
RESOURCE AND UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES- THANK YOU AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. YOU HAVE
MY NUMBER THREE. THREE SEVENTEEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE THAT BIRDS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMBAT
BUT IT IS TABLET YOU LIVE
DIRECTLY WITH CALIFORNIA FAMILY
LIFE CENTER WE ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE APPROPRIATE
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE THE AGENDA
PAGE THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY WHAT.
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT TO FULLY
FUND KOLHAPUR AT THAT BASE FOR
THE NEXT TWO YEARS THE FOSTER
CHILDREN THAT ENTIRE SYSTEM WITH
PROBLEM TO HAVE STABILITY WITH
SOCIAL WORKERS IS PARAMOUNT TO
BEGIN THEIR HEALING PROCESS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND I
HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR HOW
MANY MORE COLORS DO WE HAVE TO
WISH ME HAPPY BIRTHDAY TODAY. WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVENTEEN CALLERS IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU HERE WE GO.
CURRENTLY MY NUMBER THREE TWENTY
TWO. OKAY. HELLO AT THREE TWENTY
FOUR. HELLO MADAM CHAIR. HELLO
FROM CHILDREN'S BUREAU FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY PROGRAM MANAGER
REQUESTING SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE PROPOSAL
TWENTY EIGHT PAGE THIRTY ONE FOR
THE INVESTMENT PLANS TO PROVIDE
A CALL UP TO SUPPORT THE CHILD
PLACEMENT RTE THAT GOES TO
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY PROGRAMS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS DEVELOP AND SUPPORT
RESOURCE FAMILIES SO THEY HAVE
THE SKILLS TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO FOSTER CHILDREN
WITH FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES ARE
UNDERFUNDED IT INCREASES SOCIAL
WORKER TURNOVER AND REDUCES
PERMANENCY OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN. THE TWO YOUR CALL WILL
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAME CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER. THREE TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GET A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HEALTH EQUITY RESEARCH
JUSTICE ONE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
DIRECT SUPPORT TO THE BASIC
INNOVATION CONNECTING TRUMP
ORGANIZATION. THESE LOCAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS IDENTIFY THE MOST
PRESSING HEALTH INEQUITIES AND
RACIAL INJUSTICE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND DEVELOP
EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
THEM CALIFORNIA DEPENDED ON CBO
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO HELP STEM THE
SPREAD OF COURT NINETEEN THE
OUTREACH EDUCATION INCREASING
ACCESS TO GOOD MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND MORE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HAVE A DEEP
AND UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
REPUBLIC OF HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
RESTRAINT OF THE- AND THE
COMMUNITIES. ARE NOT APPARENT
AND IT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT THAN
THEY ARE AT THAT PARTICULAR FACT
OF CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE SOLUTIONS OF THE
CONDITION IN ANOTHER YEAR OF
HISTORIC BUDGET THE FUNDS IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING FOR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN THE
GOVERNMENT JACK GRUBER NURSE
JANUARY TWENTY THANK YOU BUT YOU
COULD. WITH IMPORTANT ONGOING
COMMITMENT NEEDS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION TO THE HEALTH EQUITY
RATIOS OF THE FUND'S SUPPORT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CONNECT IN TROUBLE AGAIN STATION
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO IMPROVING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ADDRESS HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND RACIAL INJUSTICES
INCLUDES DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR
FOR GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL. TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE A LINE ONE. IN LINE.
NINE HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ROBERT RITCHIE IT'S A FOR RE
UNPAID FIVE WHICH PROVIDES
SCHOLARS FOR BOTH DICK MEDICINE
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AND HELP THE ONE COACH
. GOOD INTEREST WITH THE
CHARACTERISTIC UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IRVINE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FOR THE SUSAN SAMUELI
INTEGRATIVE HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
ASSISTANT DEAN IN THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE- I ALSO DIRECT BOTH
AFOREMENTIONED EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS USE THE
TIME TESTED TRAIN NEW TRAINERS
EDUCATION MODEL TO INCREASE AND
OPTIMIZE THE BEHAVIORAL AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIA WE'RE
EXCITED TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE GOING FORWARD TO
PROVIDE INNOVATIVE TRAINING
DESIGNED TO HELP MORE TEAM BASED
BOOTS ON THE GROUND HERE AND
ADDRESSED GROWING NEEDS IN THE
AREA OF OPIOID MANAGEMENT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS CAN BE
EVER HELP HERE I ALSO WANT TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT OF
DAMAGE THAT THE NAPPY BUDGET
REQUEST THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE MY NUMBER. THREE
FOURTEEN. PAULO A MEMBER OF
PASADENA VILLAGE IN LA COUNTY.
I'M VOICING SUPPORT FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAM FOR VILLAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE REMINDING YOU
THAT THERE WASN'T SUPPORT OLDER
ADULTS WHO LIVED TO AGE IN THEIR
OWN HOME I'M REQUESTING IT TO
INCLUDE THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
A LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY EIGHT
THEY THOUGHT THAT. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND SENATE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE I'M DOCTOR LAURA HIGH
INTENSITY- AT STANFORD SHE
ARGUES AND FAMILIES WE PROVIDE
FOSTER CARE ADOPTIONS MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT TO
YOUTH AND FAMILIES ACROSSTHE
CHAKRAM IN A REGION I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE COLON FOR FFA- I
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE FOSTER
YOUTH HAVE BEEN NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED WHEN THEIR SPECIFIC
SOCIAL WORKER. LISA AND IT'S
ANOTHER ABANDONMENT AND
INSTALLED PERMANENT G. AS YOU'VE
SEEN IN THE FACT SHEET THE PRINT
IS PROVIDED FOR YOU. OUR FOSTER
YOUTH WHICH OUR OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ONCE THEY ENTER
THE SYSTEM DESERVES THE BEST
POSSIBLE SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
THE REAL LIFE PERMANENT SEATS AS
THEY GET THE BEST CHANCE
POSSIBLE TO DRIVE. THAT IS NOT
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND SOCIAL
WORKERS LEAVES AND SOCIAL
WORKERS LEAVE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THEIR OWN FAMILIES SO I
ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT INVESTING
IN OUR FOSTER USED TO IMPROVE
THEIR OUTCOMES. I ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND FUNDING
RESOURCE CENTERS AND THEIR
SECURITY KEYS. AND THEN I HAVE A
REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLOR. WE HAVE A LINE
THREE THIRD NINE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WHATEVER
YOU NEED TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT A NONPROFIT CLINIC THAT
MOMENTUM IN IMPLEMENTATION MANY
POLITICAL FIGURE AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT
HEALTH POINT OUT THAT THAT MAKE
IT I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
MORE THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS YEAH
NOT BY THE PUMP BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T HELP BUT HAVE NOT THAT IT
COULD HAVE BEEN MAKING CLEAR THE
FINANCIAL DAMAGES THAT WOULD
COME TO HELP INTERCONNECT AGENT.
COULD TRANSITION. WILL BE
PARTIAL IN A PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT WILL LIVE AT THE
PARTY DATING INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION HEALTH EDUCATION
CASE MANAGEMENT OUTREACH PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY A HELPING ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA REPORTED THAT YOU MAY
NEED TO CLOSE YOUR PHARMACY WITH
DEFENSES UNDER NINETY THOUSAND
PRESCRIPTIONS WITH NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND PATIENTS ANNUALLY.
HUNDREDS OF EVERY CLASS HAD
CRACKED AND HALF THE ELIGIBLE
PATIENTS OTHER HEALTH IN THE BAY
AREA BUT THEY HAVEN'T CALLED HER
IN HER APARTMENT YEAH WELL WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S PART THE PART OF
THE NON HOSPITAL CLINIC FROM AN
OPINION POLL WHICH WAS CREATED
TO HELP HELPING TO MITIGATE THE
LOSSES INCURRED BY MEDICAL RACK.
FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED HERE
WERE QUITE DOUBLING THE FIND OUT
WHO HUNDRED FIVE MILLION FOR A
NEW FIFTY MILLION GET OFF ON IT
THANK YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THEIR NEXT. IF I NEVER
THREE. LINE OF THREE FOR. THREE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
YEAH THE DIRECTOR PROGRAMS THAT
PARENTS THIS IS A CALL TO MEET
YOU TODAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAME
SHE- THE CALIFORNIA YOU HELL
LINE AND ONLINE PARENTS GROUPS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING VITAL
CULTURE RISK. MODE SUPPORT FOR
DIVERSE PARENTS CHILDREN AND YOU
IN OFFICE EIGHT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. GOOD PARENTS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WERE SUDDENLY THROWN
INTO CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CREATED
ANXIETY FEAR WORRYING AND
SECURITY AND THE NEED FOR
PARENTS ANONYMOUS GROUPS AND THE
CALIFORNIA PARENTS NEED HELP
LINE IS CRITICAL. GIVEN THAT I
AM URGING THE COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN ADDITION TO
THAT WHAT IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. TO CONTINUE THE CRUCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT. FIVE YOUNG.
PARENTS GET. ONLINE NOT THIS
GROUP. THE FIRST FAMILY THAT
STATE NEED ACCESS EVIDENCE
EMOTIONAL NOW MORE THAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO CALIFORNIA PARENTS
WHO RAISING THREE NINE POINT
THREE MILLION CHILDREN. THANK
YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER THREE FORTY ONE THAT'S
FINE NUMBER THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS PATRICK BROWN AND THE
PORT NUMBER FOR QUERY VILLAGE IN
REDWOOD CITY. I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LEECH MOVEMENT
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THEIR PILOT PROGRAM RELIGION TO
STRUCTURE PROPOSAL AND I ASKED
THE SENATE TO INCLUDE IN ITS
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER THREE FORTY
FIVE ONE NUMBER THREE FOUR FIVE
. HI THERE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SPEAKING AROUND THE LONG RUN
YOUR BIRTHDAY TO GIVE EVERYONE A
CHANCE PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
YEAH MANY BELIEVE SOME OF THE
TALLY WITH DEFEAT AT THE ROUND
TABLE I'M BACK MY ORGANIZATION
AND THE THREE THOUSAND CLASSROOM
PROGRAM OPERATORS THAT WE WORK
WITH AND TRYING TO GAIN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF GOOD WITH CAREFREE
NIELSEN CAN INCREASE ON CHILD
CARE BUT ENDEMIC EXPOSE THE
WEAKNESS WITH THEM AND WIDEN THE
GAPS IN OUR- AD CHILD CARE
SYSTEM WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
EXACERBATED FOOD INSECURITY
AMONG HOUSEHOLDS WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
HAVE HAD TO SCRAMBLE TO BE EVEN
HUNGRIER CAN'T ALL AFTER GOING
WITH INCREASING CONTRACT LIMITED. SUPPLIES THANK YOU. WHAT
ADEQUATE MY IN SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM BUT TO FILL THE GAP IN
ACCESS HEALTHY YOU KNOW AND
CHILD CARE. WELL I'M SUPPORTING
THE BRING IT STABILITY THE WORK
FOR. WE LOOK FORWARD WORKING
WITH THE LECTURE. CAN OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS RECEIVE THE
NUTRITION I NEED. AN ACCOUNT
CARE PROVIDER. IT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY Q. ONE FORTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
WOMAN AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY- AS
WELL TO THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
DOCTOR LEE SUPPLIER BILL IN THE
PRESIDENCY OF PARENTS ANONYMOUS.
I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
SUPPORTING THE FIRST RESPONDER
SYSTEM WE CREATED TWO YEARS AGO
SO THE PARENTS COULD REACH OUT
AND YOU COULD REACH OUT DURING
THESE TROUBLING TIMES AND ASKED
FOR HELP WITHOUT THE BLAME AND
SHAME ASSOCIATED WITH I NEED TO
TALK TO SOMEBODY I FEELING
ISOLATED. WHO'S NOT FEELING
ANXIETY FEAR EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
ENDING A PANDEMIC HOPEFULLY A
MOVING INTO AN ENDEMIC THE
CONCERNS ABOUT SENDING MY CHILD
TO SCHOOL IS THE MASCOT FOR NOT.
THIS SUPPORT NETWORK DIDN'T
EXIST BEFORE APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN PARENTS ANONYMOUS LUNCHEON
AND WE'RE ASKING YOU TO JUST
INVEST A DOLLAR THIRTY SEVEN PER
CHILD IN THE STATE THAT'S NOT
EVEN A CUP OF COFFEE TODAY. TO
CONTINUE. TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
SOMEBODY ON THE OTHER LINE
CARING COUNSELOR TO PROVIDE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND FREE
ONGOING EVIDENCE BASED ENGLAND
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL TODAY
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE THE
RIGHT NUMBER THREE FIFTEEN MY
NUMBER THREE FIFTY. THANK YOU
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DAVE LEVINE ON BEHALF OF
THE HELP OF ONE OF THE TOP ONE
YEAH. NOT THE CLINIC THAT WORK
IN THE MORNING TO OUR THOUSAND
PATIENTS PER MEMBER HEALTH
MINISTER. CALIFORNIA I'M GOING
TO INSTRUCT SUPPORT A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ADVOCATES WHO SPONSORED
PROPOSAL- I'M FIRST YOU. WALKING
PACE REQUEST. WE BELIEVE THAT
WITHOUT THE AUGMENTATION
IMPORTANT HEALTH SERVICES ARE AT
RISK IN A LITTLE COMMUNITY THAT
WE DO NOT WANT TO YOU KNOW
SERVICES REDUCED. SECOND WE
BELIEVE THE TARGET HEALTH
WORKFORCE FUNDING THAT. HELPS
WITH THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
PROPOSED IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE WORSENING WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE. ESPECIALLY IN OUR
LITTLE COMMUNITY. THE SHORTAGE
EXISTED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
IT'S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE. BUT
AFTER POSTPONING IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. AGAIN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
YOU HAVE MY NUMBER.THREE TWO
ONE THREE THREE ONE. HI HARRY
PULL FROM- POWERPOINT A SERVICE
PROVIDER IN THE CENTRAL COAST
FOR IT SERVICES SPEAKING ON THE
PDF PROPOSALS FOR YOU STRONG
PROPONENT OF THE LANTERN
COALITIONS TO PROPOSALS WE HAVE
A WORKFORCE CRISIS WERE NOT ABLE
TO SUPPORT. THE PEOPLE IN OUR
SERVICES EXONERATING THE RATE
STUDY FROM TWENTY NINETEEN WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TO LETTING US HIRE
ENOUGH STAFF TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND THE SECOND OPPOSE IT WOULD
CLEAN UP THE RATE STUDY.
LEMONADE RECESSION ERA CUTS ON
HALF THE BILLING AND PROVIDE
ONGOING. UPDATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S NOT ENOUGH
POSITION THAT AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT PARKER PROPOSAL FOR
FIXING UP FOR STAFFING FORMULA
AND THE FAMILY SHE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. PROVIDE. THREE FIFTY
THREE FIFTY TWO. HELLO THIS IS
WAYNE APRIL I'M A MEMBER OF THE
PASADENA VILLAGE. AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM FOR VILLAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO I'M ASKING
THE SENATE TO- TAKE A TINY SLICE
OF THE STATE'S SURPLUS. WITH THE
PROJECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER THREE FIFTY
THREE THEY THOUGHT HAD. HELLO
I'M KATIE BRANDON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR PASSING THE VILLAGE TO
A ALONG WITH WAY IN APRIL AND
MEMBERS OF THE VILLAGE MOVEMENT
CALIFORNIA A STATE COALITION OF
FORTY FOUR VILLAGES AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT I'M ALSO CALLING TO
SUPPORTTHE PILOT PROGRAM FOR
VILLAGE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
SUPPORT OLDER ADULTS IN THE
FORGOTTEN MIDDLE WHO NEEDS A
SOCIAL CONNECTION SUPPORT AND
CONNECTIONS TO RESOURCES SO THAT
THEY CAN AGE IN PLACE WITH GREAT
GRACE AND DIGNITY AND SELF
DETERMINATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ONE TIME INVESTMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS CALLER PLEASE
. WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO SIX
EIGHT SIX- BUT WE COULD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANIELLE
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
INTEGRATED RESOURCES THAT YOU
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PEOPLE
SUPPORTING EMPLOYMENT- I'M
CALLING TODAY TO OPPOSE THE
DELAY OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE F. B. SIXTY NINE. WHICH CAN
BE FOUND ON PAGE TWENTY FIVE
FURTHER DELAYING THE PRACTICE OF
PAYING PEOPLE LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE FURTHER EXTENDS THE
EXPLOITATION OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WE BELIEVE THAT
PAYING PEOPLE LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE TREAT PEOPLE LIKE THEY ARE
LEFT THAT. LET THE END OF THE
DAY OUR CAKE PRACTICE AND
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THE POST
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY MADAME
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
COLOR PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS MINE
WINDOW I AM THE POLICY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COURAGE
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR FULLY
FUNDING THE PROVISIONS OF SB
FIFTY FIVE EDITION WHICH CREATED
THESE ACCURATE PICTURE PRETTY
CRITICAL INTERVENTIONS NEEDED TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THE
MATERNAL AND INFANT MORTALITY
AND MORBIDITY CRISIS IN OUR
STATE. HE'S REALLY FUNNY
PROVISIONS OF AN INVESTMENT
TOWARD BUILDING CALIFORNIA'S
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC DISPARITIES
IN BIRTH OUTCOMES THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER THREE SIXTY
ONE LINE THREE SIXTY ONE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON REASONABLY JR ON
BEHALF OF THE PSYCHIATRIC
CITIZENS ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
JOINT PROPOSAL FOR TRAILER
BELLINGER'S RELATED TO IMPROVING
ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES MAY
EXPERIENCE MENTAL ILLNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
COLOR PLEASE. I DON'T CARE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYMORE IN QUEUE FOR
COMMENT ON. ARE YOU SURE THANK
YOU CAN YOU TELL ME HOW MANY
CALLS WE HAD TODAY. HOW MANY
COLORS IT LOOKS LIKE I SOLD
THIRTY ONE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE.
THIRTY FIVE TOTAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME END I WILL SAY IF
YOU DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO CALL
IN WE STILL WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU AND PLEASE REACH OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE- BUT THAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR BUDGET SHOP THREE
FOR TODAY. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.